Pogge, Sleep, Bettke, aus dem Bettke, Captain Poggers ist am Start, 22 Monate für den Zap, so, Lautstärke passt, man weiß ja nie, was Windows damals so umgestellt hat, Windows Logik ist ja unergründlich, ein Headset hängt,
weil es einen Knoten im Kabel hat, oder was, was so aussieht wie ein Knoten, was wahrscheinlich kein Knoten ist, weil ich keinen Knoten reingemacht habe, weil es ähnlich wie das Kabel schaffen, sich so sehr zu verknoten, ohne dass man was macht, ja, letzten Montag, ja, alles wieder gut, Corona ist vorbei, würde ich sagen, Corona ist vorbei, hat sich erledigt, dafür habe ich jetzt was Neues, mein Auto ist kaputt,
Leute, mein Agila ist kaputt, also ich meine, er fährt noch, aber ich weiß nicht mal, wie lange, und, also, für alle, die es nicht wissen, ich habe ja ein, ich habe dieses Ding hier, in grün, das ist quasi ein Auto, das ist jetzt irgendwie, das ist 20 Jahre alt, oder so, das ist zu alt, man, zumindest, das hat jetzt, hat jetzt endlich, ich fahre ja nicht viel, ne,
also wisst ihr ja,
ich bin ja im Prinzip so gut wie nie unterwegs, und, also mit dem Auto, und, der hat jetzt in letzter Zeit schon öfters Probleme gehabt, also angefangen von, dass das, ein Licht beim Zurückfahren nicht funktioniert, auf der einen Seite, dann, was war letztens, ich habe es schon wieder ganz vergessen,
war dann letztens nochmal, letztens ging, genau, letztens ging irgendwie nicht richtig an, und jetzt war das,
dieses System für das, wie nennt sich das, Kühlmittel, Kühlsystem, undicht, und, das Ding hat immer mehr, das ist, das ist komplett, komplett am abkacken, genau, so, und ich dachte mir jetzt, weißt du was, easy, komm, es wird mal Zeit, du musst, du musst dir eh mal ein neues Auto kaufen, ja, also habe ich mal nach kleinen Elektroautos geguckt, und, da bin ich dann auf dieses Ding gekommen, da habe ich mir gedacht, das passt eigentlich ganz gut,
das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist
Ich will keine 39.000 Euro ausgeben.
Also, ich will keine 39.000 Euro ausgeben für ein Auto.
So, und es gibt noch bis nächstes Jahr, gibt es noch eine Förder-Innovations-Umwelt-Prämie, fragt mich nicht, wie das genau heißt.
Und da kriegt man bis zu 9.000 Euro quasi obendrauf.
Also sprich, irgendwie 3.000 Euro vom Hersteller und irgendwie 6.000 Euro, die man nochmal beantragen kann.
Der Haken dabei ist, wenn ihr euch jetzt, oder wenn ich mir jetzt ein Elektroauto bestelle, dann dauert das, na mit Leasing hast du wieder andere Probleme.
Da musst du dir dann über jeden Huppel, den du fährst, Gedanken machen.
Oder über jeden noch so kleinen Hauch eines Kratzers Gedanken machen, dass du es am Ende nicht alles drauf bezahlen darfst.
Und das Übernehmen am Ende ist auch nicht so billig.
Das muss man wirklich genau rechnen, ob sich das lohnt.
Zumindest aktuell kriegst du 9.000 Euro Prämie für ein neues Elektroauto.
Was ziemlich gut ist.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, wenn das laut Hersteller 39.000 Euro kostet in der gescheiten Ausstattung.
Und man ein bisschen mit dem Händler labert.
Wahrscheinlich kriegt man es dann auch ein bisschen billiger.
Plus, Minus die 9.000 Euro Prämie.
Dann, was weiß ich, dann wahrscheinlich unter 30.000 Euro.
Und das wäre okay.
Das würde ich ausgeben dafür.
Aber nicht so einfach in Deutschland.
Weil diese Prämie, die du beantragen kannst, also die 9.000 Euro Prämie, die du bei neuen Elektroautos beantragen kannst, die gilt bloß noch bis Ende des Jahres.
Und du kannst diese Prämie beantragen, erst wenn du das Auto zugelassen hast.
Also nicht, wenn du das verbindlich bestellst, sondern wenn du das angemeldet hast und wenn du den Antrag eingereicht hast.
Also es reicht nicht, wenn du es einfach nur bestellst dieses Jahr.
Und ab nächstem Jahr, ich habe irgendwo auch ein Video zu aufgemacht, weil ich mir das nochmal genauer anhören wollte.
So und nächstes Jahr sinkt das ordentlich.
Dann ist es irgendwie nur noch die Hälfte.
Dann ist es nur noch 4.500 Euro oder so, anstatt 9.000 Euro.
Und das ist halt echt ziemlich für den Arsch.
Deswegen ist die Sache die, ich habe jetzt mal rumgeguckt und man kann bei Fiat auf der Seite suchen nach Händlern, die welche haben.
Allerdings sind das dann halt keine, die man sich komplett selbst zusammenstellen kann.
Also sprich, wenn du jetzt ein Auto kaufen willst, wo du sagst, ich will dieses Paket haben, ich will was, was ich, diese Felgen haben, ich will das haben, diese Farbe haben.
Dann müssen die das ja extra bestellen für dich.
Anmelden geht aber, musst halt die Karre haben.
Das ist ja das Problem.
Versuch, die Karre zu bekommen.
So, wobei ich jetzt gerade stehen geblieben bin.
Dann müssen die das bestellen aus Italien oder wo auch immer das gebaut wird.
Die Sache ist jetzt halt die, manchmal haben Händler noch Autos da, die halt fertig sind.
Ich weiß nicht, wo die herkommen, ob die irgendjemand nicht abgeholt hat oder so.
Aber ich habe jetzt über die Fiat Webseite mal geguckt.
Und so viele gibt es da nicht.
Letztendlich ist mir die Farbe egal.
Das Paket ist mir jetzt auch nicht so wichtig, was es ist.
Ja, mal gucken.
Also ich kann es euch insofern nur, ich kann es dir.
Die Dinger sind echt klein.
Du weißt, was ich aktuell habe, oder?
Und ich finde das gut, dass das so klein ist.
Die Abmaße von dem Fiat sind ungefähr, mehr oder weniger, genauso groß wie mein Alter.
Also, das sind ein paar Zentimeter, das nimmt sich nix.
Ich glaube, breit sind sie sogar exakt gleich breit.
So.
Ich, ich, ich will, ja, ja, wir machen demnächst was mit Avalon, ja.
Tja, da bin ich mal gespannt.
Also, wenn ich dieses Jahr noch die Chance habe, einen zu kriegen und auch so, sagen wir mal, so, ähm, in einem Zeitraum, dass ich das mit dem Antrag und so noch machen kann und die Förderung kriege.
Dann würde ich mir ein Elektroauto tatsächlich kaufen.
Und zwar den.
Und wenn das dieses Jahr nicht mehr funktioniert, wenn es da keine Chance gibt, dann kaufe ich mir kein Elektroauto.
Weil, wie gesagt, ich würde mir ja prinzipiell ganz gern eins kaufen, dann muss ich nicht mehr tanken fahren.
Und für meine Ministrecken, die ich fahre, ist das, ist das wunderbar.
Aber, wenn auch ein bisschen teuer, muss ich sagen, so wirklich rechnen tut sich das Ganze ja irgendwo nicht.
Aber trotzdem, dann würde ich das machen.
Aber nächstes Jahr würde ich es nicht mehr machen.
Also, ich gebe halt ungern Geld aus.
Und vor allem Unsinn.
Ich gebe nicht Geld aus.
Bin ich mal gespannt.
Die neue, ist das, ist das 11er, ist, ist, ist das 11er Avalonia nicht vor ein paar Tagen rausgekommen?
Habe ich irgendwo was auf Reddit gelesen, dass das angeblich jetzt raus ist?
Oder ist das eine Ankündigung, dass das demnächst rauskommt?
Ja, da bin ich nämlich interessant drauf.
Damit kannst du jetzt angeblich auch Android und iOS Anwendungen und, und, äh, Firefox WebOS Anwendungen und alle möglichen Geschäfte machen.
Ja, ja, ich werde auf jeden Fall die neueste Version ausprobieren.
Hehehe.
Ich habe gerade mal geguckt, was das ist.
Das ist irgendwie so ein riesen Traktor.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was die machen.
Wahrscheinlich ist es unter der Haube ein Browser oder so.
Zweifelsfall sind die meisten Mobile Anwendungen heute Browser.
Tja.
Ja, ich bin mal gespannt, ob das klappt dieses Jahr mit Elektroauto.
Wie gesagt, wenn nicht, dann nicht.
Und dann kaufe ich mir halt keins.
Weil, wie gesagt, 40.000 Euro gebe ich dafür nicht aus.
So, ein bisschen unter 30.000 mit Förderung ist okay, aber, ne, 40.000 Euro gebe ich dafür nicht aus.
Moin.
Ab und zu funktionieren einfach alle Erweiterungen.
Das Problem ist mir nicht bekannt, das kenne ich nicht.
Also, bei mir funktionieren die Erweiterungen immer.
Ich glaube, ihr habt noch nicht einen Stream gesehen, wo ich Chrome aufgemacht habe.
Und, äh, da ging die Erweiterung nicht.
Musik ein Stückchen leiser.
So.
Der Graf Alexander hat subscribt.
Subscribed.
Massive Subscription.
Möb auch.
Dankeschön, Leute, hier.
Captain Peng, Captain Poggas ist auch wieder am Start.
Ob Chrome da neu installieren hilft, weiß ich nicht.
Vielleicht hast du das Problem, dass du Erweiterungen installierst, die da, äh, die Google aus dem Shop nimmt, weil sie irgendwelche dubiosen Sachen enthalten.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich bekomme was.
Ja, ich bekomme die Hälfte.
Das lohnt sich nicht wirklich zu subscriben.
Das, also, natürlich unterm Strich für mich schon.
Aber von dem Anteil her lohnt sich.
Irgendwie nicht wirklich.
Wenn man sich überlegt, eigentlich, eigentlich bezahlt sich Bezos mit Prime-Subs ja selbst zur Hälfte.
Oder besser gesagt, er muss, ja, eigentlich hat er das Geld ja schon.
Nee, eigentlich lohnt sich doch.
Prime-Subs, ich, ich, Leute, ich, ich, ich ziehe das zurück, was ich gesagt habe und behaupte das Gegenteil.
Natürlich lohnt sich's, weil der hat ja das Geld schon.
Und jetzt muss er ein bisschen was rausrücken.
Also, ist gut.
Alle, alle Prime-Subben, die können.
Pog.
Aber ich freue mich auch, dass ihr da seid.
Muss sich keiner hier irgendwelche...
...Subs aus den Fingern saugen.
Es sei denn, ihr habt Prime-Subs offen und wisst nicht, wohin.
Dann freue ich mich natürlich drüber.
Der Hype-Trainer.
Mal gucken, ob wir den schaffen.
Wir hatten letztens mal Hype-Train Level 5, der dann bei 100% war und irgendwie auch durchgelaufen ist.
Und uns richtig gebetet hat, weil der einfach nicht aufgehört hat bei 100%.
Oder beim, beim, am Ende der Zeit irgendwie ganz komisch.
Pfeifert.
Aber du kannst doch nur maximal 5 vermitteln.
Du kannst doch nur mal 5 vermitteln, oder?
Kann man, kann man im Amazon-Familien-Account auch wieder Leute ausladen?
Also, meine Familie wechselt halt einmal im Monat.
Nein, wir wollen uns ja hier keine Amazon-Skamas-Geschichten angucken.
Ja.
Ja, so, so viel zu meinem Elektro, Elektro-Auto suchen.
Nicht so einfach, wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe, alles.
Das Nächste, was ich gesehen habe...
Ja, bevor wir uns an ein paar Videos angucken.
Das Nächste, was ich gesehen habe, ist...
Wahrscheinlich habt ihr die Meldung auch gesehen.
Es gab hier bei...
Ich beheise.
Aber hier, Google, DDoS.
Ja, es gab ja wieder einen riesen DDoS-Angriff auf Google, die im Prinzip...
Wo ist der Link zu dem offiziellen Google-Blogpost?
Die eigentlich mittlerweile nur noch als Schwanzvergleich von den Cloud-Anbietern benutzt werden.
Achtung, Leute, Flashbang.
Also, mittlerweile gibt es ja total viele dieser Blogposts.
Microsoft macht solche Blogposts.
Wir haben den größten DDoS-Angriff aller Zeiten abgewährt.
Cloudflare macht solche Blogposts.
Und jetzt kommt Google um die Ecke.
Übrigens, wir haben auch den größten DDoS-Angriff aller Zeiten abgewährt.
Und wenn man das mal vergleicht...
Die überschlagen sich...
Die überschlagen sich ja alle.
Wie gesagt, Cloudflare postet den gleichen Krempel, ja.
In dem Fall bei Microsoft.
Die haben was zum größten Teil von...
Es war Anfang des Jahres.
Microsoft hat zum größten Teil was über UDP-Traffic geschrieben.
Google schreibt jetzt was über Layer-7-DDoS-Angriff.
Aber, was ich eigentlich ganz interessant finde, ist, wenn man sich mal anguckt, was für Ausmaße das mittlerweile annimmt.
Das ist schon nicht ohne.
Also, da muss man echt sagen, da geht was.
Aber, wie gesagt, diese ganzen Blogposts, das ist ja alles immer ziemlich...
Ja, Schwanzvergleich...
Cloudflare...
Äh...
Was, was ist...
Die schreiben genau das Gleiche in ihrem Blog, ja.
Guck hier.
Die schreiben genau das Gleiche.
Die größte DDoS aller Zeiten, bla bla bla.
Also, im Prinzip nimmt sich da Microsoft, Microsoft Google, Cloudflare, Amazon und, und, wenn es so alles gibt, da nicht viel.
Aber, ich finde es in dem Fall ganz interessant, was sie so schreiben.
Was ich wollte neulich...
Und da sind die...
Die Seite wird morgen noch vom BSI untersucht.
Die hatten wohl auch...
Das wundert mich bei der IHK nicht.
Die IHK ist ein riesen unfähiger Haufen an unfähigen Leuten, ja.
Also, wie gesagt, die haben es auch geschafft, mein Abschlussprojekt zu verlieren und dann zu sagen, ich hätte es nicht eingereicht.
Also, ich...
Den traue ich wirklich alles zu.
Mulfs, moin.
Also, IHK ist IHK.
Ich habe überlegt, ob ich dazu nicht ein Video machen soll, weil es gibt ein paar ganz interessante Sachen, was man dazu erzählen kann, zu diesem Bericht.
Ich meine, wie gesagt.
Zu 90% ist es Werbung, wie geil Google diesen DDoS-Angriff hier wieder vereitelt hat.
Aber ich finde, es sind ein paar ganz interessante Geschichten dabei.
Vielleicht habt ihr die Meldung auch gesehen, vor ein paar Tagen auf News-Seiten.
Wie gesagt, bei Heise steht es in den News und bei Golem stand es, glaube ich, auch.
Und bei den englischsprachigen Seiten und so gab es das auch alles, dass hier Google wieder irgendwie krasse DDoS-Hackermans abgewährt hat.
Zumindest gibt es ein paar Sachen, die ich ganz spannend daran finde.
Zum Beispiel, was ich ganz spannend daran finde, wenn man das mal vergleicht, das, was Microsoft schreibt und das, was Google schreibt,
dass die beide was schreiben von größte DDoS-Attacke aller Zeiten, aber es sich eigentlich auf komplett unterschiedliche Sachen bezieht.
Bei Google geht es um 46 Millionen Requests, also RPs, Requests pro Sekunde.
Und bei Microsoft geht es um UDP-Traffic und Packages pro Sekunde.
Also bei Microsoft geht es um 3,47 Terabit pro Sekunde und um 340 Millionen Packages pro Sekunde.
Was man daran sieht ist, dass Requests und Packages sich zwar ähnlich anhören, aber, tja, was ziemlich unterschiedliche sind.
Weil, das sieht man ja schon in Größenordnung, ja.
Hier ist das größte 46 Millionen Requests und hier ist das größte 360, irgendwie was, was, 340 Millionen Packages.
Ist ja auch logisch.
Hier geht es ja auch um UDP-Traffic und hier geht es um Layer 7 Traffic.
Wobei man halt sagen muss, Layer 7 Traffic, also Layer 7 ist immer so ein bisschen, ja, schwammig irgendwie.
Zumindest bei den ganzen DDoS-Geschichten, wo Microsoft drüber geschrieben hat, ging es ja darum,
möglichst schnell dicht zu machen.
Und hier ging es darum, möglichst viel Traffic zu generieren und, ja, nach Möglichkeit auch Last auf den System zu generieren
und das möglichst nachhaltig kaputt zu machen.
Letztendlich geht es bei beidem halt darum, irgendwas auf dem Weg kaputt zu machen, dass der Service nicht mehr erreichbar ist.
Aber bei Microsoft ging es hauptsächlich darum, die Netzwerkinfrastruktur dicht zu machen, mit UDP-Traffic und massig Bandbreite.
Und hier ging es darum, ja, auch massig Bandbreite zu verursachen, aber die Systeme irgendwie anzugreifen und abzuschießen.
Ist ja auch was anderes, ja, das ist ja auch ein Layer 7 DDoS.
Wer hat aufgepasst, was ist Layer 7 im OSI-Modell, Leute?
Wer hat aufgepasst?
Ich meine, es ist eh ziemlich schwammig.
Das betrifft, ein Layer 7 Angriff betrifft natürlich auch alle Schichten unten drunter und es lässt sich eh nicht so ganz klar abgrenzen.
Layer 8, wissen wir, Layer 8 sind wir, die vom Bildschirm...
Ich meine, es gibt ja, es gibt ja verschiedenste Application, korrekt, genau.
Deswegen ist das hier, deswegen ist das hier ein Application Layer DDoS oder so, könnte man auch sagen.
Aber das ist alles, das ist alles irgendwie ein bisschen, bisschen schwammig.
Zumindest, es gibt ja verschiedenste Angriffsszenarien, was sowas angeht.
Ich labere jetzt einfach ein bisschen mal so vor mich hin, bevor wir uns mal Videos angucken, weil ich das Thema gerade hier im Vergleich relativ spannend finde.
Anwendung.
Ja, richtig.
Also, es gibt ja verschiedenste Angriffsszenarien.
Also, du hast solche Sachen, so die Klassiker, nenne ich es jetzt mal.
Sowas, wo du hier beispielsweise Traffic verursachen kannst, wo sich Microsoft drauf bezogen hat.
Du hast so die Klassiker, du hast sowas wie DNS Amplification oder NTP Amplification.
Weiß gar nicht, ob es da so schöne Bilder gibt.
Gucken wir mal, ob es da so schöne Bilder gibt.
Ja, das sieht doch...
Okay, das ist...
Das ist ein ziemlich hässliches Bild.
Aber ich glaube, da erkennt man eigentlich ganz gut, woran es darum geht.
Also, zumindest sowas wie DNS Amplification war in der Vergangenheit relativ beliebt.
Warum?
Na ja, weil du selbst als Angreifer nicht viel machen musst.
Du schickst an einen DNS-Server Anfragen und fälschst die Absenderadresse.
So.
Und dann antwortet der DNS-Server, also du setzt die Absenderadresse desjenigen ein, den du angreifen willst.
Und dann schickst du das mit der gefälschten Absenderadresse an den DNS-Server.
Okay.
Und der DNS-Server antwortet dann demjenigen, den du angreifen willst, der eigentlich gar nicht angefragt hat.
Und wenn du das ganz oft machst an ganz viele DNS-Server, ist es für dich relativ geringer Aufwand, DNS-Anfragen rauszuschicken.
Steht ja auch hier.
Eine 60-Byte-lange Anfrage kann in bestimmten Fällen eine 300-Byte-lange Antwort provozieren.
Also sprich, du passt selbst relativ wenig Aufwand und kannst ordentlich Traffic verursachen.
Das ist NTP, NTP Amplifier ist relativ ähnlich.
Da machst du es mit NTP.
Das war so in der Vergangenheit relativ beliebt.
Aber das ist in letzter Zeit, in letzter Zeit ist das ein bisschen außer Mode gekommen, habe ich so den Eindruck.
Ja, ich denke mal, ich denke mal, das liegt zum größten Teil daran, weil sich größere Cloud-Anbieter und Hoster so ein bisschen drauf eingestellt haben.
Weil die auch nicht blöd sind, weil die das Ganze auch beobachten.
Und ich meine, wenn jetzt auf einmal ein Web-Server...
Ungefragt Terabyte-weise DNS-Traffic bekommt, könnte man sich schon überlegen, dass ist das irgendwie, das scheint wahrscheinlich was nicht so ganz zu stimmen, oder?
Und ich denke mal, das dürften die Systeme bei den Cloud-Anbietern und Hoster mittlerweile relativ gut und relativ schnell erkennen.
Natürlich lassen die sich das auch ordentlich bezahlen, das darf man auch nicht dazu sagen.
Äh, muss man auch dazu sagen.
Also, so DDoS-Protection ist nicht, ist nicht ganz billig.
Ja, Chad, ihr habt recht.
TCP-Sessions-Spam ist auch relativ beliebt.
Ja.
Also, da macht man ganz viele TCP-Anfragen und beantwortet die halt nicht.
Man schickt die mit gefälschter Absenderadresse hin, lässt die offen und hofft halt, dass dann irgendwann das System vollläuft.
Das funktioniert heute auch nicht mehr wirklich so gut, weil es ist halt alles besser geworden.
Also, Netzwerkgeräte sind besser geworden, Server-Software ist besser geworden.
Beispielsweise werden heute einfach TCP-Verbindungen, die nur so halb geöffnet wurden, also wo es so einen Synge gibt,
einfach wiederverwendet und dementsprechend kriegst du die Systeme gar nicht mehr wirklich voll gespammt mit neuen TCP-Sessions.
Es gibt, es gibt jede Menge.
Es gibt jede Menge Sachen.
Zumindest die Schutzmaßnahmen lassen sich die Cloud-Anbieter ordentlich bezahlen.
Keine Ahnung, was so Web-Application-Geschichten kosten, aber es ist auf jeden Fall nicht billig.
Könnten wir eigentlich gleich mal ausrechnen.
Wir gucken gleich mal bei Google, gucken gleich mal bei Google in die Preistabelle und gucken, wie das, was das alles so gekostet hat.
Aber so diese klassische Sache mit, wir machen einfach nur möglichst viel Traffic, so hirnlos Traffic, Traffic-Spam,
das können Cloudflare, Google, Microsoft und so eigentlich ganz gut, ganz gut handeln mittlerweile.
Also, wie gesagt, ich denke, in Zukunft werden wir mehr solcher Sachen sehen und weniger so hirnloses Traffic-Gespamme, nenne ich es jetzt mal.
Weil das, weil das wahrscheinlich immer weniger zum Ziel führt.
Und die Cloud-Anbieter ja mittlerweile auch, wenn man sich das hier mal anguckt,
riesen Bandbreiten so für Spitzenlast-Zeiten haben.
Also das musst du erstmal voll DDoS'en, das kostet dich natürlich auch ein bisschen was als Angreifer.
Also so einfach ist das nicht.
Glücklicherweise, glücklicherweise ist es mittlerweile so, dass du dich nicht mal als Angreifer drauf verlassen musst,
dass es irgendwie ein Botnetz aus ollen, verseuchten, virenverseuchten Desktop-Systeme gibt.
Glücklicherweise sind wir im IoT-Zeitalter angelangt.
Das heißt, an solchen DDoS-Attacken können sich heute natürlich auch Glühbirnenautos,
Kühlschränke, Smartphones, äh, veraltete Netzwerkgeräte und Klos beteiligen.
Also, es sind nicht mehr nur alte Desktop-Rechner, ja?
Mittlerweile sind wir weiter. Mittlerweile kann die Glühbirne mit DDoS'en.
Aber zumindest muss man halt sagen, der Unterschied zwischen dem...
Natürlich, Klo kann auch DDoS'en. Klo im WLAN, alte Firmware, irgendwas, das kann alles passieren.
Mich würd's nicht wundern, wenn an solchen DDoS-Angriffen nicht auch mittlerweile smarte Klos beteiligt waren und smarte Toaster.
Und smarte Kühlschränke und Autos und alles mögliche. Kannste alles mittlerweile knicken.
Zum größten Teil werden's natürlich immer noch Desktop-PCs sein, ungesicherte Netzwerkgeräte, äh, nicht geupdatete Smartphones und sowas.
Aber, dass dein Toaster an irgendeinem Microsoft-DDoS beteiligt war, ist gar nicht so unwahrscheinlich im Jahr 2022.
Das kommt, ja, Isa, das kommt noch dabei.
Im IoT-Bereich, gerade die China-Chinesen-Hersteller, die juckt das zum größten Teil mal gar nicht, ob ihr Zeug gepatcht ist oder ob das überhaupt von Haus aus sieht.
Die juckt das zum größten Teil mal gar nicht, ob ihr Zeug gepatcht ist oder ob das überhaupt von Haus aus sieht.
Und gerade bei, ähm, IoT-Geräten, die halt rein über die Cloud gesteuert werden, permanent eine Verbindung haben, also den Dingern traue ich ja prinzipiell nicht über den Weg.
Deswegen habe ich auch ein eigenes WLAN, äh, eigenes WLAN, wo das alles reinkommt, die nirgendswohin dürfen, wenn ich's nicht flashen kann.
Und selbst die geflashten Sachen kommen da rein.
Tja, was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Aber wie gesagt, hier ging's ja nicht um reinen, um reinen Traffic-Spam, sondern hier ging's um Layer 7 DDoS, also sprich, ähm, wahrscheinlich war den Angreifern hier bei dieser Google-Geschichte auch klar,
ja, hirnlos Traffic spammen führt wahrscheinlich nicht zum gewünschten Ziel und bei dem Angriff waren das Requests über HTTPS.
Und Requests über HTTPS sind natürlich für beide Seiten schwieriger, na, das ist mehr Aufwand.
Na, das ist mehr Aufwand.
Beim, beim Angreifer, ich meine, du musst HTTPS-Verbindungen machen, du musst TLS-Handshakes machen, alles mögliche, dass du dann ein Request schicken kannst.
Es ist natürlich auch schwieriger zu erkennen, so einen, so einen, gerade über HTTPS Layer 7 DDoS, das ist natürlich auch schwieriger zu erkennen.
Ähm, das liegt zuerst mal daran, also, zum, was ist denn das hier, warum kann ich meine Emotes nicht richtig anzeigen?
Ähm, ja, das, das liegt, das liegt zum, das liegt einmal daran,
dass jetzt hier der Angreifer seine Absender-IP nicht mehr fälschen kann, weil wenn du HTTPS-Verbindungen aufbauen willst,
dann musst du einen TLS-HTTS-Handshake machen und den kannst du nicht machen, wenn deine Absender-IP gefälscht ist,
weil du kriegst dann die Antwort nicht mehr.
Und zum Handshake machen brauchst du halt, allein schon für die TCP-Verbindung, brauchst du halt eine gültige, gültige Absender-IP.
Das heißt, wenn du sowas hier machen willst, dann brauchst du eine gültige Absender-IP, das heißt irgendwie massig,
massig gefälschte Pakete abschicken, ist da nicht.
Das macht's natürlich dann auch zum Erkennen wieder schwieriger, weil es sind halt so legit IP-Adressen, die Absender,
was auch normale Kunden für den jeweiligen Service sein könnten.
Also, das macht's auch schon mal, das macht's zwar aufwendiger für den Angreifer, das macht's aber auch aufwendiger für denjenigen,
der es erkennen will, ähm, den, den Traffic zu klassifizieren, also sprich, kann das jetzt weggeschmissen werden oder nicht?
Ja.
Und außerdem, gerade wenn's HTTPS ist, in dem Fall war's nicht so, ich sag's jetzt aber trotzdem,
weil normalerweise, gerade wenn's HTTPS ist, kann dein Cloud-Anbieter mit dem Traffic ja eh schon mal nix anfangen.
Weil echter Traffic und DDoS-Traffic, ja, über HTTPS verschlüsselt, die Requests, die über HTTPS gehen, zu deinem System,
ja komplett gleich aussehen, das sind einfach ganz normale, ähm, HTTPS-Verbindungen, die dein Cloud-Anbieter nicht mitlebt.
Ja.
Und wenn dein Cloud-Anbieter nicht mitlesen kann und da auch keine Magic-Analysen machen kann, ist das jetzt vielleicht ein DDoS-Angriff,
ist das vielleicht ein echter User-Request, kann's nicht.
Also normalerweise kann dein Cloud-Anbieter nicht reingucken, weil dein Server und der Client reden über HTTPS miteinander,
in der Mitte sieht das keiner, das ist ja grad der Sinn von HTTPS.
In dem Fall ist es nicht so, weil, wir gucken uns das jetzt mal an, in dem Fall ist es nicht so, der Header ist nicht unverschlüsselt.
Ähm, achso, warte mal.
Bin ich mir jetzt gar nicht so sicher.
Initial könnte es sein, am Ende ist es ja eine TLS, äh, ist es ja auf TCP eben eine TLS-Verbindung.
Bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher.
Ist der, ist der, hatten wir das nicht mal ausprobiert?
Ne, den Header siehst du auch nicht, oder? Siehst, ne, du siehst den Header bei HTTPS nicht.
Du machst, du machst da einen TLS-Handshake?
Mir ist da aus dem Kopf gar nicht so sicher, was du siehst und was du nicht siehst.
Keine Ahnung, weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht.
Zumindest in dem Fall ist es eh egal.
In dem Fall ist es eh egal, weil, anscheinend derjenige, der hier bei diesem DDoS-Angriff angegriffen wurde,
also es wurde ja nicht Google direkt angegriffen, sondern, es wurde jemand angegriffen, der den Cloud-Service von, von Google,
ehrlich gesagt, ich weiß es grad aus dem Kopf nicht, was du siehst und was du nicht siehst.
Zumindest, es wurde ja jemand angegriffen, der den Cloud-Service von Google verwendet.
Und, was der gemacht hat ist,
der hat einen Google-HTTPS-Loadbalancer verwendet.
Das heißt, der macht TLS-Terminierungen auf Google-Seite.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob ich das so geil finde, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber, das sorgt dafür, dass Google auf jeden Fall in den Request reingucken kann.
Ob man das jetzt haben will?
Naja, ich weiß nicht, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber, in dem Fall, in dem Fall ist es so.
Also, der Anbieter hat sich dafür gewöhnt.
Er hat sich dafür entschieden,
er will TLS-Terminierungen bei Google machen.
Dementsprechend kann Google in den Traffic reingucken.
Was ihm wohl jetzt auch was gebracht hat,
dass Google in den Traffic reingucken kann,
weil, dementsprechend hat Google relativ schnell erkannt,
dass diese Requests verdächtig aussehen.
Und rein von der Theorie her,
muss man ja sagen,
ein gut gemachter HTTP-Request
kann schon ziemlich viel Traffic verursachen
und Last erzeugen auf den Systemen,
den du in den Request schickst.
Ich meine, zum Beispiel,
überlegt euch mal,
ihr seid ein Angreifer
und schickt einen Login-Request an einen Service.
Überlegt euch mal, was an diesem Login-Request alles dranhängt.
Also, erstmal muss natürlich ein TLS, HTTPS-Handshake gemacht werden,
dass die Verbindung funktioniert.
In dem Fall passiert das auch im Proxy davor, okay.
Aber, damit der Service überhaupt checken kann,
ob ihr euch einloggen könnt oder nicht,
muss der eine Datenbankabfrage machen.
Also, sprich, gibt es den User überhaupt,
mit dem ihr euch versucht einzuloggen?
Stimmt das Passwort?
Und dann muss der eine Fehlermeldung generieren,
euch zurückschicken.
Das heißt, mit einem einfachen für euch,
in Anführungszeichen, relativ einfachem Login-Request
verursacht ihr auf mehreren Ebenen jede Menge Traffic
und jede Menge Last auf dem Service.
Oder auf dem System oder auf dem einzelnen Server,
je nachdem, wie die Architektur aussieht.
Also, ein einfacher Login-Request für euch ist relativ easy,
aber die Antwort, was das an Traffic braucht
und was das an Ressourcen braucht,
um die Antwort darauf zu generieren, ist relativ hoch.
Und jetzt überlegt euch mal, ihr spammt solche Login-Requests
46 Millionen Mal pro Sekunde.
Da geht schon ein bisschen was.
Das macht nicht nur massig Traffic,
das macht vor allem auch Last
und hat Einfluss auf die Server-Kapazitäten.
Also sprich, kann durchaus sein, dass die Server bei dem,
dass das irgendwie, dass die Anwendung crasht,
dass es zu viel RAM braucht, dass die Log-Files die Plade voll machen
oder was auch immer.
Also sprich, das schlägt tatsächlich mehr durch,
so ein Angriff, wie das hier reine Traffic-Spammen,
was Microsoft drüber geschrieben hat.
Und hier sind es halt 340 Pakete,
einfach so stumpfe UDP-Pakete die Sekunde.
Und hier sind es halt 46 echte Requests,
die auch wirklich Last verursachen und auch wirklich was machen
und auch wirklich beantwortet werden müssen.
Und wenn du, ja, wenn du das 46 Millionen Mal die Sekunde machst,
dann ist das schon ein bisschen was.
Es ist dann natürlich auch für den Angreifer aufwendiger,
sowas zu machen.
Das hier ist relativ, in Anführungszeichen, relativ easy.
Das hier ist dann auch für den Angreifer schon ein bisschen aufwendiger,
ein bisschen kostenintensiver, ist aber auch einschneidend dafür,
denjenigen, der angegriffen wird in dem Fall.
Wie gesagt, zumal mittlerweile du ja auch auf IoT-Geräte
für solche Angriffe zurückgreifen kannst, ja,
von Glühbirnen bis Autos bis Klos und alles Mögliche.
Oder Mikrotik-Router wurden beispielsweise die letzten Jahre über
ganz gerne mal mit veralteter Firmware übernommen.
Und gerade die hängen an der Position, wo sie auch ordentlich Bandbreite haben.
Also da geht schon ein bisschen was.
Naja, zumindest, um das hier jetzt mal abzuschließen,
Google sagt natürlich, sie haben das Ganze relativ schnell bemerkt
und natürlich auch nur, weil die ihren HTTPS-Loadbalancer verwendet haben.
Und der Kunde hat irgendwie Cloud Adaptive Armor Protection verwendet
und die haben gleich am Anfang, als die DDoS-Anfragen angefangen haben,
haben sie das erkannt und haben dem Kunden empfohlen,
er soll doch irgendwie da so eine Application-Level-Firewall-Regel einschalten
und dann war gut.
Der Angriff ging übrigens genau 69 Minutes.
Also, wenn das nicht der Meme-Angriff schlechthin ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Corona scheint noch nicht ganz vorbei zu sein.
Ja, und in dem Fall ging das Ganze halt auch nur,
oder konnte Google das auch nur so easy erkennen,
weil eben ein Google HTTPS-Loadbalancer verwundet wurde.
Also sprich, Google konnte da reingucken.
Da bin ich jetzt persönlich kein so großer Fan von.
Aber gut, was soll's.
Dort haben sie das dann erkannt.
Das, was nicht stimmt.
Dann haben sie ihre Regel aktiviert, dass das Ganze gedrosselt wird.
Die haben das irgendwie, Rate-Limit steht da glaube ich drinnen.
Limit, Limit.
Ja, sie haben das Rate-Limited, dass sie nicht so viele reguläre Kunden betrifft,
die das vielleicht, die vielleicht, ja, legit Anfragen stellen, die so ähnlich aussehen.
Dann lief die Attacke 69 Minutes.
Und dann war wieder gut.
Was ich interessant fand, wo der Angriff herkam,
das sind natürlich die üblichen Verdächtigen wieder.
Brasilien?
Russland?
Indien?
Idee weiß ich nicht.
Was ist denn Idee?
Indonesien?
Ah, das passt.
Ja, Indonesien.
Ja, Indonesien mitzahlen.
Ja, ja, Indonesien passt auch bei sowas.
Die sind da, die Indonesier, die Indoneser, die sind da auch bei sowas immer gut vorne mit dabei,
wenn's um sowas angeht, ja.
Genau.
Also sprich, es waren am Ende irgendwie 5.000 noch was IPs beteiligt.
5.200 oder so?
Nee, äh, oder 5, 5.2?
5.2?
Ach so.
Also von 5.256 Source-IPs über 132 Länder.
Wie gesagt, Top-Länder waren halt die üblichen Verdächtigen, die sind da immer ganz gerne dabei.
Und Google sagt hier auch,
zum Vergleich, dass man so als Noob mal ein bisschen das einschätzen kann, wie groß das ist,
die sagen also, dass 10 Sekunden dieses Angriffs sind ungefähr das,
was Wikipedia täglich insgesamt an einem Tag für Requests bekommt.
Und Wikipedia ist halt eines der Top-10 Seiten in der Welt, was Traffic angeht.
Also sprich, der Angriff hat in 10 Sekunden das an Traffic,
oder das an Requests gemacht, was Wikipedia an einem Tag bekommt.
Das ist halt schon ein bisschen was, ne?
Das ist halt, da brummt's, da brummt's schon ein bisschen.
Kann ich, kann ich nachvollziehen.
Jetzt müssen wir noch mal gucken, was das Ganze gekostet hat.
Das würde mich nämlich mal tatsächlich interessieren.
Google Cloud Armor heißt der Klamm.
Rising.
Gucken wir mal.
Ja, von Terabits steht da nix.
Microsoft lässt sich ja hier jetzt sehr,
sehr ausführlich über Bandbreite aus.
Hier steht nix über Bandbreite drüber.
Hier geht's zum größten Teil um Requests und wie geil Google ist und das Ganze abgewehrt hat.
Das hätte mich tatsächlich auch mal interessiert.
Ich meine, die Bandbreite ist jetzt in dem Fall wahrscheinlich nicht ganz so entscheidend gewesen,
weil es ja hauptsächlich darum ging, möglichst viel Last,
aber natürlich auch Traffic zu generieren.
Aber ja, der restliche Teil ist im Prinzip einfach nur, wie geil Google ist.
Also bisschen, bisschen Lob, eigene Lobbreite.
Eigene Lobpreisung auf Google.
So, schauen wir mal, was der Kram kostet.
Ich meine, wir wissen es natürlich nicht,
was die für einen Vertrag mit Google haben, ob die das hier jetzt bezahlen oder nicht.
So, Web Application Firewall.
Hier 75 Cent pro Millionen Anfragen.
Also das heißt 0,75 mal 46.
Dann haben wir das Ganze pro Sekunde.
Also 34 Dollar, sagen wir Euro.
Scheiß auf Dollar, macht hier keinen großen Unterschied.
34 Euro pro Sekunde hat das gekostet.
Ja, da muss man sich ja langsam fragen, ist der Ausfall nicht vielleicht billiger?
Okay, und das Ganze jetzt mal 69, weil es hat halt 69 Minuten.
Ne, Moment, da stimmt irgendwas nicht.
Habe ich irgendwas falsch gemacht?
Ach mal 60 Sekunden.
Ach mal 60 Sekunden habe ich vergessen, wollte ich gerade sagen.
Das ist deutlich zu wenig, dachte ich mir.
Das ist deutlich zu wenig.
Mal 60 muss ich, also 0,75 mal 46 in der Sekunde mal 60 in der Minute mal 69 für die gesamte Laufzeit.
Okay, also das hat die ungefähr 150.000 Euro gekostet, diese DDoS Protection.
Wahrscheinlich, je nach Vertrag.
Mehr oder weniger.
Ja, das Euro oder Dollar macht es jetzt auch nicht fett.
Ich tippe darauf, dass wenn der Service down gewesen wäre, es teurer gewesen ist.
Weil wer so einen Aufwand hat und sowas bereit ist zu machen und zu bezahlen, der hat wahrscheinlich einen Service dahinter, der wichtig ist.
Aber trotzdem, also wenn ihr einfach nur ein kleiner Kackladen seid, der mal von irgendwo gede-dosed wird, wahrscheinlich ist die DDoS Protection teurer, als dass ihr mal kurz eine Laufzeit habt.
Aber natürlich muss man sagen, ein kleiner Kackladen wird auch nicht so einen riesen DDoS abkommen, weil das ist ja auch nicht umsonst sowas zu machen.
Es kostet ja auch was, es kostet den Angreifer ja auch was.
Also insofern ist es wahrscheinlich relativ, relativ safe.
Und was man halt auch nicht vergessen darf, diese ganzen Posts hier, sei es jetzt von Microsoft oder Google oder Cloudflare, die sich ja alle überschneiden über DDoS.
Oder über Treffen mit größtem DDoS aller Zeiten und sowas abgewehrt.
Ein bisschen Werbung ist das natürlich auch. Das ist 50% immer Werbung.
Das heißt, die freuen sich eigentlich drüber, wenn mal wieder irgendeiner groß gede-dosed wird.
Das können sie dann schön abwehren und dann können sie wieder einen Blogpost rausbringen und sagen, wir sind der geilste Anbieter überhaupt und haben es total krass drauf.
Das waren 69 Minuten lang, 46 Millionen Anfragen pro Sekunde.
Achso.
Ja.
Ja, glaub schon.
Na, am Anfang war es ein bisschen weniger.
Der Peak, der Peak war 96 Millionen.
Nee, das war weniger.
Das war weniger.
46 Millionen waren eigentlich bloß eine Minute oder so.
Also wahrscheinlich hat es sich sogar ein bisschen weniger gekostet, aber rechnen wir mal mit 150.000.
Was, 420 Anfragen?
Wo steht da was?
Achso, man hätte ja sein können, man weiß ja nicht.
Aber ja, das hätte eigentlich 420 sein müssen.
Dann hätte es richtig gepasst.
Na, es war weniger, aber, nein.
Da haben wir so, da haben wir ein oberes Ende ausgerechnet.
Also 150.000, 150.000 Euro hat es denn im oberen gekostet.
Wahrscheinlich hat es nur die Hälfte gekostet, wenn man sich das hier anguckt, ja.
Das macht nichts, wenn du das nicht verstehst, nee.
Aber trotzdem, fand ich ganz interessant, sich mal anzugucken.
Wie gesagt, ich denke, es wäre auch für den Angreifer nicht ganz billig.
Und wahrscheinlich sogar ein bisschen frustrierend, weil es nicht so ganz funktioniert hat.
Manchmal habe ich ja das Gefühl, die dedosten sich selber irgendwie, dass sie neue Blogposts machen können.
Weil das Geld und die Infrastruktur dafür halten sie.
Aber so weit will ich jetzt mal nicht gehen.
Man weiß ja nie, ja.
Was sagt er denn?
Ja, wahrscheinlich haben die die Plusstufe.
Wir wissen es ja nicht.
Wir haben ja keine Ahnung, was die haben.
Hm.
Wer weiß, was die am Ende bezahlen.
Keine Ahnung.
Wir wissen es nicht.
Und ich muss euch ganz ehrlich sagen, diese Preistabellen, sei es jetzt Google oder was Azure, also was Microsoft da verzapft, ich blick da nicht durch.
Bei Amazon genauso wenig.
Ich blick da nicht durch.
Also ich finde das, weiß nicht, wer da von euch mit arbeitet und wem es da vielleicht ähnlich geht.
Ich finde das unglaublich schwierig durchzublicken.
Was am Ende wirklich was kostet, ja.
Wenn du zum Beispiel in Azure bei Microsoft eine vm, eine popelige vm anlegst, da kommt so viel dabei und es ist so viel inklusive und so viel dann auch wieder nicht, dass du am Ende gar nicht genau, es gibt ja diesen Azure Calculator, wo man das ausrechnen kann und da kommt so viel dabei.
Da kommt vom Speicher, von der CPU, wie redundant das Ganze sein soll.
Teilweise sogar, wird sogar der Speicherplatz berechnet, den die Config kostet, zu speichern für deine vm.
Also diese, keine Ahnung, diese 25 Kilobyte, die du an Config speichern musst, dass deine vm geht, müssen auch auf irgendeinen Storage Account und dieser Storage Account kostet dann wieder ein paar Cents.
Also es ist sehr, sehr undurchsichtig, was sich Cloud-technisch am Ende irgendwas kostet.
Das Einzige, was ich euch wirklich wärmstens empfehle.
Ja.
Was ich euch empfehlen kann, selbst, also vor allem auch, wenn ihr privat mal was ausprobieren wollt oder bei irgendeinem Cloud-Hoster, Cloud-Dienstleister laufen lassen wollt, macht ein Limit in eurem Account.
Macht ein Limit und setzt das Limit auch realistisch.
Also sprich, wenn ihr sagt, ich will nur was Kleines ausprobieren, dann setzt das Limit halt mal auf 200 Euro oder so.
Sofern der jeweilige Cloud-Anbieter ordentliche Limitierung hat, was ja auch lange Zeit nicht so gerne gemacht wurde von Cloud-Anbietern.
Weil man dann eben nicht über Nacht die 200.000 Euro Rechnung den Leuten schicken konnte.
Zumindest setzt ein Limit, wenn es geht.
Unbedingt.
Weil wenn ihr irgendwie Scheiße baut, ihr könnt in der Cloud relativ schnell Tausende und Zehntausende, Hunderttausende Euro Kosten fabrizieren.
Nur mal so als Beispiel, wo ich letztens ein Video drüber gesehen habe, was wirklich Leuten passiert ist und wahrscheinlich auch, wenn man den nachdenkt.
Ja.
Den Support-Anfragen glaubt.
Genau.
Es gibt Leute, die benutzen beispielsweise Azure Functions oder Google, nee, Amazon Lambda.
Und wie heißt der Krempel bei Google?
Google Functions?
Keine Ahnung.
Die das, also quasi diese, wie nennt sich das nochmal?
Nee, nicht Function as a Service.
Was?
Ach, Cloud-Abkürzung.
Hört mir auf.
Also die beispielsweise, die halt ausnutzen, dass du in der Cloud bist.
Ausnutzen, dass du in der Cloud direkt Logik ausführen kannst.
Und nee, nee, nee, SaaS ist wieder was anderes.
SaaS ist, ähm, äh, ich blick schon gar nicht mehr durch.
System as a Service?
Nee, äh, was ist SaaS?
Software as a Service?
Ach du Scheiße.
SaaS ist Function as a Service und, ja, es ist Infrastructure as a Service.
Zumindest, was ich meine, ist FaaS.
Also sprich, das, was so unter Cloud Native läuft.
Es ist, es ist wirklich schlimm.
Also ganz ehrlich.
Wer bei diesem ganzen Shit das noch aus dem Kopf hinkriegt, der ist, glaub ich, anderweitig,
hat anderweitig Probleme.
Zumindest gibt's Leute, die schaffen's beispielsweise so ne Azure Function.
Versuch ich mal ein Bildchen von, von diesem Editor zu zeigen.
Letztendlich, wahrscheinlich sieht man nur in Visual Studio Code.
Weil die meisten das da drüber machen.
Ah, also keine Ahnung.
Wenn hier irgendwie einer so ne Azure Function programmiert.
Azure Function ist folgendes.
Du programmierst Logik.
Ja, zum Beispiel Hello World.
Du willst nen Webservice haben, der auf nen Request Hello World antwortet.
Das lässt du dann als, äh, Cloud Function laufen.
Sagst nen Endpunkt.
Und du brauchst keinen Rechner mehr.
Kein Server mehr.
Keine virtuelle Maschine mehr.
Äh, kein Application Server mehr, wo dein Code läuft.
Sondern der läuft direkt, äh, in der Cloud auf ner Plattform, die dich nicht interessieren muss.
Und...
Wenn du da jetzt aus Versehen,
zum Beispiel einen Service hast für Login.
Ja?
Du willst, dass sich deine User einloggen können.
AZ-900 hab ich gemacht.
War Painschamp.
War ziemlich vieles, ziemlich vieles, ähm, Powerpoint abgelesen von dem Dozent.
War mega kack Schulung.
Also hat mir überhaupt nicht gefallen.
Zumindest, wenn du jetzt beispielsweise nen Service hast, über solche Functions in der Cloud, wo sich User einloggen können.
Dann müssen diese Cloud Services ja...
...sich untereinander aufrufen können.
Also, du hast beispielsweise ein Login-Service, der dann unter der Haube wieder auf nen anderen Service zugreift, der dann auf die Datenbank zugreift und guckt, ob der User sich einloggen darf.
So.
Und wenn du da nicht aufpasst und aus Versehen es schaffst, dass mehrere Funktionen sich gegenseitig aufrufen, dann hast du quasi ne Art Endlosschleife.
Nur ne Endlosschleife mit Functions, was darauf rausläuft, dass du Millionen aufrufe und du bezahlst den Gramm pro Aufruf.
Beziehungsweise pro, ja, kopierte Aufrufe, pro Tausende, pro Zehntausende, wie auch immer das dann gestaffelt ist, Aufrufe.
Und dann generierst du über Nacht Millionen Function-Aufrufe.
Und am anderen Tag guckst du in dein Cloud-Konto rein und stellst fest, oh, ich hab ne halbe Million Schulden bei Google.
Das ist dann doof.
Und dementsprechend Limit.
Auch wenn ihr einfach nur mit rumspielt.
Macht nen Limit in euren Cloud-Accounts.
...
Vor allem, wenn ihr noch nicht genau wisst, was ihr macht.
Macht ein Limit rein, sofern es der Anbieter kann.
So.
Hätten wir das auch durch.
Ganz schön lang geschwätzt, aber musste auch mal sein.
Dazu könnte ich, Leute, was haltet ihr davon?
Dazu könnte ich eigentlich ein Video heute machen, oder?
Zu dieser Geschichte und mich quasi das, was ich hier im Stream gesagt habe,
nochmal in etwas überlegterer Form.
Ähm, ja, ich habe die AZ-900-Schulung gemacht.
Oder ist das das Zertifikat?
Ein Zertifikat habe ich nicht.
Nee, nee, ich habe die Schulung gemacht.
Oder Training, ja.
Also ich habe insgesamt drei Azure-Schulungen gemacht.
Ich habe 900 oder 901 oder irgendwie sowas gemacht.
400 noch was.
Und das andere war dann 401 und 402 oder irgendwie sowas.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr.
Die Schulungen waren aber alle kacke.
Tja, musst du ja mal überlegen.
Also, die Schulungen waren alle Müll von Microsoft.
Das war ein Dozent, der PowerPoint vorliest.
Aber wenn du die gemacht hast, da gibt es doch immer so Testfragen und Labs.
Also wenn du die Schulung gemacht hast, da hast du Zugang.
Da kriegst du einen Account mit, glaube ich, 100 Euro Guthaben.
Und du kannst die Prüfungsvorbereitung damit machen.
Also die haben ja dann quasi komplette Übungen und Anleitungen und Tests da drinnen.
Ja.
Ansonsten kann ich ja leider auch nicht mehr sagen.
Dozent, der nur vorliest, Klassiker.
Die sollten das so machen.
Wir haben den auch gefragt.
Können wir nicht ein bisschen mehr Übungen machen?
Aber nein, Microsoft möchte, dass die Schulungen so gemacht werden, dass die Schulungen einheitlich sind.
Also bei Hetzner bin ich mir gar nicht sicher, ob du überhaupt ein Limit setzen kannst.
Aber bei Hetzner ist das auch kein größeres Problem.
Also erstens, Hetzner hat standardmäßig, wenn du es nicht erweiterst, Limits, was anlegbare Objekte angeht.
Also allein schon damit ist ziemlich stark limitiert, was du maximal ausgeben kannst.
Und Hetzner hat keine Functions.
Hetzner hat ja im Prinzip, also Hetzner Cloud hat ja im Prinzip VMs, Loadbalancer und ein bisschen Firewall-Regeln.
Wenn auch nicht so Advanced.
Und da würde ich mir jetzt wenig Gedanken machen, dass du da irgendwie Traffic...
Ja.
Bei Hetzner hast du, ja, du kannst dich benachrichtigen lassen.
Ich weiß aber nicht, ob du dich bei so und so viel Traffic benachrichtigen lässt.
Weiß ich gar nicht.
Traffic hast du eh in eine Richtung bei Hetzner unlimited und ich glaube in die andere 20 Gigabyte oder so.
Es ist auf jeden Fall genug.
In der Regel hast du da keine Probleme.
Falls du sowas meinst wie Rate Limiting für Programme, die auf einem Server laufen.
Das hat mit dem Limit, was ich meine, nichts zu tun.
Also ich meine wirklich Limit.
Im Management-Interface vom jeweiligen Cloud-Anbieter, dass du nicht mehr Ressourcen von denen anfragen kannst.
Oder dass es deshalb halt blockiert, wenn du mehr Ressourcen anfragen willst, als dein Budget hergibt.
Wenn du Rate Limiting machen willst für deine Programme, dann brauchst du Software, die auf deinem Server läuft, die Rate Limiting macht.
Da gibt es welche.
Da gibt es zum Beispiel, wir haben es letztens erst im Stream verwendet.
Ich habe den Namen wieder vergessen.
GitHub, Linux, Rate Limiting.
Nope.
Wie hieß denn das, was wir letztens verwendet?
Das haben wir letztens verwendet, glaube ich.
Genau.
Nee.
Ohne Jammer-File.
Nee, nee.
Das haben wir nicht verwendet.
Ich kann es dir jetzt gar nicht mehr sagen, was wir da letztens verwendet haben.
Verdrängt.
Keine Ahnung mehr.
Also das kenne ich, aber das haben wir, glaube ich, nicht benutzt.
Doch, das haben...
Nee, aber wir haben keine Jammer verwendet.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Das war relativ easy.
Wir haben nämlich die komplette Bandbreite der VM einfach limitiert auf 100 Mbit.
Wenn du einzelne Programme limitieren willst, dann geht das auch, aber das macht es ein bisschen komplizierter.
Ich gucke mal kurz.
Was muss man für das Zertifikat tun?
Wenn du ein Zertifikat haben willst, dann musst du die Prüfung machen.
Und ihr...
Ey, die Azure-Prüfungen sind lustig.
Da musst du dich aufs Klo setzen.
Nur halb Kappa.
Weil die haben ziemlich...
Nee.
Traffic?
Ich weiß wirklich nicht mehr, was wir da gemacht haben zum Traffic limitieren.
Hä?
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was wir verwendet haben.
Wenn ich den Namen des Programms sehe, weiß ich es wieder sofort.
Wie heißt mein Interface?
ENS 33.
Wondershaper!
Wondershaper haben wir verwendet.
Genau.
Gitter Wondershaper.
Jetzt.
Jetzt weiß ich es wieder.
Wondershaper haben wir verwendet.
Da kannst du nämlich zum Beispiel sagen,
ich möchte, dass mein Interface bloß noch 40 Mbits im Download hat.
Und sowas.
Das geht aber für das komplette Interface nicht pro Anwendung.
Pro Anwendung gibt es auch Software, aber das haben wir in dem Fall nicht gebraucht.
Ja, aber nochmal eine Sache zu den Microsoft.
Die sind relativ streng, was die Prüfung angeht.
Also, du musst dich filmen per Webcam.
Ich weiß nicht, ich kann das nur vom Hören sagen.
Vielleicht hat jemand von euch schon mal solche Microsoft-Prüfungen gemacht,
der das ein bisschen genauer sagen kann.
Also, das, was ich gehört habe, ist, du musst dich filmen bei den Prüfungen.
Du musst den Raum abfilmen bei den Prüfungen.
Du brauchst permanente Kamera auf dich oder auf den Blog.
Bildschirm oder auf die Tastatur.
Vielleicht brauchst du sogar mehrere Kameras.
Es darf niemand durchs Bild laufen.
Du darfst dich nicht umdrehen.
Es darf keiner die Tür öffnen.
Also, es darf nichts passieren.
Also, alles, was nur den Anschein eines Bescheißens sein könnte,
das ist schlimmer als bei OnlyFans.
Ist echt so.
Und, also, kannst du komplett, kannst du,
also, es ist eine ziemlich heftige Anforderung an die Prüfung.
Aber ich meine, okay, die wollen halt auch nicht, dass jeder da bescheißt.
Wenn du dich nur räusperst, wirst du ermahnt.
Ja, könnte ja sein, dass du per Räuspern kommunizierst
mit irgendeinem Typ, der vor der Tür steht und dir dann einen Zettel durchschiebt oder so.
Oder du hast was, du hast, du hast was versteckt.
Also, ich gehe halt davon aus, die Leute bescheißen dabei halt auch wirklich.
Und dementsprechend sind die da so allergisch dagegen.
Ja, ich finde, man muss es nicht übertreiben.
Microservice ist nur um Microservice.
Ich muss jetzt einfach nochmal sagen.
Also, Cloud-Zeug machen um des Cloud-Zeug-Willens oder Microsoft-Services einfach,
weil, äh, nicht Microsoft, Microservices, einfach, weil Microservices jetzt cool und angesagt sind,
hat ja keinen Sinn.
Das Ganze kommt in der Regel erst richtig zur Geltung, wenn man irgendeinen Service hat, der skalieren muss.
Ihr wisst ja, wir skalieren weder horizontal noch vertikal, wir skalieren gleich diagonal.
Also, sprich, wenn ihr irgendeinen Service habt oder irgendeinen Dienst anbietet, der skalieren muss,
dann ist das nicht so.
In der Regel sind das halt Services, die mal extrem viel und mal relativ normal und wenig benutzt werden.
Also, stellt euch jetzt mal zum Beispiel vor, ihr habt, keine Ahnung, Service XY gebaut und auf einmal macht PewDiePie ein Video über eure Webseite.
Dann müsst ihr skalieren.
Und wenn ihr das im Vorfeld für diesen Fall natürlich schon ausgelegt habt, in der Cloud mit Microservice,
dann könnt ihr richtig krass skalieren von zwei Usern auf zwei Millionen.
Allerdings wäre das,
nun ja,
ziemlich bescheuert, so zu engineeren,
weil,
ich würde nicht auf den Fall hoffen, dass PewDiePie ein Video über euren Service macht.
Und der Aufwand,
eine Webseite zu entwickeln,
oder einen Webservice zu entwickeln,
wo das Backend auf einer VM läuft,
und, sagen wir mal, für,
tja, keine Ahnung, 5000 User ausreicht,
ist halt einfacher,
als einen Webservice zu entwickeln,
der sich über 500 Microservices erstreckt,
der sich da zwar richtig krass skalieren lässt,
aber keine Sau mehr versteht, was da eigentlich passiert.
Also, ich bin der Meinung, sowas muss, ähm,
mit Bedacht eingesetzt werden, ja,
und vieles sich auch über die Zeit so ein bisschen entwickeln.
Die Sparkasse will 5 Cent pro Push-Benachrichtigung haben.
Tja, Sparkasse sagt eh.
Also, ich hab zwei Konten.
Ich hab eins bei der Sparkasse und eins bei PewDiePie.
Also, ich hab zwei Konten. Ich hab eins bei der Sparkasse und eins bei PewDiePie.
Das ist ja echt, wie zum Beispiel,
eins beim Risiko, für die Post,
eins eines bei der Direktbank,
eins halt für Business-Stonks-Zeug,
also, und noch eins für, für, für Stonks.
Übrigens, über 1.000 Euro Plus diesen Monat,
ne, 1.600 Euro Plus diesen Monat,
die Stonks, Stonks gehen richtig steil grade.
Ja und wie gesagt, ich hab,
ich hab das Konto für die Stonks.
Ich hab das Konto für, für Business
und ich hab das mein privates Konto.
Und die Sparkasse geht mir mit Abstand
am meisten auf den Sack.
Und die Sparkasse möchte mir auch laufen
irgendwelche Beratertermine und sowas aufschwätzen.
So nach dem Motto,
So nach dem Motto, haben sie schon versucht, ihr XY zu optimieren, haben sie schon gesagt, Leute, geht mir nicht auf den Sack, lasst mich einfach in Ruhe.
Ja, das geht auch. Wondershaper ist quasi ein Frontend für irgendwelche Low-Level-Tools.
Also Cisco-Zertifikate, ich habe ja mal vor Urzeiten ein CCNA gemacht.
CCNA, das erwähne ich normalerweise nicht, weil CCNA hat ja jeder eigentlich irgendwann mal zumindest die Schulung zugemacht.
Mittlerweile ist das auch schon expired.
Zumindest damals war die Prüfung halt noch vor Ort und da musstest du wirklich in den Prüfungen, da stand da, hattest du so einen Typ, so zwei zertifizierte Cisco-Typen.
Und da hattest du eine Aufgabe, so nach dem Motto, richten sie jetzt, keine Ahnung, irgendeinen Interconnect zwischen zwei Switchen mit WLANs, XY, wie auch immer ein.
Ne, Trunkport heißt es ja, Trunkport heißt es ja bei Cisco.
Zwischen zwei Switches ein und sorgen sie da dafür.
Und dann hast du das gebaut.
Und dann kam da wirklich dieser Dude an und hat das kontrolliert, ob das funktioniert und was du konsolentechnisch eingegeben hast.
Also das war auch vor Ort gar nicht ohne.
Im Prinzip ist der CCNA-Inhalt relativ easy, aber wenn du es aus dem Kopf komplett alles wissen musst, ohne nachzugucken.
Und wenn du den Prüfertyp hast, der sich wirklich alles genau anguckt, was du machst, sind auch einfache Sachen relativ kompliziert.
Das Spanning Tree ist doch wieder was anderes.
Spanning Tree ist, dass du keine Schleifen in deinem Geswitcher hast.
Und Trunkport ist ein Port, wo mehrere, zumindest bei Cisco, wo mehrere WLANs drüber gehen.
Was ist die Frage gewesen?
Kennst du eine gute Alternative, günstige Alternative zum Raspberry Pi?
Tja, im Prinzip das, was Stripes gesagt hat, was du machen willst.
Ansonsten, zum Raspberry Pi selber gibt es keine gute Alternative.
Du hast zwar jede Menge mittlerweile.
Du kannst, SPC kannst du suchen, ja.
Single Board Computer.
Oder suchst nach Raspberry Pi.
Alternative.
Es gibt jede Menge Single Board Computer Alternativen.
Zum Beispiel auch die Odroid-Sachen, die sind ganz gut.
Habe ich auch ein paar von.
Aber, das sind alles keine wirklichen Alternativen zum Raspberry Pi.
Weil den Raspberry Pi machen mehrere Dinge aus.
Erstens, der Preis.
Der bisher eigentlich relativ günstig war.
Mittlerweile unglaublich dämlich teuer, aber preislich war Raspberry Pi immer ziemlich gut.
Und das zweite, der mega Vorteil beim Raspberry Pi ist, die Softwareunterstützung und vor allem die Riesenauswahl an Tutorials und Videos und Hilfen und Projekte und Zusatzboards, also das gesamte Raspberry Pi Ökosystem.
Und das hast du bei keiner anderen Plattform, also bei keiner Singleboard Computer Plattform, bei keiner anderen Singleboard Computer Plattform als beim Raspberry Pi in diesem Umfang.
Das heißt, es gibt keine gute Alternative zum Raspberry Pi in diesem Umfeld.
So, die O-Droid Dinger gehen auch, aber du wirst feststellen, dass Support, wie gut das, wie easy das unter Linux zu machen ist, ist dort etwas komplizierter und du musst auch einiges selbst wissen und machen, dass das damit geht.
Ich hatte lange Zeit ein O-Droid HC2 im Einsatz. Das ist so ein ganz kleines Board gewesen, wo man eine Festplatte anschließen konnte.
Also sprich, das ist quasi ein riesen Passiv-Kühlrahmen und ein kleines Board mit SATA-Anschluss und da hatte ich meinen TV-Headend-Server drauflaufen.
TV-Headend ist was, wo man mit einem DVB-C-Stick, mit einem DVB-C-Tuner Fernseh empfangen kann und aufnehmen kann und Serienaufnahmen machen kann, sowas.
Also hatte ich quasi Fernsehaufnahmen drüberlaufen. Da hatte ich eine 2TB SSD später dran und hab das darüber gemacht, aber, und das haben wir glaube ich sogar im Archiv.
Das haben wir damals sogar irgendwo im, vor drei Jahren haben wir das gemacht im Stream.
Bei PowerShell an sich gut.
Jaja, Max, ist gut.
Und damit der DVB-C-Stick und das jeweilige Betriebssystem mit dem Treiber für den DVB-C-Stick da drauf gelaufen ist, mussten wir einen eigenen Kernel kompilieren damals.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie wir das gemacht haben, irgendwo hier.
Irgendwo haben wir einen Kernel kompiliert.
Und dann haben wir glaube ich noch TV-Headend kompiliert.
Das ist was, das Problem hast du unter dem Raspberry, hier läuft's, guckt.
Das Problem hast du unter dem Raspberry Pi nicht, weil unter dem Raspberry Pi installierst du das einfach Gutes.
Und Raspberry Pi, das OS ist auch relativ aktuell, auf Debian basiert.
Also die Kombination aus Einfachheit halber, normalerweise früher den Preis und der gar nicht schlechten Hardware.
Also mach das einzigartig, den Raspberry Pi.
Also gibt's eigentlich keine gute Alternative.
Äh, ne, ne, ne.
Den TV-Headend haben wir nochmal zusätzlich auf einer Hetzner-Kiste kompiliert mit 48 Kernen, ja.
Das war aber für meine neue Linux-Box.
Für den Odroid haben wir das damals, ich glaub sogar auf dem Odroid selber gemacht oder so.
Tja, also keine Alternative für den Raspberry Pi.
Was du machen kannst ist, je nachdem was du machen willst, ja.
Kannst du gucken, ob es beispielsweise ein normales x86-Board tut.
Ja, zum Beispiel die, ähm, diese Boards, ähm, wie heißt der?
Solche Dinger hier zum Beispiel.
Wobei man da halt echt mal gucken muss, ich weiß nicht, ob das noch aktuell ist.
Solche Boards sind auch ganz gut, die kosten nicht viel, falls es das noch gibt.
Alter, ich hab damals, was hab ich, Leute, wir haben im Stream geguckt, was hab ich damals für bezahlt?
5.000 Euro.
5.000 Euro oder so?
Alter, das ist ganz...
What the fuck?
Warum ist das so teuer geworden?
Kacke, was ist denn da los?
Vielleicht sind das auch nicht mal die aktuellen.
Ah, das sind auch, glaub ich, gar nicht mal die aktuellen, okay.
Also, nach solchen Boards kannst du zum Beispiel auch mal gucken.
Die sind relativ stromsparend.
Die verbrauchen...
Die verbrauchen EIDL ungefähr so viel wie ein Raspberry Pi unter...
Naja, wie ein Raspberry Pi 3 unter Vollast.
Also, ein Raspberry 3 oder ein Raspberry...
Ja, so, Raspberry Pi 4 unter Vollast braucht wahrscheinlich eher so 13, 14 Watt.
Und das Board braucht EIDL ungefähr 8.
Also, sagen wir mal, ein Raspberry Pi unter Vollast braucht ungefähr so viel wie...
Es gibt keinen Sockel.
Die CPU ist aufgelötet bei diesen Boards.
Ähm, also dieses Board braucht EIDL ungefähr so viel wie der Raspberry Pi unter Vollast.
Also, irgendwas zwischen 8 und 10 Watt.
Allerdings muss ich sagen, der Preis hat es echt in sich mittlerweile.
Ah ja, das ist schon besser.
Ab 75 Euro, da kann man sich das überlegen.
Dafür hast du halt auch mehr Rechenleistung.
Du hast ein x86 Dual-Core.
Das heißt, du hast keinerlei Probleme, dort irgendwas zum Laufen zu bekommen.
Du kannst ganz normales...
Okay, auch kleineren RAM-Riegel, aber du kannst ganz normales RAM-Riegel drauf machen.
Das ist auch eine Option.
So was hier.
Das ist Board und CPU in einem für 75 Euro.
Rechenleistung mehr als der Raspberry Pi.
Verbrauch ein bisschen mehr.
Natürlich bei weitem nicht so kompakt.
Du brauchst noch ein Netzteil.
Du brauchst theoretisch noch irgendwelche Platten.
Dafür hast du halt auch mehr Erweiterungsmöglichkeiten.
Also, sprich, du kannst halt auch mal eine PC-Express-Karte reinstecken und so.
Was du beim Raspberry Pi eben nicht machen kannst.
Muss ich mal gucken.
Ist eventuell eine Alternative zu dem, was du machen willst.
Möchtest du dir beispielsweise Netzwerk-Store.
Was ja ganz viele Leute lustigerweise im Raspberry Pi machen wollen.
Wofür der Raspberry Pi meiner Ansicht nach überhaupt nicht geeignet ist.
Auch der Raspberry Pi 4 ist...
Also Raspberry Pi, auch der 4er, ist ein ziemlich grottenschlechtes Nass.
Aber es gibt Leute, die wollen das trotzdem machen.
Da ist so eine Plattform deutlich besser.
Du hast die Möglichkeit, hier eine Karte reinzumachen für weitere SATA-Anschlüsse.
Du kannst eine 10-Gigabit-Netzwerkkarte reinmachen.
Wenn auch nicht mit voller Power.
Weil du siehst, der PC-Express-Steckplatz...
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das erkennt.
Sieht man das?
Der PC-Express-Steckplatz ist bloß mal 2 angebunden.
Oder ist das mal 4?
Ist das PC-Express 2 oder 4?
Gucken wir doch mal.
Mal 2.
Also es ist ein 16er-Slot.
Das die Karte hält.
Aber es ist nur ein PC-Express mal 2.
Also sprich, ihr könnt euch eine 10-Gigabit-Netzwerkkarte kaufen.
Die wird dann aber wahrscheinlich bloß mit...
6-7 Gigabit funktionieren.
In dem Slot.
Zumal es auch nur PC-Express 2 ist.
Was auch nochmal langsam ist.
Also für einen 10-Gigabit-Netzwerkkart ist das...
Auch wenn ich mir sowas damals damit gebaut habe,
ist es nicht das allergeilste.
Es gibt natürlich auch die Möglichkeit, sowas über USB zu machen.
Aber wie gesagt...
Flexibler als...
Schneller, flexibler und besser erweitert als ein Raspberry Pi ist es auf jeden Fall.
Es ist aber halt auch größer.
Kostet unterm Strich mehr.
Gerade mit den ganzen Sachen dabei.
Musstet ihr mal überlegen, ob das nicht vielleicht was sind.
Genau, das was Stripes hier sagt.
Low-Power-Internet-Plattform.
Ey, du kannst dir eine 4-fach-Gigabit-Karte ohne Probleme in einen 2-fach-PC-Express reinmachen.
Dann läuft die halt nicht mit kompletter Bandbreite.
Das geht. Das ist kein Ding.
Der Barry-Base-Club.
Das stimmt.
Beim Barry-Base-Club habe ich mich letztens versucht,
im Stream fake zu registrieren.
Und die haben erkannt, dass es eine Fake-Registrierung ist.
Und...
Haben mich nicht in den Club reingelassen.
Ich finde nicht, dass Cody...
Cody gut läuft auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Cody läuft nur gut auf dem Raspberry Pi,
wenn man es noch nie auf einem Shield-TV oder Android-TV
mit ordentlicher GPU-CPU gesehen hat.
Cody und generell die Oberfläche
ist so weich auf dem aktuellen Android-TV
und so ruckelig auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Ich meine, es läuft benutzbar.
Nicht so, als dass man es nicht benutzen könnte.
Aber...
Es ist nicht schön.
So, gucken wir uns mal ein bisschen was an.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Windows 11.
Top 5 Features.
Und wichtige Neuerungen.
Oh, oh, oh, Microsoft.
Wobei, das Video hatte ich irgendwo doch schon mal auf.
Microsoft.
Huge Änderung.
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Kann man jetzt in der...
Also, es ist Windows 11.
Jetzt bin ich noch auf Windows 10.
Kann man jetzt in der Taskleiste
wenigstens ordentlich
die Programme entgruppieren?
Das wäre ja eine Sache, die ich ganz sinnvoll finden würde.
Aber wahrscheinlich nicht.
Stuhlmacher, danke schön für den Sub.
Gucken wir uns mal an.
Gucken wir uns mal an die massive, huge Änderung,
die Microsoft bringt.
Das erste große Update für Windows 11
heißt 22H2
und ist entsprechend für das zweite Halbjahr 2022 vorgesehen.
Genauer gesagt sollte es im Herbst dieses Jahres erscheinen.
Bevor das Update dabei erscheint,
sehen wir uns heute die fünf wichtigsten Features an,
damit ihr die Neuerungen direkt kennenlernt.
Da bin ich gespannt.
Vorher aber eine Nachricht von unserem heutigen Videosponsor,
Textblaze.
Textblaze ist eine super Pro-Undernachricht.
Praktische Erweiterung für Google Chrome.
Leute, ich muss unbedingt auch mehr Sponsoring machen.
Mittlerweile ist es Standard.
Jeder hat Sponsoring für seine Videos, nur ich nicht.
Und es ist ja nicht mal, dass ich keine Anfragen habe.
Die meisten Sachen finde ich aber so bescheuert,
für die habe ich keinen Bock, Werbung zu machen.
Aber, mein, why not?
Womit ihr Shortcuts für jede Art von Texten erstellen könnt.
Doch, Hetzner-Ads mache ich.
Ich wollte erst mal warten, bis mein Corona-Scheiß richtig vorbei ist.
Dann machen wir demnächst ein, äh, Sponsor-Stream wieder.
Über das neue, dynamische IP-Feature von Hetzner.
Wenn ihr häufig eine dieselbe Nachricht schreibt, könnt ihr den Prozess mit Textblaze einfach automatisieren.
Ich lass die Werbung aber jetzt trotzdem laufen.
Ich meine, wir gucken uns den Content von ihnen an, also sind wir mal so nett.
Seit ich Textblaze kenne, habe ich Unmengen an Zeit gespart,
indem ich auf LinkedIn und in E-Mails ganz schnell auf häufig ähnliche Anfragen antworten kann.
Ladet euch die Textblaze Chrome-Erweiterung direkt herunter und sichert euch einen kostenlosen Monat mit der ProValue.
Die Pro-Version über meinen Link unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Was, was läuft denn eigentlich in den S7P...
Meinst du die Samsung-Smartphones oder was ist ein S7?
Oder wa... Ich versteh's jetzt grad nicht.
Was sind, was sind S7PLCs?
Ich weiß doch nicht mal, was das ist.
Was ist das?
Chat, was ist das?
Kann man danach suchen?
Ist das eine Telefonanlage?
Keine Ahnung.
Habe ich noch nie was mit das zu tun gehabt.
Wo soll ich das wissen?
Keine Ahnung.
Industrieanlagen steuern?
Kein Schimmer.
Keine Ahnung, was da läuft.
Weiß ich doch nicht.
Nee, keine Ahnung.
Ich wusste bisher nicht mal, was das überhaupt sein soll, bis eben.
Der Windows Explorer wird mit dem kommenden Update groß erneuert.
Übrigens, wisst ihr, was ich witzig finde?
Jetzt, wo ich das, wo ich, wo ich, wo ich, wo ich hier den Channel gerade sehe.
Also, ich hab letztens, also ich als Linux-Fan, ja?
Hab letztens ein Video gemacht,
warum es für viele Leute wahrscheinlich
keine gute Idee ist,
auf Linux umzusteigen.
Und die hier,
als quasi
Microsoft- und Windows-Fans,
haben ein Video zugemacht.
Zehn Gründe, warum
Linux besser ist als Windows.
Was ich witzig finde, weil das quasi
die entgegengesetzte Aussage
von so entgegengesetzten Leuten kommt.
Also sprich, ich bin ein Windows-Fan,
ich bin eigentlich der Linux-Fanboy,
doch LevelCaptchaBaitmama auch.
Ich bin eigentlich der Linux-Fanboy, der sagt,
Linux ist nicht für jeden was.
Und er ist wahrscheinlich, würde ich sagen, eher der Windows-Fanboy
und sagt, Linux ist POG.
Aufzeichnen.
Das ist neu?
Okay, für mich sieht das aus wie vor...
Das Häuschen ist neu.
Das sieht jetzt ein bisschen aus wie ein KDE-Icon.
An neuen Startseite sind die Tabs im Windows Explorer
eine erwünschte und...
Endlich! Wirklich!
Das glaube ich nicht.
Es gibt jetzt wirklich nach
zehn Jahren Tabs, Tabs im Windows Explorer.
Haben sie es jetzt geschafft?
Leute, ich wette mit euch,
irgendwas funktioniert da nicht richtig.
Irgendwas ist da undurchdacht und kacke.
Wir können mal die VM
aktualisieren. Ja, ja, ihr habt...
Wobei, das Update gibt es noch gar nicht.
Echt wichtige Verbesserung.
Ab Windows 11 22 H2
könnt ihr in einem Windows Explorer Fenster
mehrere Tabs öffnen
und so deutlich schneller und effizienter
durch euer Dateisystem navigieren.
Wobei, ich sagen muss, das Öffnen
sieht sehr holprig aus, oder?
Guckt euch das mal an.
Guckt mal, habt ihr das gesehen,
wie das Menü hier nach und nach aufbaut und so?
...durch euer Dateisystem navigieren.
Hier oben in der Titelleiste findet ihr nun ein Pluszeichen,
womit ihr einen neuen Tab öffnet.
Habt ihr gesehen, wie...
Ja, mach nochmal zu.
Okay, okay, Achtung, Pausechamp aufs Plus.
Plus, Plus, Plus.
Ja, klick.
Guckt mal, er hat geklickt.
Guckt mal, seht ihr?
Wie laggy das aufbaut.
Die cachen noch nicht mal die Icons richtig.
Ihr könnt davon ausgehen,
wenn ich das sogar in einem YouTube Video
mit 30 FPS so hier links...
Das ist krasses Rumgelagge
beim Aufgehen.
...womit ihr einen neuen Tab öffnet
oder eben eine neue Registerkarte,
wie Microsoft das nennt.
Wir haben die Explorer Tabs in einem eigenen Video
und da werde ich euch die detaillierte Rundschau
jetzt ersparen.
Und wenn ihr diese doch sehen wollt,
dann findet ihr sie jetzt hier oben in der Infokarte
sowie in der Beschreibung.
Eine Neuerung des Windows 11 22 H2 Updates
ist auch die Startseite im Windows Explorer.
Diese beinhaltet jetzt eure Schnellzugriff-Ordner
sowie die Favoriten und zuletzt...
Ich habe nicht die Leerzeile gespammt.
Ich habe doch gerade mit Punkt und Komma navigiert.
Das bringt aber nicht nur positive Änderungen.
So hat Microsoft
die Dieser PC Ansicht
dafür deutlich im Umfang reduziert. Warum?
Ich will USB-Sticks an der Stelle auch auswerfen können
und Zeug machen.
Also das ist okay,
aber passt mal auf.
Ich sage es euch.
Also hat Microsoft die Dieser PC Ansicht
dafür deutlich im Umfang reduziert. Warum?
Ich will USB-Sticks an der Stelle auch auswerfen können
und Zeug machen.
Also das ist okay,
aber passt mal auf.
Ich sage es euch.
Also hat Microsoft die Dieser PC Ansicht
dafür deutlich im Umfang reduziert. Warum?
Ich sage es euch.
Die sind verschlüsselt und die werden nur entschlüsselt, wenn ich mich anmelde an meinem anderen Main-Windows-Account.
Au! Was ist denn da? 3,5 GB free. Sekunde.
Das ist aber ganz schön wenig.
Da muss ich mal ein bisschen...
Glaub ich, da muss ich mal ein bisschen was wegschmeißen wieder, oder?
Bisschen sehr wenig.
... im Umfang reduziert, sodass dort tatsächlich nur noch eure lokalen Laufwerke sowie eure Netzwerklaufwerke angezeigt werden.
Das Disk-Clean-Up-Tool. Okay, auf geht's.
Für C. Thumbnails, okay.
Ja, mach. Yes. Thumbnails.
Hui! Das hat's aber gelohnt.
Auch wenn das ein kleiner Rückschritt ist, meiner Meinung nach, wird der neue Windows Explorer deutlich besser, einfach nur aufgrund der Tabs.
Das Startmenü von Windows 11...
Guck mal, er verwendet hier unten die Wetteranzeige. Benutzt das wirklich Serious Lim? Jemand ernsthaft, diese Wetteranzeige?
... bekommt ebenfalls einige neue Funktionen.
Die allerdings eher noch in die Kategorie Notwendige Nachbesserung...
Deine Suche geht nicht mehr unter Windows 11, das ist normal. Die Suche ist nicht dafür gemacht zu gehen.
... gehören und weniger zu den wichtigen Innovationen des 22H2-Updates.
Das Startmenü in Windows 11 wird aber mit dem Update ein Stück weit anpassbarer und ihr könnt über die Einstellungen bei Personalisierung und dann bei Start etwas genauer festlegen, wie euer Startmenü aussehen soll.
Ja, gibt es denn jetzt die Möglichkeit, endlich mal die Programme nicht zu gruppieren?
Nö, immer noch nicht.
Geil.
... aussehen soll. Ihr könnt nun einstellen, ob ihr mehr angehefte Elemente oder mehr Empfehlungen sehen möchtet.
Nein, ich will keine Empfehlungen. Ihr sollt einfach zumindest mal Funktionsgleichheit herstellen zu Windows 98, das wäre doch schon mal was.
Ich habe mich bereits als ziemlicher Fan von diesen Empfehlungen geoutet, weil es meine...
Ach diese, Moment. Ja, das ist in Ordnung. Das hier, Appsempfehlungen, sowas finde ich Müll.
Wenn es mir beispielsweise sagt, zuletzt...
Nein, und so, das ist okay.
... Blumen geoutet, weil es meine zuletzt verwendeten Dokumente und Programme immer direkt im Startmenü anzeigt.
Aber dafür erzählt er hier so ein anderes Zeug auch.
So muss ich mich nicht immer daran erinnern, woran ich zuletzt gearbeitet hatte oder wo sich dieses Dokument gerade befindet.
Ja, es ist ja nicht so, als wäre das jetzt irgendwas Neues gewesen, ja? Das hat Windows 95 schon angezeigt.
Ich verstehe aber, dass ganz viele Leute keine Fans davon sind, sodass man die Empfehlungen nun auch stark zurückschrauben kann und dann nur noch eine einzige Reihe an Empfehlungen dargestellt wird.
Ihr müsst ja aber erstmal genügend Programme finden und Apps, um das Startmenü damit zu füllen.
Viel Glück damit bei dem Microsoft Store.
Kurz gesagt sei auch, dass das Windows 11 Startmenü bald Ordner unterstützt.
Wenn ihr eine App nun auf eine andere App draufzieht, könnt ihr die...
Das sind immer so Dinge, wo ich von ausgegangen bin, dass das eigentlich schon immer funktioniert hat.
Und jetzt erfahre ich, nein, anscheinend kann das Store Startmenü kein Ordner.
Mein, what the fuck?
Wie sieht dann sowas hier dann zum Beispiel aus?
Gibt's es dann gar nicht mehr, oder wie?
Windia Start habe ich normalerweise auch, ja?
Diese in so ganz simplen Ordnern zusammenfassen und diesen Ordnern auch einen Namen geben.
Das Design davon ist wirklich sehr simple und auch unausgereift.
In Windows 10 waren...
Wer hätte das gedacht?
...die Ordner wesentlich besser durchdacht und haben deutlich besser zum übrigen Design des Startmenüs gepasst.
Ich persönlich finde es aber schade, dass man...
Das ganze Verschlimmbessern von irgendwas, das ist ja fast wie bei Battlefield 2042.
Als wissen sie nicht, wie es geht, obwohl sie es eigentlich wissen müssten.
...noch nicht mehrere Apps zusammen aus...
Der Clipchamp?
Endlich.
Endlich war eine Software von mir mit dabei.
...einen Ordner zusammenfassen und direkt vom Startmenü entfernen oder direkt deinstallieren kann.
Bei dem ganzen Spam, den Microsoft vorher installiert bei Windows...
Ich weiß nicht, warum ist Instagram, Facebook, TikTok Standardmenü, Clipchamp, ja, das Beste von mir.
...das auch bitter notwendig, aber...
I made this, Leute.
...dann die ganzen...
...Apps hin, die eben Microsoft empfehlen möchte.
Mit Windows 11 hat Microsoft die Snap-Layouts eingeführt, die euch mehrere vordefinierte Möglichkeiten bieten, die aktuell geöffneten Fenster anzuordnen.
Die Snap-Layouts zeigen sich bisher nur, wenn man über das Maximieren-Icon drüber fährt.
Doch ab Windows 11 22H2 werdet ihr diese auch beim Ziehen eines Fensters sehen.
Wenn ein Fenster an den oberen Bildschirmrand zieht, wird von oben die Snap-Assist-Leiste dargestellt mit Vorschlägen, wie ihr eure Fenster schnell anheften könnt.
Warum?
Warum braucht man das? Warum kann man nicht?
Also jetzt mal ganz dumme Frage, ja?
Warum ist das hier jetzt zu viel, das Guten?
Also ich mein, warum brauche ich eine Vorschau, wie mein Fenster angeheftet wird, wenn ich denn mein Fenster einfach anheften könnte, wo ich es will?
Außerdem ist neu, dass ihr die Snap-Layouts nun auch per Tastenkombination aufrufen könnt, indem ihr einfach auf Windows und Z drückt.
Das ging auch nicht!
Das zeigt euch dann die Snap-Layouts für euer aktuelles Fenster an.
Das ist natürlich sinnvoll, dass es per Tastatur geht.
Und wenn ihr das nicht machen solltet, könnt ihr die Snap-Layouts übrigens auch über die Einstellungen unter System und dann Multitasking deaktivieren.
Die Option heißt im Deutschen Fenster andocken und dort könnt ihr genau konfigurieren, wie die Undock-Layouts bei euch am Computer funktionieren sollen.
Der Task-Manager zählt zu den wichtigsten Systemkomponenten in Windows.
Ist das kleine Programm doch immer dann der Rettungsanker, wenn sonst alle Stricke reißen.
Microsoft hat den Task-Manager nun komplett umgestaltet und er bekommt neben einem neuen Design auch...
Sieht der so viel anders aus?
Ja?
Ja, der hat jetzt...
Der hat jetzt...
Einige interessante neue...
Der hat jetzt links so eine...
So eine...
Navigation-Bar.
Aber der Inhalt vom Task-Manager ist doch immer noch genau der gleiche.
Erstmal zum Design.
Die haben da einfach irgendwie den neuen UWP-Wrapper drumherum gemacht.
Das ist doch alles, oder?
Die Leiste hier links passt doch auch schon mal gar nicht zu dem Rest rechts.
Auf den ersten Blick, dass der Task-Manager nun deutlich moderner aussieht.
Das kleine, tabsbasierte Interface wird ersetzt durch ein modernes, iconbasiertes Menü auf der linken Seite.
Alle...
Ich sag euch, Leute, das ist einfach nur ein Wrapper.
Um den alten Task-Manager.
Die haben hier die Task-Leistling gemacht und der Rest ist ganz normales Oldschool Win32-Zeug.
Elemente sind nun außerdem etwas größer.
Das hier.
Diese Liste.
Das ist wahrscheinlich einfach stinknormales Win32, embedded in irgendeinem UWP-Ding.
Interface wirkt an sich etwas aufgeräumter.
Der Task-Manager zeigt nun bei den Prozessen eine praktische Visualisierung der Ressourcen mit Hilfe eurer Akzentfarbe an.
So seht ihr relativ schnell, welche Programme gerade die meisten Ressourcen eures Computers sind.
Wahnsinns-Feature.
Außerdem unterstützt der Task-Manager nun einen dunklen Modus, welcher auch richtig fein aussieht.
Es handelt sich hierbei mehrheitlich um ein Redesign des bestehenden Programms.
Aber Microsoft hat sich immerhin ein neues Feature dafür überlegt.
Der Task-Manager unterstützt ab Windows 11 22H2 einen Effizienzmodus, welcher im Prozessetap für Programme aktiviert werden kann.
Das geht entweder direkt über die Menüleiste oder eben per Rechtsklick.
Und dann?
Wenn der Effizienzmodus für ein Programm aktiviert ist, limitiert das System, die verfügbar ist, die Funktion.
Prozess, sodass dieses Programm so effizient wie möglich ausgeführt wird.
Das heißt, das Programm bekommt dann weniger CPU-Zeit, auch wenn's die haben will, und
dann ruckelt's, oder wie?
Also mal angenommen, ich hab jetzt einen Browser, der eine Website hat, die eben relativ CPU-intensive
Animationsgeschiss und so macht, dann ruckelt's, oder wie?
Ja ok, doch, das ist tatsächlich ganz sinnig, wenn man Software verwendet, die unnötig
viel Leistung braucht, die man aber, die jetzt irgendwie, die du nicht flüssig brauchst,
ja?
Wenn du irgendeine kack-programmierte Software hast, die der Meinung ist, immer einen CPU-Kern
voll auszulasten, ja dann vielleicht.
Ok, ja, warum nicht?
Wobei ich's ein bisschen befremdlich finde, dass man das über den Task Manager macht.
Ich hätte eher erwartet, dass man das über, hier drüber macht.
Guckt, also ich hätte beispielsweise erwartet.
Wo haben wir hier?
Firefox?
Ja, nehmen wir mal hier Firefox, hier, dass man das hier drüber macht, hätte ich eigentlich
erwartet, ja?
Dass du das für die, für die, ähm, für das Programm festlegst, aber ok.
... ermöglicht dies, dass andere genutzte Programme die verfügbare Leistung des Systems
besser ausnutzen können.
Mit dem Effizienzmodus könnt ihr bestimmte Programme selbst gewissermaßen einfach kalt
stellen.
Dabei wird die Priorität auf gering geschaltet und das Programm läuft dann vorzugsweise
mit den effizientesten Kernen eures Prozessors.
Ok.
Moderne Prozessoren kommen immer häufiger mit Performance- und Effizienzkernen daher
und ihr als Nutzer könnt in Windows 11 bald ein bisschen genauer entscheiden, wie diese
Prozessorkerne genutzt werden.
Ja, ist ok.
Wenn ihr dieses Feature benutzten wollt, startet einfach den Task Manager und lasst die Prozessor
am besten nach CPU-Intensität absteigend auflisten.
Nun sucht euch jene Programme aus, die für euch weniger wichtig sind und steckt diese
einfach in den Effizienzmodus.
Windows 11 wird daraufhin die CPU-Nutzung dieser Programme optimiert.
Ja, ist in Ordnung.
Ok.
Die Taskleiste von Windows 11 ist eine der enttäuschendsten Neuerungen des Betriebssystems,
macht sie doch zahlreiche Abstriche im Vergleich zu Windows 10.
Viele Funktionen sind entweder bewusst gestrichen worden oder wurden einfach unbewusst aus Zeitgründen
nicht implementiert.
Oder schlechter als vorher.
Das Rechts-Link-Menü der Taskleiste ist in Windows 11 so gut wie unbrauchbar, aber auch
wichtige Funktionen.
Zum Beispiel die Unterstützung für Drag-and-Drop war nicht vorhanden.
Mit Windows 11 22H2 liefert Microsoft auch hier ein
Drag-and-Drop funktioniert nun endlich und sofern ihr in der Zwischenzeit vergessen habt,
wie das funktioniert, zeigen wir es euch ganz kurz her.
Einerseits könnt ihr wieder Programme an die Taskleiste anheften, indem ihr sie vom
Desktop oder vom Start-Menü direkt in die Taskleiste zieht.
Unglaublich.
Außerdem könnt ihr endlich wieder Dateien mit einem Programm aus der Taskleiste öffnen
mittels Drag-and-Drop.
Wenn ihr ein PDF-Dokument zum Beispiel mit einem gewissen Programm in der Taskleiste
öffnen wollt, zieht ihr die gewünschte Datei an die Taskleiste.
Das ist einfach unglaublich.
Ihr klickt einfach auf das Programm-Icon und es wird damit geöffnet.
Wie das ging in der Zwischenzeit nicht, so ziehe ich immer meine Videos in Vegas rein.
Ich mache den Ordner auf mit dem Footage und dann ziehe ich das über die Taskleiste in
Vegas.
Wie soll ich das sonst machen?
So einfach kann es gehen.
Unglaublich, dass es Microsoft bisher nicht implementiert hatte.
Windows 11 wurde zum Start ohne diese Features ausgeliefert, obwohl Windows 10 sie noch hatte
und jetzt sind sie wieder zu.
Der Witz ist echt.
Und vor allem so unsinnig.
Die haben eh in der Vergangenheit nicht mehr diese Features ausgeliefert, obwohl Windows
10 es noch nicht gab.
Aber die neuen Sachen sind dann teilweise schlechter als die alten, aber diese alten Sachen werden
dann entfernt.
Aber die alten Sachen, die einfach nur alt und kacke sind, die bleiben drinnen.
Okay, schönes Video, muss ich sagen.
Gut gemacht.
Aber die Änderungen, also wenn das die größten Änderungen sind, dann muss ich in nächster
Zeit auch nicht updaten.
Mein Kollege Armin wird in seinem ausführlichen Video noch viel genauer darauf eingehen, aber
ich wollte euch einfach mal eine kurze Zusammenfassung machen.
Ich hoffe, dass euch das Video gefallen hat und wenn ja, gebt mir gerne einen Daumen rauf
und abonniert unseren Kanal für noch mehr Tipps, Tricks und Tests rund um Windows 11.
Warum Windows 11 nicht empfehlenswert ist.
Okay.
WTF?
Minecraft Let's Play, hör mal auf.
Minecraft Let's Play kann ich mir jetzt nicht geben.
Es funktioniert eigentlich nicht aus.
Ähm, so, was haben wir denn als nächstes?
Äh, Moment.
Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
Oh ja, die eine neue Map, die kommt, hui!
Ja, wir wissen, er sagt, Create Changes Ahead, bla bla bla, dann kommen keine Create Changes.
Und am Ende fragt er uns dann, ob wir jetzt denken, dass Battlefield 2042 da mit in einem besseren Spot ist.
Und dann ist das Video fertig, immer das gleiche.
Soll ich euch mal was sagen?
Real Talk, das ist kein Easter Egg.
Das ist kein Easter Egg.
Die haben einfach die Kiste copy-pasted von der neuen Map auf Kaleidoskop.
Die waren einfach zu faul.
Die Description für die Playercard hinkt an eine Dark-Market-Organisation.
Dataminer Tempriyal hat letztens Datamined, was die Season 2-Map sein könnte,
und er hat erwähnt, dass es etwas mit der Dark-Market-Organisation zu tun hat.
Und bevor wir in diese Details kommen, habe ich eine kurze Worte von heute's Sponsor.
Wachst du in der Morgen, schaust in die Fenster und denkst dir, es scheint weniger Haar anzunehmen.
Das ist kein Easter Egg.
Die Kiste hier.
Je schneller du mit Kabelkapp startest und mit der Medikamenten-Routine in 12 Monaten sprichst,
um die Ergebnisse zu sehen, werden diese Bücher in die Kiste gehen.
So ist es.
Die Kiste ist 50% auf der Kiste.
Geh zurück.
Die Welt-Map-News.
Die 2042-Season-2-Map wird wahrscheinlich in oder um Ganten-Lake Panama gesetzt.
Das ist eine Artifizierte Fläche mit einem Damm und einem beschäftigten Schiff-Block-Port.
Initiale Spekulationen, basierend auf der vorhergeschlossenen Konzeptart,
sagen, dass die Map sein könnte.
Mit Physik hatten sie es in diesem Video aber auch nicht sonderlich, oder?
Ha! Backstory! Welche Backstory?
Es gab den Irish-Film und sonst nix.
In den aktuellen Events gibt es eine starke Möglichkeit,
dass es hinkt, dass das Setting für die Ganten-Lake-Map Temporial gefunden hat.
Die Gebäude sehen authentisch aus und haben noch nicht im Spiel gesehen.
Temporial hat noch keine Konzeptart oder visuelle Inhalte für die neue Map gefunden.
Es ist jeder Meinung, was es sein wird.
Also es gibt News, dass es, habe ich das richtig verstanden?
Es gibt News, dass es keine News gibt, dass es eine neue Map gibt, über die wir nichts genaues wissen.
Aber es scheint sehr wahrscheinlich, dass wir irgendeine Art von,
wie die Flut in Panama Town oder der remote Location in Saison 2 beeinflusst hat.
Temporials Findings kombiniert mit dem neuen in-game Easter Egg und Spieler-Karten
lehnen viel Kredibilität zu seinen Spekulationen.
Die Saison-2-Update wird im frühen September eröffnet werden.
DICE wird wahrscheinlich mehr Infos über die Saison-2 auf Montag
während ihrer nächsten Entwicklungs-Update erläutern.
Wann startet das? Wann?
DICE wird wahrscheinlich mehr Infos über die Saison-2-Update erläutern
und die Spieler-Karte lehnt viel Kredibilität zu seinen Spekulationen.
Die Saison-2-Update wird im frühen September erläutert werden.
DICE wird wahrscheinlich mehr Infos über die Saison-2 auf Montag
während ihrer nächsten Entwicklungs-Update erläutern.
Wann startet das? Wann startet das?
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, dass man zu den Battlefield 3 und Battlefield 4 DLCs
oder sagen wir mal Erweiterungen,
teilweise im Monaten voraus schon Teaser-Material und Maps und so gesehen hat?
... eine volle Erweiterung der Saison-2-Informationen.
Diese Broadcasts sind generell mehr...
Nee, das spielt keiner mehr.
Du meinst Hazard Zone.
Hazard Zone ist auch eingestellt.
DICE hat gesagt, die entwickeln das nicht weiter.
... auf die Gameplay-Updates und die Veränderungen, die DICE anbietet.
Das heißt, sie könnten endlich das Spezialist-System-Auflösen erläutern,
das wir seit Monaten warten.
Was denkt ihr von all dieser Info?
Seid ihr gespannt auf die mögliche neue Map?
Bist du auf Overwatch 2 gehypt?
Nee, gar nicht.
Weiß gar nicht, soll das jetzt nicht demnächst sogar rauskommen?
Das wissen wir in den Kommentaren.
Star-Citizens-Developer haben signifikante Veränderungen zu den Statt- und Gefängnissen des Spiels erläutert.
und den Statt- und Gefängnissen des Spiels erläutert.
Und über alles, was die Korea-Station auf dem Markt erarbeitet hat,
und über alles, was die Korea-Station auf dem Markt erarbeitet hat,
wird die PVP-Fokus, die diese Station vorher hatte, zurückgebracht.
Aber immerhin!
Hier sieht man wenigstens, dass das Geld, was gesammelt wurde,
in irgendeiner Art und Weise in die Spieleentwicklung fließt.
Ich mein, die haben ja durchaus was vorzuweisen, vorzuzeigen bei Star Citizen.
Es hat halt immer noch nix mit dem zu tun, was eigentlich rauskommen soll, aber...
Ja!
Was macht eigentlich das Single-System?
Was macht eigentlich das Single-System? Was macht eigentlich das Single-System?
... der schon vor drei Jahren erscheinen sollte.
Korea will get a new NPC security force, a contraband dispenser,
and it'll be the only place that you can hack your crime stat away.
This is proving to be a very divisive change for players.
Many feel the burden of Star Citizens' bugs causing accidental crime stats
will far outweigh the fun factor of making Korea a PVP-focused area of such high importance.
The devs are also working on updates to the game's central prism.
Ah, das spiel ich perma Death?
ein Permadeath-Game im Leben nicht in die PvP-Ära gehen.
... und Klescher.
Die Gefangenen-NPCs werden in die Käfen gelegt, um die sonst isolierte Location zu vermischen.
Sie geben auch einige interessante neue Missionen ein, die man aufgrund von Kriminellen, die außerhalb des Gefängnissystems sind, akzeptieren kann.
Diese Missionen werden lukrativ sein und dich wahrscheinlich mit einer direkten Ausflugstrafe oder einer Art,
deine Gefängnis-Sentenz massiv zu reduzieren.
Diese veröffentlichten Änderungen scheinen wie ein Versuch, die schweren Konsequenzen von Krimi und Tod in Star Citizen zu erneuern.
Aber wegen der Alpha-State des Spiels und der Plethora von Bugs,
hören wir News, dass die Krimi-Krise in der Klinik in der Klinik in der Klinik in der Klinik in der Klinik
und das Krimi-Krise-System noch mehr verurteilt werden wird,
fühlt sich an, als wäre es wahrscheinlich nicht das richtige System, auf das wir uns gerade konzentrieren.
Zum Beispiel ein Überfall und eine Verletzung von Bugs...
...
Ich meine, die müssen da Shooter-Mechaniken einbauen.
Das ist das einzige, wo die Cry-Engine wirklich gut drin ist.
Was... Ich meine, es sieht nicht umsonst aus wie Crysis hier gerade, so.
... auf das aktuelle Krimi-System, damit Spieler nicht...
Es sieht halt auch jedenfalls aus wie Crysis.
... immer wieder Kriminell werden oder Bugs nicht, die sie nicht verursachen, Kriminelle zu werden,
wäre viel wichtiger, um zu veröffentlichen, bevor man ein System wie dieses einbaut.
Die Gemeinschaft hat sich ziemlich vokal über die Veränderungen, die in Korea kommen,
mit vielen Leuten gesagt, dass es die falsche Richtung für das Spiel ist, in seinem aktuellen Zustand.
Hoffentlich wird CIG das Feedback ansehen, es gibt keine exakte ETA auf die Veränderungen,
aber wir bekommen später mehr Infos in diesem Quartal.
Ich frage mich nicht, warum ich den jetzt über den Bildschirm habe rollen lassen, aber es musste mal sein.
Habt ihr auch diese Öl, ähm...
... Bohrstationen-Mission gesehen und mit dem Schiff?
Ich fand, das sah so langweilig aus.
So durchgescriptet und langweilig.
Das hat mich so überhaupt nicht abgeholt.
Modern Warfare 2 wird am 28. Oktober veröffentlicht,
aber die neue Battle Royale-Erfahrung und die mögliche Tarkov-like Extraction-Mode, die DMZ genannt wird,
sind wahrscheinlich noch...
... dann sind die auch so mega langsam noch über diese Bohrstation geschlichen, wo nix passiert. Ich fand das mega langweilig.
... am 16. November, basierend auf dem verlinkten Dokument.
Die Nachricht sieht ziemlich legitim aus, obwohl es als Spekulation genommen werden sollte, bis es anders gelesen wird.
Assumieren wir, dass es wahr ist, ist es ein signifizierter Veränderung des Eröffnungs-Schedules von Warzone 1.
Der original Battle Royale-Modus wurde 2020, ein paar Monate nach dem Eröffnungs-Schedule von Modern Warfare, eröffnet.
In offiziellen Call of Duty-News wurde die letzte Saison für Warzone eröffnet.
Es heißt Last Stand und beginnt am 24. Oktober.
Diese Update wird wahrscheinlich die fortschrittliche Storyline von Warzone beenden.
Ich bin mal gespannt, wie sie das machen.
Ich meine, die Leute haben doch mittlerweile sau viel in Warzone reingekommen.
Ja, sowohl auch an Season Passes und Unlocks und alles.
Ob das dann alles weg sein wird mit Warzone 2?
Da bin ich, da bin ich, äh, bin ich gespannt.
Vielleicht gibt's dazu schon was, vielleicht wisst ihr was, keine Ahnung.
Last Stand Update will add Volcanic Activity to the game's current default map, Caldera.
It will introduce a new Gulag, themed around the Volcanic Activity.
New Doomsday Stations are also being added that reward you with powerful in-game-
Es gibt aktuelle nicht so viele, gute Frage.
Es gibt aktuell nicht so viele Games, wo ich mich wirklich drauf freue.
Also ich bin auf das nächste God of War gespannt.
Mal schauen, ob das wirklich noch dieses Jahr kommt.
Sie sagen ja, das ist so, aber naja.
Na ja.
Mal schauen, ob das, ob das wirklich so ist.
Das ist das erste, was mir so aus dem Stehgreif einfällt, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich freu mich auf einen neuen Dark Freeshot im Ende des Jahres,
weil ich dieses Uralt-Game immer noch gerne spiele nebenbei.
Ähm, ist aber kein neues Game.
Ne, Hunt Showdown hab ich noch nie probiert.
Ich bin mir auch nicht sicher, ob man da jetzt noch gut einsteigen kann.
Ansonsten, was kommt denn dieses Jahr?
Kommt, kommt dieses Jahr noch etwas?
Kommt noch irgendwas Spannendes?
Das hab ich auch offen, das Video.
Das wollte ich mir nachher angucken.
Äh, Eden, mein ich.
Da läuft dieses Wochenende gerade die Alpha, aber Alpha hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Vielleicht macht Phoenix auch was Neues.
Bin mal gespannt, was da rauskommt.
Äh, okay.
Upcoming Game Releases 2022.
Lass das mal ganz kurz durchgucken.
Äh, was gibt's denn da?
Hat Gamesport, gibt's da irgendwie eine schöne Seite?
So.
Also, was haben wir denn hier zu bieten?
August, was kommt denn da noch?
Äh, vielleicht auch irgendwas mit Bildchen.
Nix dabei, was mich interessiert.
Cursed to Golf.
Alter, der Name allein schon.
Nix dabei, nix dabei, nix dabei, nix dabei.
Splatoon 3, nee.
Also, ich hab jahrelang Call of Duty mit P2P-Hosting gespielt.
Das brauch ich jetzt auch nicht in Splatoon 3.
Last of Us 1 Remake, nee.
Also, ein drittes Mal brauch ich jetzt Last of Us 1 nicht wirklich.
Ähm, Temtem, das ist für die ganzen Pokémon-Leute vielleicht ganz nice.
So, nix dabei, nix dabei, nix dabei, nix dabei.
Will sie kurz ein bisschen gedudelt anmachen.
Ups.
Das gäb's doch schon seit über einem Jahr.
Achso, für Playstation und Switch.
Das war gut.
Also, wer so Oldschool-RPGs mag, kann sich das, sollte sich das mal angucken.
So, Overwatch 2.
Overwatch 2 bin ich gar nicht gehypt drauf.
Überhaupt nicht.
Also, ich mein, die machen das Beste, was sie machen können daraus, indem's Free2Play wird.
Ja.
Aber, ob das nochmal den Hype-Level erreicht von Overwatch 1?
Ah, ich bin da skeptisch.
Diablo 4 kommt doch nicht mehr dieses Jahr.
Das würd mich sehr wundern.
So, ähm.
Juckt mich nicht, juckt mich nicht, juckt mich nicht.
Dass es die Serie immer noch gibt.
Vielleicht guck ich mir Modern War...
Ich werde mir wahrscheinlich Modern Warfare 2 mal angucken.
Einfach, einfach weil's, ja, weil ich alter Fanboy bin, aber eigentlich schon seit Jahren weg.
Aber ich will einfach wissen, was da rauskommt, ob sie's hinkriegen oder nicht.
Ja, Scorn hat man nicht viel gesehen.
Außer so ein paar Alien-Dinger mit Clipper-Zeug.
Da freu ich mich drauf.
God of War, äh, God of War...
Was ist es denn jetzt eigentlich?
5 ist es quasi, ne?
God of War 3 war noch auf der PS3, dann ist, dann ist es...
Theoretisch ist es God of War 5 quasi.
Ja.
Also da freu ich mich drauf.
Vielleicht hol ich mir dafür ne PS5.
Ich hab immer noch keine PS5, weil's nix gibt, was ich den Kauf gerechtfertigt hätte bisher.
Das Beste, was sie machen könnten für mich, wär natürlich das auf den PC bringen, aber das werden sie wahrscheinlich erst ein Jahr später wieder machen.
Ähm, was war denn das nochmal?
Das sagt mir irgendwas.
Upge...
Ne, das weiß ich nicht.
So, das war's.
Also es hält sich, es hält sich wirklich sehr in Grenzen.
Das einzige, was mich game-technisch noch schocken kann in nächster Zeit, wär Half-Life 3.
Ne, ähm...
Ach, das ist das, was wie Dead Space aussah.
Stimmt, stimmt, ja.
Also...
Mal gucken.
Ja, ich versteh's auch nicht. Für God of War vielleicht dann.
Aber bisher versteh ich's auch nicht.
Also ihr seht nicht so viel dabei, was mich hyped dieses Jahr.
Gucken wir mal, gucken wir mal kurz. Fertig.
Ja, Blizzard...
Leute.
Ernsthaft.
Glaubt irgendjemand noch, was Blizzard sagt?
Also da musst du...
Da fällt mir gar kein Vergleich ein.
Das ist quasi wie einer, der schon zehnmal aufs Maul gefallen ist und wieder vergessen hat, dass an der Stelle, was ihm gefällt...
So ungefähr ist das, wenn man Blizzard was glaubt.
Also Live-Service-Plan.
Das wichtige Hinweis ist, dass das kommende Action-RPG keine Lootboxen hat.
Die Fans der Franchise haben die Diablo...
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr, ihr wisst doch genau, was ist.
Blizzard sagt, es gibt keine Lootboxes.
Und am Ende baut Blizzard Lootboxes ein, nennt sie nicht Lootboxes und sagt dann...
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ihr wollt.
Wir haben keine Lootboxes.
Wir haben...
Setze Diablo benahmte Lootboxen ein.
Was wäre denn da ein schöner Name für?
Wir haben...
Keine Ahnung.
Mephistos Kleiderschrank.
Und das sind unsere Lootboxen.
Demonic Treasures, ja sowas, genau.
Es gab ja letztens diese Umfrage, die geschickt wurde, wie sehr man Pay2Win und Sachen tolerieren würde...
...und nur rein kosmetisch und so.
Das hat ja ein bisschen für ein bisschen Wind gesorgt.
Aber ich glaube, Blizzard...
Nichts. Gar nichts mehr.
...utilisiert ein ähnliches System in Diablo 4.
Aber das klingt unwahrscheinlich.
Blizzard planiert, den normalen Battle Pass- und Kosmetik-Shop zu eröffnen...
...mit dem Spiel, in dem das echte Geld nicht etwas gibt, was den echten Gameplay beeinflusst.
Ja.
Das ist doch exakt das Gegenteil von dem, was sie gesagt haben.
Also es gibt, es gibt Lootboxen, aber keine Lootboxen, oder wie?
Und ich finde es auch, wirklich Leute, ich finde es sehr fragwürdig...
...dass das heute so weit akzeptiert ist, also dass da gar keiner mehr was sagt...
...dass in Vollpreisspiele mit, mit, mit teilweise noch...
Ich meine, guckt euch mal an, wie krass es mittlerweile in World of Warcraft ist.
Du kaufst das Game, du kaufst die Add-Ons, du kaufst ein Monats-Abo und du hast einen Shop.
Sogar mit Levelboost und solchen Sachen drinne, ja.
Ich verstehe es ja bis zu einem gewissen Punkt, dass man sagt, hey, wir bringen...
...also ich verstehe, dass es heute ein bisschen anders ist als früher.
Ja.
Früher haben viele Entwickler quasi nur aus, wie soll ich sagen, von Luft und Liebe und sonst wie gelebt.
Okay.
Dass das heute alles ein bisschen langfristiger abgesichert sein will, sein soll, verstehe ich.
Also wenn man ein Spiel rausbringt, das Spiel kostet 50 Euro, man supportet das Spiel fünf Jahre lang...
...dass man dann das nicht rein aus diesen 50 Euro...
...50 Euro, ja, Start bezahlen, finanzieren kann, das verstehe ich ja.
Das ist, das ist ja in Ordnung.
Aber es ist mittlerweile so selbstverständlich, dass Spiele rauskommen zum Vollpreis...
...und die enthalten standardmäßig einen Shop mit irgendwelchen Sachen drin.
Das, warum ist das mittlerweile einfach schon so akzeptiert?
Es wird dann immer gesagt, ach, ja, ja, das ist ja nur, das ist ja nur kosmetisch...
...und es hat doch keinen Einfluss aufs Spiel.
Das mit dem, okay, ob es Einfluss aufs Spiel hat oder nicht...
...ich meine, ich muss es zumindest sehen, ja.
Da kann man sich schon mal streiten, ob es Einfluss aufs Spiel hat oder nicht.
Aber okay, bei einem Free-to-Play-Spiel mag das nochmal alles anders aussehen.
Aber allein schon diese, die Existenz dieser Dinger und bei diesen krassen Preisen, die die teilweise haben wollen...
...15 Euro für ein Skin und sowas, Blizzard ist ja da eh schon nicht mehr ganz dicht...
...gibt es einen Faktor, der sehr wohl Einfluss hat auf mich, also sprich den normalen Spieler.
Auch wenn die Leute immer nur sagen, es ist kosmetisch.
Es gibt zwei Sachen, die haben sehr wohl auf mich.
Also das erste natürlich, ich muss es sehen, wenn andere damit rumlaufen, die reingecasht haben.
Okay, egal.
Aber es hat entscheidenden Einfluss drauf, wie Erfolge beziehungsweise erreichbar Sachen gemacht werden ingame.
Nehmen wir mal...
...weil es einfacher ist als Diablo, nehmen wir mal beispielsweise Gold-Skins in Call of Duty.
Wenn du den Gold-Skin erspielen kannst und nur erspielen kannst, dann haben die Entwickler einen gewissen Anreiz...
...dass dieser Gold-Skin zwar schwer zu erreichen ist, aber nicht 4000 Stunden Grind erfordert.
Weil niemand wird 4000 Stunden grinden, aber man könnte zum Beispiel so Sachen machen wie...
...mit dieser Waffe über 100 Games lang eine 5er Cut, irgendwas, was wirklich schwierig ist.
Könnte man machen.
Gibt es einen Gold-Skin, dann weiß jeder, aha, der Typ hat einen Gold-Skin, der hat die Waffe wirklich gemeistert, der hat den Gold-Skin verdient.
Ist jetzt solche Sachen wie Cosmetics beispielsweise ingame erreichbar?
Was hier wahrscheinlich immer gerne gemacht wird, um zu sagen, ja, man kann theoretisch mit Spielen auch alles erreichen.
Und im Shop, dann ist die Sache, kannst du sie im Spiel wirklich realistisch erreichen?
Also, muss ich 4000 Stunden jeden Tag die gleiche Daily machen, um es zu bekommen, anstatt 15 Euro auszugeben?
Und dann hat das ja wohl einen Einfluss auf mich als Spieler.
Weil ich werde keine 4000 Stunden grinden.
Und man hat diese 4000 Stunden grinden auch nur reingemacht, dass man Alibi-mäßig sagen kann, ja, es ist theoretisch erreichbar ingame.
Und man möchte allerdings ganz klar Kaufanreiz setzen.
Kauf sie doch für 15 Euro jetzt im Shop.
Das entwertet richtig, Trockenhorn, das entwertet auch diese Cosmetics, ja.
Zum Beispiel, nehmen wir mal ein Beispiel aus einem uralten MMO.
Dark Age of Camelot.
Nehme ich, weil ich das fast 10 Jahre gespielt habe.
So.
Dort gab es Waffen, die waren gar nicht schwer zu bekommen.
Das trifft übrigens auf moderne Games, moderne MMOs und moderne Pay to Win und so, trifft auf alle Games zu.
Dort gab es Waffen, die waren gar nicht mal, da waren die Gegner gar nicht schwer, die die gedroppt haben oder so.
Aber sie waren ein bisschen trickreich, ja.
Also man musste teilweise zur richtigen Tageszeit am richtigen Spot sein.
Hoffen, dass du jetzt Glück hattest auf den Drop.
Und diese Waffen waren an sich von den Stats her nichts besonderes.
Also halt Cosmetics, ja.
Das waren ganz normale Level 51 Waffen.
Auch von den Stats her gar nichts besonderes.
Aber die hatten einen Feuereffekt.
Also sprich, wenn du die Waffe gezogen hast, hat die gebrannt.
Was normale Level 51 Waffen nicht gemacht haben.
Und es war richtig cool damals zu sehen, dass halt so die richtig Hardcore Dedicated Leute sich diese Waffen gemacht haben.
Also sprich, wenn du die Waffe gezogen hast, hat die gebrannt.
Und du wusstest halt quasi, okay, jemand, der diese brennende Waffe hatte, das ist halt so der richtig krasse 24-7-No-Lifer.
Also ich hatte so eine Waffe natürlich.
Ist so der krasse 24-7-Kellersitzende No-Lifer, der nichts anderes macht, als diese Waffe zu crimen.
Aber du wusstest, das ist jemand, der höchstwahrscheinlich Ahnung von dem Game hat und da wirklich sehr viel Zeit und Energie reingesteckt hat.
Das hatte einen gewissen Schwanzvergleich wert.
Und du entwertest das komplett mit dem Wunder, du kannst es über einen Shop kaufen.
Wir reden ja hier nicht von einem Free-2-Play-Game, die sich finanzieren müssen.
Und deswegen finde ich es immer ein bisschen fragwürdig, dass es so komplett selbstverständlich ist,
dass ein Game zum Vollpreis erscheint, automatisch uprelease einen Shop bietet,
uprelease in-game, disharmony 10%.
Uprelease plays also einfach.
Währung bietet,
ab Release irgendwelche komischen
Packages bietet, die man kaufen kann,
ab Release
drei verschiedene Pre-Order Packages
und solche, das finde ich
wirklich bedenklich, dass das
so, dass da überhaupt keiner
mittlerweile mehr drüber nachdenkt. Ach ja, gut,
ist halt ein Cosmetics-Shop.
Wen juckt's? Ja, es juckt mich
schon. Mich
juckt das schon. Und gerade, wenn
Cosmetics entwertet werden und die Frage ist
ja natürlich auch, wie hoch
ist denn der Anreiz, schöne
Cosmetics zu machen, für
schwere Gegner, versus
schöne Cosmetics zu machen
für den Shop. Also stellt euch mal vor,
ihr habt jetzt ne
Art-Abteilung, wo Blizzard ja wirklich sehr gute
Leute hat, und die
überlegen sich jetzt ein paar Wochen lang
für jede Klasse coole Rüstungsskins
und
jetzt haben die die Auswahl, keine Ahnung,
die suchen sich die 10 schönsten
Skins raus. Und jetzt haben sie die
Auswahl. Wie verteilen wir das?
Packen wir von den 10 schönsten
Skins 8 in Shop
und 2 vielleicht als
quasi rare Boss-Drop?
Oder umgedreht?
Was machen wir jetzt?
Hmm. Natürlich
packt man die schönsten Skins und
die besten Skins nach
Möglichkeit nur in Shop,
wegen Money, oder eben hinter
so ner riesen Grind-Barriere,
dass es keiner wirklich realistisch
erspielen kann. Sie werden das wahrscheinlich
hinter ner Grind-Barriere verstecken, um
so alibimäßig zu sagen, ja, wieso?
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ist. Also, wenn
du jetzt ein halbes Jahr 24-7
spielst, du kannst doch alles ingame erreichen.
Und dann hast du Leute, die verteidigen
das auch die ganze Zeit noch so krass, so nach dem Motto
Ja, dann spiel doch normal, das
muss doch keiner machen, du musst es doch nicht kaufen,
dann spiel das Spiel doch nicht.
Das ist immer der gleiche Kram. Ich weiß gar
nicht, was die Leute sich erhoffen.
Ehrlich gesagt, mir ist es ein absolutes Rätsel,
was die Leute, die das immer so krass
verteidigen, sich erhoffen.
Ich kann mir ehrlich gesagt nur zwei Sachen vorstellen.
Erstens,
sie wollen sich selbst schönreden,
das Geld, was sie da schon reingesteckt
haben.
Also sprich, das sind vielleicht Leute,
die selbst schon viel im Shop ausgegeben haben
und das jetzt, ja,
seelisch, moralisch, wie auch immer
nicht verkraften, dass
ihnen jemand sagt, das war ne doofe Idee.
Das kennt man ja in vielen anderen Bereichen
auch. Ja, wenn einer 10 Jahre lang
Kacke macht, dann
neigt er dazu auch noch, auch wenn er es
besser wissen müsste ab dann,
ein elftes Jahr Kacke zu machen, weil er dann quasi
in Frage stellt, wenn er das aufhört
zu machen, dass er die letzten, also, dass er
was Sinnvolles gemacht hat, die letzten 10 Jahre über.
So.
Und das Zweite ist, was ich mir
vorstellen könnte, warum das Leute so krass verteidigen,
weil die in irgendeiner
Art und Weise den Fanboy des Monats
Award gewinnen wollen. Nur mit dem
Umkehrschluss, dass es keinen Fanboy
des Monats Award gibt.
Also es ist jetzt ja nicht so,
dass sich Jeff Kaplan,
ist ja gar nicht mehr Overwatch, dass
der dich dann per Twitter DM anschreibt
und sagst, alter krass, du bist der größte
Overwatch-Freund aller Zeiten, hier hast du ne T-Shirt
oder sowas.
Okay, wenn das so wäre, dann könnte ich's noch
verstehen, aber nein, es ist ja nicht so.
Das ist ja nicht, dass irgendwie die Leute
den Fanboy des, es gibt keinen Fanboy
des Monats Award. Die werden wahrscheinlich sogar
noch ausgelacht bei den Herstellern. Wie kann man
so doof sein?
Also insofern kann ich's nicht
verstehen.
Leuchtet mir nicht ein. Na gut.
Wie heißt denn das Game?
Blizzard plans to release the usual Battle Pass
and Cosmetic Shop with the game, where
real world money won't get you anything
that affects the actual gameplay.
Dying Light 2 got a teaser
for its first major story DLC.
It's called... Moment.
Dying Light?
Es ist
nicht das mit den Killern und den Typen,
die man dann an so Haken aufhängt, oder?
Nee, Dying
Light ist das dieses Parcours-Zombie-Ding.
Wie heißt denn das Game
mit dem Killer, wo die Leute an so Haken
aufgehängt werden? Ich weiß, es hört sich jetzt
verstörend an, aber die Leute, die es
kennen, wissen, was ich
meine. Dead by Daylight?
Ja, genau.
Okay, das kann man
schon mal verwechseln.
Dying Light und Dead by Daylight.
Okay, das meinte ich.
Da hab ich grad irgendwie dran gedacht. Das sieht
aber komisch aus. Ah, das stimmt, das sind ja
unterschiedliche Games.
Dead by Daylight meinte ich.
Blood Ties. The teaser is a short video
showing a human character fighting a zombie
in what looks like a combat arena.
A full reveal for the DLC is happening
at Gamescom.
Before we get to our next story, I just wanted to say,
thanks for tuning in. If you've been watching our news
coverage this week, let us know if any stories
stood out to you in the comments.
Also, Alter, der hat echt perfekt zuniert.
Sieben Minuten was zu erzählen, ohne
was zu erzählen.
Consider subscribing. It's a few extra clicks, but in return, your sub box
will show our videos. Channel members also
get exclusive emotes and name badges
in chat to show off their extraordinary
support. Either way, we're always grateful
for your support.
YouTube Subscriptions ist der größte Müll überhaupt.
Ich hab das auch und ich würde es am liebsten
wieder abschalten, weil ich danach festgestellt
hab, wenn man YouTube Subscription hat bei mir.
Ich mein, ich bekomm da was. Insofern ist
das natürlich nice für mich, aber
die Emotes, die ich da hochgeladen hab,
die kann man nur bei mir verwenden,
auf gar keinem anderen Channel. Ich dachte
ursprünglich eigentlich, dass jemand,
der mich subscribt auf YouTube, meine Emotes
dann auch auf anderen Channeln verwenden kann.
Also, dass der dann coole Kekse
und Keks im Anzug,
Keks-Hackerman-Keks und sowas
spammen kann, auch in anderen Channels.
Aber nein, der kann das nur auf
meinem Channel verwenden. Komplett sinnlos.
Es ist auf Twitch viel besser. Auf Twitch kannst du
meine Emotes in allen Channels verwenden.
Embracer Group published their
latest earnings report, revealing some
jaw-dropping acquisitions.
Tripwire Interactive, Tuxedo Labs,
Limited Run Games, NIP Rights
to J.R.R. Tolkien's Lord of the Rings
and...
Herr der Ringe wird ja so extrem ausgeschlachtet
aktuell. Also...
Hobbit Books. That last one is
sure to raise some eyebrows.
In a nutshell, it gives Embracer the all-clear
to have the many game studios
it owns develop titles based on the
characters and stories from Tolkien's books.
And to clarify, it means that they can make
a game about the book version of
Frodo, not the movie version.
So, as long as they're avoiding too many
movie inspirations or similarities,
they should be fine. And based on
the associated press release, it sounds like
Embracer fully intends to...
Das ist halt so wieder...
Ist so geil, oder? Er hat im Prinzip gerade gesagt,
die haben die Rechte erworben,
dass sie jetzt quasi
auch Sachen
auf den Büchern basieren lassen können.
Was halt der Witz ist, es sollte
das nicht alles auf den Büchern basieren
und jetzt geht das nur, wenn sie
vermeiden, dass es zu sehr auf den Büchern
basiert. Alter, keine Wunder, dass
viele Umsetzungen einfach so rotz...
so kacke sind, ja?
Wenn du quasi
noch nicht mal das machen darfst, was du
vielleicht aus künstlerischer Sicht
am besten hältst...
Mein Mute mutet nicht komplett?
Oh, hab ich euch gerade ins Ohr gehustet?
Naja, gut.
Wir testen das mal.
Chat, ich sag jetzt was,
gemutet, und ihr sagt mir, was ich gesagt hab.
Was hab ich gesagt?
Du hast gesagt, Chat ist cute.
Okay, ich hab nix gehört.
Vielleicht hab ich einfach den Mute-Button nicht richtig gedrückt
vorhin. Oder es ist...
Es ist nur, wenn ich zu laut huste.
Wartet mal, testen wir mal. Ich mute mich...
Ich mute mich nochmal.
Tatsächlich, wenn ich ins Mikrofon huste...
Wenn ich ins Mikrofon huste, schlägt das hier aus.
Monka W!
Alles klar.
Mute mutet nicht korrekt.
Na gut, aber wenn ich quasi komplett
ins Mikrofon husten muss, dass ein bisschen was durchkommt,
dann mutet mir das genug.
So, was haben wir... Was können wir uns als nächstes angucken?
Reicht... Ne, was soll...
Was hat der Chat vorhin gepostet, soll ich angucken?
Das da.
So sehr hing Deutsch bei der Digitalisierung hinterher.
Heute-Show.
Oh, das ist bestimmt cringe.
Viele Beiträge von der Heute-Show
empfinde ich persönlich als äußerst...
äußerst...
cringe.
Was sagst du zum Alt-F4-Hype?
Zum was?
Ich geh nicht davon aus, dass du Alpha-4-Games meinst.
Äh...
Was ist denn der Alt-F4-Hype?
Das ist ein Spiel!
Okay, siehste mal.
Ich bin da nicht Zoomer genug. Keine Ahnung.
Soll das sein?
Äh...
Das sieht äußerst...
billig aus?
Sehr billig aus?
Das ist irgend so ein Streaming-Game,
was mal kurz funny ist für zwei Tagen
und dann ist es wieder vorbei.
Zumindest sieht das für mich in den Bildern so aus.
Twitch.
Mal gleich sehen, ob das ein Twitch-Hype-Game ist.
Äh, ist es gar nicht.
Ach, den wollte ich nur auf Deutsch.
Nee, bei mir im Video nicht.
Nee.
Ich hatte...
Speedrunners from Hell, oder wie das hieß,
mal ein paar Videos gezeigt.
Das war ein anderes Game.
Ich hab zu wenig Tabs offen.
Ja, deswegen hab ich ja hier noch Tabs offen
und in meiner 4M hab ich auch noch Tabs offen.
Dass es auch genug Tabs sind.
Ich mein, ich muss irgendwie meine 64...
Nee, 32...
Wie viel RAM hab ich?
Meine 32 GB RAM vollbekommen.
Guck mal.
Ich hab's nur geschafft,
24 GB von 31 GB RAM vollzubekommen.
Also, da fehlt noch ein bisschen was.
Ah, da geht schon...
Da geht schon noch was.
So, also, was meinte der Chat,
soll ich mir angucken?
Hier, das da.
Nee.
So sehr hinkt Deutschland bei der...
Leute, ich behalte mir vor,
wenn das zu cringig ist,
weil es ist immerhin ein Heute-Show-Video,
die treffen oftmals nicht so ganz meinen Humor,
das auszumachen, ja?
Aber mal gucken.
Wahrscheinlich ist es hyper-cringe.
Aber dass Deutschland bei der Digitalisierung hinterherhinkt,
hab ich oft genug gemerkt,
die letzten Jahre über.
Und es gab nur einen Fall,
wo ich gesagt hab,
der ist wirklich ganz okay mittlerweile.
Und da hab ich auch ein Video zu gemacht.
Und zwar, wo ich echt begeistert war, ist,
krank melden lassen über die App.
Über Apps.
Krank, also, krank...
Wie heißt das denn offiziell?
Krankmeldung, Krankschreibungszettel zu bekommen.
Das war okay.
Das lief wirklich gut.
Aber alles andere, was von Behörden ist
und was irgendwie so quasi offiziell so gemacht wird,
ist grausam.
Ich mein, hat irgendjemand eine elektronische Gesundheitsakte
benutzt irgendjemand seinen Personalausweis,
zur Authentifizierung, oder sowas?
Äh, naja, egal. Gucken wir mal.
Ich, ich, das Intro,
gegen das Intro hätte ich ja normalerweise nix.
Aber das ganze Intro wirkt schon wieder wie ZDF.
Boomer wollen lustig sein.
Aber okay.
Ja, versteh ich.
Ja, klar, da versteh ich dich.
Hier.
Mit?
Ja, vierstellige Betragsbeschränkungen.
Das klingt erstmal viel, jaja, klar.
Aber ist ja aufs Jahr gesehen.
Ja, das ist ne Betriebsausgabe, ja.
Ja, klar.
Ja, ich mach ja Stimmungsarbeit.
Und mit so nem Sekt, da arbeitet die Stimmung für mich.
Moment, ganz kurz.
Sorry, Leute, es ist Finanzamt.
Hab grad ein bisschen Stress.
Bitte?
Ob ich Belege hab für die gute Stimmung?
Ja, klar.
Ja, ich bin ja Deutschlands beliebtester Dreieinhalb-Sterne-Comedian.
Auf praktisch allen Ticket-Plattformen.
Ja, ich hab alle Bewertungen gespeichert.
Schick ich Ihnen dann per Mail.
Kleiner Spaß.
Es tut ja schon weh.
Das ist kleiner Spaß.
Das ist ne Berufskrankheit von mir.
Nee, natürlich nicht per Mail.
Ganz genau.
Auf dem regulären Wege.
Ja, wie immer.
Alles klar, mach ich.
Ja, ich hab sie sogar dabei schon.
Ich hab sie dabei.
Ja, alles klar.
Gut, danke.
Tschüss.
So schlimm ist es auch nicht, sagt er.
Scheint Geschmackssache zu sein.
Ich find das schlimm.
Hallo.
Na gut, das passt zur Digitalisierung in Deutschland.
So.
Hier bitte.
Alle Belege.
Handschriftlich.
In Sütterlin.
Warum nicht per Fax?
Hier den Wappen.
Vielen Dank.
Fax?
Ich bin ja kein Anfänger.
Okay.
Ganz so schlimm ist es natürlich nicht mit deutschen Behörden, aber fast.
In vielen anderen Ländern lassen sich Verwaltungsakte komplett digital erledigen.
Ja.
In Deutschland sollten Ende 2022...
Übrigens, wusstet ihr eigentlich, dass bis...
Könnte sogar bis 2022 sein.
Da hat doch vor ein paar Jahren hat doch irgendjemand erzählt,
dass Deutschland bis 2022 quasi alles digital machbar sein soll und sowas.
Und da habe ich damals glaube ich sogar noch auf Twitter das Ganze gequotet und mir gedacht,
naja, gucken wir mal 2022.
Das ist genauso, wie damals unsere Bundeskanzlerin noch geschrieben hat, ich glaube 2017 oder
so.
Wir müssen jetzt in Gigabit denken.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es bei euch daheim aussieht, ob da schon in Gigabit gedacht wird.
Also bei mir wird noch nicht in Gigabit gedacht.
600 Behördengänge digital erledigbar sein.
Bis jetzt kann ich davon gerade mal 15 Prozent vom Klo aus...
Boah, Wahnsinn, doch so viel.
Vom Sofa aus erledigen.
Dabei hat sich die Politik doch so viel Mühe gegeben.
Peter Altmaier hat sogar zwei Kisten Grauburgunder darauf gewettet, dass Deutschland bis 2021 die bürgerfreundlichste Verwaltung hat.
2001.
Wie ist denn das ausge...
Also da kannst du davon ausgehen, wenn irgendwie einer sowas vom Stapel lässt.
Das ist einfach schon so realitätsfremd.
Da müsste richtig massiv was passieren.
Also du müsstest quasi direkt merken, da wird alles umgekrempelt, dass das funktioniert.
Und nachdem du das nicht mitbekommen hast, dass das dann wirklich eintritt.
Rein vom Sagen passiert sowas halt nicht.
Ach ja, auf dich Peter.
Ist Alkoholkonsum auf Twitch erlaubt?
Sorry, das nimmt mich irgendwie mit, dass wir als Deutsche da nicht die Besten sind.
Deutschland ist so digital wie nie.
Deutschland ist so digital wie ein Grammophon.
Boah, so viel Wein.
Das wird in Studien immer wieder bestätigt.
In einem viel beachteten Digitalranking stehen wir unter den 20 wichtigsten Industrieländern weit abgeschlagen an drittletzter Stelle.
Okay, drittletztes, ja.
Wir sind quasi Hertha BSC.
Ich habe nicht so viel Ahnung von Fußball, aber ich habe mal jemanden aus Berlin gefunden...
By the way, bei der so nochmal eingeworfen.
Wir sind das viertreichste Land der Welt.
Also wirtschaftstechnisch, ja.
Und uns geht's...
Also uns müsste es eigentlich...
Was das angeht, möglich sein, besser zu sein als viele andere Länder.
Aber es ist halt die Frage, wofür du das Geld verwendest.
Und der meinte, das sei furchtbar.
Und ich meinte es auch nicht so, als würden wir wenig Steuern bezahlen.
Okay, aber wie viel besser läuft das denn in anderen Ländern?
Bestimmt nicht so viel besser, oder?
Leider doch.
In Spanien zum Beispiel haben 80% der Haushalte einen Glasfaseranschluss.
In Deutschland nicht mal 15%.
Da bekommt außerdem jede Bürgerin und jeder Bürger eine digitale Signatur.
Mit der man fast alles von zu Hause machen kann.
Von Impftermin bis zur Ummeldung.
Spanien hat sogar sein gesamtes Gesundheitssystem.
Eine Sache.
Ich will mal nicht alles nur auf die politischen Entscheidungen schieben.
Vieles liegt halt auch daran, dass die Leute das nicht annehmen und nicht wollen.
Das geht allerdings, das muss ich jetzt sagen, das geht so ein bisschen Hand in Hand.
Wenn die Sachen, die quasi entwickelt werden, also wenn sie die offiziellen Lösungen,
ja von Gesundheitsakte bis Personalausweis und so was,
wenn diese Lösungen kompliziert sind oder sagen wir mal unterm Strich,
wenn diese Lösungen kacke sind, sodass sie keiner verwenden will,
dann kann ich den Leuten nicht übel nehmen, dass sie nach einer Weile sagen,
alter, ich hab keinen Bock auf den Kram.
Und die haben mittlerweile halt gelernt, dass so gut wie nix von dem, was da so kommt,
durchdacht ist.
Und sinnvoll, ja, umgesetzt ist.
Das geht so ein bisschen Hand in Hand.
Die Leute in Deutschland sind eh schon relativ technikfeindlich und sagen wir mal technik-skeptisch.
Und wenn dann noch die Sachen auch ultra-kompliziert sind,
teilweise für viele Leute, die da nicht so drin sind,
komplizierter als per Fax was zu schicken,
ja dann schicken die lieber weiter was per Fax und sagen,
ja warum soll ich den neuen Scheiß denn verwenden?
Deutsche Startups, das ist tatsächlich so,
ich weiß nicht, ob ich schon mal erzählt habe,
ich hab letztens was gelesen,
dass es in Deutschland relativ viele Startups gibt,
allerdings natürlich auch im Technologie-Sektor und halt auch solche typischen Startup-Sachen,
so ich hab eine neue App-Idee oder ich hab eine neue Service-Idee oder so,
gibt's auch.
Aber viele deutsche Startups, denen scheint es ganz gut zu gehen,
weil sie genau das machen.
Die erklären den großen Firmen, wie Technik funktioniert.
Die großen Firmen sind mittlerweile so weit hinten dran,
dass du quasi kleinere Läden brauchst,
die irgendwie halbwegs erklären, wie die Sache läuft.
Aus diesem Grund sind viele deutsche Startups erfolgreich,
weil sie genau das machen.
Den Oldschool-Boomer-Riesen-Unternehmen erklären,
wie man 2022 manche Sachen ordentlich erledigt.
Ja, ihr habt recht, Chat, ihr habt recht.
Google Street View, Alter!
Wir sind das einzige Land der Welt,
wo Google Street View angefangen wurde und dann abgebrochen wurde,
weil Google sich gedacht hat, fickt euch.
Was ich auch verstehen kann,
das war ein riesen Ding damals,
wie die Leute Panik geschoben haben.
Wisst ihr, bei den Amis haben die Leute extra in ihre Kornfelder
Dinger reingedingst, dass der Satellit das sieht
oder dass das Auto das aufnimmt.
Und bei uns, ho!
Der hat mein Fenster gefilmt!
Anzeige ist raus!
Gutes Bild.
Ich weiß nicht, was es genau darstellen soll, aber ja.
Und ob es irgendwas mit was es auch immer sein soll
oder einfach nur ein Witz, aber ja.
Ach, das ist Google Street View.
Ja.
Das wundert mich nicht.
Genauso stelle ich mir das vor, ja.
Ach, die Österreicher wollten das auch nicht, oder wie?
Oder ist das hier einfach Gebirge, wo niemand rumgefahren ist?
Okay, wir gucken uns das erst mal. Fertig.
...jahren jeder Äste einen elektronischen Personalausweis,
der gleichzeitig Führerschein ist,
Bahnticket und sogar Versicherungskarte.
Wenn ich Äste wäre, könnte ich jede einzelne staatliche Dienstleistung
vom Klo aus abwickeln.
Sofa, Sofa.
Wichtig.
Nee, komm, sind wir ehrlich.
Ich will alles vom Klo aus machen, okay?
Ja, ich auch.
Ist das zu viel verlangt?
Sogar in der Ukraine, und die hat, weiß Gott, größere Probleme,
gibt es eine staatliche App,
die fast alle staatlichen Dienstleistungen online anbietet.
Seit Kriegsbeginn kann man mit der App
sogar die Standorte russischer Truppen direkt ans Militär melden.
In Berlin kann ich noch mal sagen,
in Berlin kann ich noch nicht mal online
meinen Hund bei der Steuerbehörde anmelden.
Ich bin mal gespannt.
Mal angenommen, das klappt mit neuem Auto
dieses Jahr noch bei mir.
Ob man das, ob man das auch online machen kann?
Also mit Anmeldung?
Wahrscheinlich muss ich ja,
wahrscheinlich kann ich den Antrag einreichen online
und muss dann aber selbst noch irgendwo hin oder so.
Nee, im Leben?
Nee, was jetzt?
Das dachte ich mir, dass das nicht funktioniert, ne?
Hab ich neulich nicht angemeldet.
Was muss ich denn hin?
Das Nummernschild abholen oder wie?
Ich kann wahrscheinlich einfach online einen Termin machen, ja.
Super.
Geil.
Digitalisierung.
Egal.
Mal gucken.
Mon castille.
Mal gucken, ob das was wird mit neuem Auto dieses Jahr.
Ich sag's noch mal kurz für alle,
weil ihr am Anfang nicht dabei wart hier.
Vielleicht, vielleicht, hab ich noch auf?
Ja, hab ich nicht mehr auf.
Ja, also mein, mein Auto macht's nicht mehr lange.
Vermute ich mal.
Und ich hab grad geguckt nach einem Elektroauto.
Bei mir ist aktuell der Fiat 500e in der näheren Auswahl
und es ist halt, was Lieferzeiten angeht, absoluter Wahnsinn, ja.
Wenn du das wirklich so customised bestellst, wie du haben willst,
also sprich, dass die das in Italien oder wo auch immer bauen für dich,
dann musst du teilweise 14 Monate warten.
Das mach ich nicht.
Also, der einzige, die einzige Chance, die es gibt,
dass halt noch irgendein Händler einen hat, der fertig ist
und mir die Farbe egal ist und mir das Paket egal ist
und ich den irgendwie noch bekomme,
weil dieses Jahr gibt's noch 9000 Euro Förderung
und ab nächstem Jahr nur noch 4500 Euro,
wenn ich das richtig im Kopf hab.
Und ganz ehrlich,
39.000 Euro für einen kleinen, kleinen Wagen, ja,
das will ich nicht ausgeben.
Mit ein bisschen Rabatt und ein bisschen Förderung,
dass man unter 30.000 Euro kommt
oder vielleicht so irgendwie auf 28.000 Euro,
das würde ich mir noch gefallen lassen.
Aber ansonsten kauf ich mir kein Elektroauto.
Aber vielleicht lass ich mein altes Auto auch,
noch mal fixen, ein bisschen besser,
dass der Schlauch auch hält und sowas,
dann kauf ich mir vielleicht dieses Jahr auch gar keins.
Ja, nach einem i-Up hab ich auch schon geguckt.
Ich will kein Porsche und ich will auch kein super fettes Auto.
Ich will so ein richtig kleines Kackding,
wie ich jetzt auch hab.
Und der Fiat hat mehr oder weniger die gleichen Abmessungen wie meiner.
Ich mein, ich hab ja aktuell ein,
in grün, das ist ein Elektroauto.
Was ist das, ein VW, oder?
Ich hab ja aktuell so ein Teil, in grün.
20 Jahre altes Auto.
Also so langsam aber sicher wird's mal wieder Zeit.
Ich mein, ich fahr ja so gut wie nicht.
Das wisst ihr ja und ihr wisst auch,
dass ich nicht, also ich fahr,
die meisten würden wahrscheinlich sagen,
ich fahr auch nicht sonderlich gut Auto
oder ich fahr auch nicht gerne Auto, muss ich sagen.
Ich bin nicht der große Autofahrer.
Und ich hätte aber schon Bock auf ein modernes Auto.
Das muss ich ehrlich mal zugeben.
Auch wenn ich immer sag, das Ding hier reicht mir.
Das reicht mir auch.
Aber ich hätte insofern Bock schon mal auf ein,
auf ein, ähm,
auf ein modernes Auto,
weil ich einfach moderne Technik mag.
Und Elektroautos für mich irgendwie,
wie soll ich sagen,
so ein Zwischending aus moderner Technik
und modernes Auto sind.
Ich kann das, kann das,
kann das schwer, schwer beschreiben.
Für mich ist ein Elektroauto näher an
einem Desktoprechner dran,
als ein Auto mit Verbrennungsmotor.
Es klingt jetzt, ich weiß, es ist ein bescheuerter Vergleich.
Es ist beides ein Auto.
Aber bei einem modernen Elektroauto ist,
weiß ich, hab ich eher das Gefühl,
ich kauf mir einen neuen Rechner,
als wie wenn ich mir ein neues Auto kaufe.
Neues Auto kaufen hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Neues, modernes Elektroauto kaufen,
hätte ich schon Bock drauf.
Das MG4 Electric ist auch top.
Fahr man nen Tesla,
die sind mir eigentlich zu teuer.
Ich mein, ich will nicht mehr als 30.000 Euro ausgeben.
Und das inklusive Förderung.
Das seh ich nicht ein.
Ich mein, ich könnte mir das schon leisten,
ich will das aber nicht.
Ich seh's nicht ein.
Und ich mein, einer der Gründe,
warum's mir finanziell ganz gut geht,
ist ja, weil ich eben nicht jeden Scheiß kaufe.
Sprich, ich gebe weniger Geld aus,
als ich einnehme.
Irgendwo muss es ja herkommen.
Das spornt ja nicht einfach bei mir aufm Konto.
Und ich geb einfach ungern mehr Geld aus,
als nötig.
Wenn du ein Tesla vom Band bekommst,
ja gut, wenn das so schwierig ist,
dann wartest du da wahrscheinlich auch 2 Jahre drauf.
Tja, das sag ich doch.
Das ist doch grade das,
was ich versucht hab zu erklären.
Auf ein neues Auto,
auf ein modernes Elektroauto,
auch mit der Technik drin und allem,
da hätt ich schon Bock drauf.
Weil sich's für mich eher anfühlt,
als ein Auto, das halt fährt,
versus ein Verbrennerauto.
Das ist für mich,
ein Auto ist für mich langweilig.
Ein modernes Elektroauto find ich irgendwie,
vom Gefühl her,
spricht mich das irgendwie
mehr an.
Ich kann das schlecht erklären.
Ich bin halt technikbegeistert
und nicht autobegeistert.
Also, ich würde normalerweise nie
30.000 Euro für ein neues Auto ausgeben.
Ich würde halt 30.000 Euro
für ein neues Elektroauto ausgeben,
auch von der Ausstattung und der Elektronik
und der Technik und allem zusagt.
Und halt fährt und klein ist
und sich gut eignet für das, was ich machen muss.
Normalerweise würde ich nie im Leben
30.000 Euro für ein Auto ausgeben.
Hab ich schon.
Fuck.
Ich bestell mir doch kein Auto,
ohne dass ich Probe gefahren bin.
Okay, das war gelogen,
Chat, das stimmt nicht.
Ich habe nicht Probe gefahren,
aber ich habe einen Termin zum Probefahren.
Nächste Woche Montag.
Morgen.
Morgen Vormittag.
Da bin ich nämlich echt mal gespannt drauf.
Ich bin noch nie Elektroauto gefahren.
Keine Ahnung, wie sich das anfühlt.
Du kannst mich snipen, ja, snipe mich.
Leasing oder Auto-Apo,
kommt das in Frage?
Ungern eigentlich.
Ich habe mir das mit Leasing auch überlegt,
ob ich das machen soll.
Ich meine, da ist der Kram ja immer direkt lieferbar.
Aber da würde ich mir permanent Gedanken machen,
was weiß ich, durch jeden Huppel, wo ich drüber fahre,
ob ich das nicht am Ende bezahlen muss.
Bis, wenn ich das am Ende dann behalten will.
Falls man das behalten will.
Wahrscheinlich will man es gar nicht behalten.
Das lohnt sich wahrscheinlich preislich nicht.
Und dann musst du dir nach zwei Jahren überlegen,
welches neue Auto.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Leasing was für mich ist.
Ich bin mir da unschlüssig.
Das probiere ich am Montag aus.
Das probiere ich am Montag mal aus.
Also was ich schon gehört habe,
ist, dass beim Fiat 500e
das Display manchmal laggt.
Ähm...
Ihr wisst, dass ich auf laggende
Bedienelemente relativ
allergisch reagiere.
Also es kann sein, dass ich gleich sage, gibt es nicht.
Aber gut, mal schauen.
Eine Frage nach deiner Meinung.
Hatte einen Nebenjob
während der Ausbildung für 10 Stunden
die Woche in der IT.
Nun, sollte aber
die komplette Anmeldung
für 20 Euro.
Hä? Was ist das für eine Logik?
Also neben deiner Ausbildung,
hast du noch einen Nebenjob gemacht in der IT.
Und die wollten jetzt, dass du in deinem Nebenjob
die IT komplett neu machst.
Naja.
Also da hängt ja auch einiges an Verantwortung
dran. Das würde ich mir dann tatsächlich
ordentlich bezahlen lassen.
Ansonsten haben sie halt Pech gehabt.
Die müssen sich aber alle dran gewöhnen.
Gerade in aktuellen Zeiten, wo jetzt nicht
auf jedem Baum einer sitzt, den man
gebrauchen kann, dass man den Leuten
ordentliche Arbeitsbedingungen und ordentliche Konditionen
bieten muss. Und wenn man das nicht kann,
dann haben sie halt
Pech. Dann gibt es halt keinen, der das macht.
Dann müssen sie sich halt entweder irgendeinen
Dienstleister suchen, was wahrscheinlich
noch teurer wird. Und sie haben auch keinen, der dann
quasi 24-7 irgendwie
ja auch nur auf
freiwilliger Basis erreichbar ist.
Da haben sie Pech. Ich denke mir,
manche müssen es einfach auf die
harte Tour lernen, dass man
IT-Experten,
die halt auch Ahnung haben von dem, was sie machen,
nicht für ein Apfel und ein Ei bekommt
zur aktuellen Zeit.
Und wahrscheinlich nie wieder.
Und
haben sie Pech, wenn sie es
lernen.
Meinst du wirklich?
Ich guck mir das mal an.
Ich bin mal montags gespannt.
Ich bin mal gespannt, wie das ist. Ich werde das
Montag ausprobieren.
Ja, so ist es ja. Also Fachkräftemangel,
wenn du nach dem Arbeitsamt gehst, heißt ja nur,
dass offene Stellen nicht besetzt werden können.
Das heißt ja nicht, dass es wirklich
zu wenig Leute gibt, die es machen könnten.
Letztendlich
ist für die alles Fachkräftemangel,
was,
wenn es nicht so ist, dass die Leute
quasi für ein Apfel und ein Ei,
also wenn du nicht mehr
für ein Apfel und ein Ei, wenn nicht jeder,
wenn nicht jedes Unternehmen für ein Apfel
und ein Ei die qualifiziertesten Leute
bekommt und Stellen offen bleiben, ist es
für die Fachkräftemangel. Also
sprich nur, weil irgendwelche
Leute keinen Bock haben, den Leuten ordentlich
Arbeitsbedingungen zu bieten, Gehälter zu bezahlen
oder eben einfach nur mal ordentliche
Stellenausschreibungen zu machen.
Ist das für die ein Fachkräftemangel?
Das heißt nicht zwangsläufig, dass die keinen finden würden.
Die würden höchstwahrscheinlich jemanden
finden. Es gibt ja nicht
zu wenige in dem Sinn. Es gibt nur zu
wenige, die Bock haben, das
für lau zu machen oder
unter Kackbedingungen zu machen.
Aber vollkommen zu Recht. Warum sollte man das
auch machen?
Haben sie selbst
dran Schuld, wenn die keinen finden?
Und eine Sache, es hat letztens ein Recruiter
erzählt, was ich sehr einleuchtend
fand. Die haben gesagt, du kannst
heutzutage, wenn du Leute suchst,
also wenn du IT-Experten
suchst und das ist bestimmt in anderen
Fachrichtungen, Fachbereichen auch so,
du kannst dich nicht mehr rein drauf verlassen,
dass du eine Stellenanzeige
ins Internet haust und die Leute
bewerben sich wie verrückt. Das kannst du
vielleicht machen, wenn du Microsoft, Google, Facebook,
Instagram, Amazon,
wer auch immer bist.
Von denen haben, ja bei denen
sind ja auch dann hier Inverte
Martin Binary Tree, da gibt es ja die ganzen
Testvideos, wo sie
sich dann auch viele kleine Klitschen
davon inspirieren lassen und der Meinung sind, sie
müssten das auch machen, aber halt vergessen, dass sie
nicht Google sind.
Ja und was er gesagt hat ist folgendes,
es bringt nichts mehr, wenn man einfach nur eine
Stellenanzeige ins Internet haut,
man muss dann wirklich aktiv gucken.
Und aktiv gucken bedeutet auch
auf Portalen
wie Xing und vor allem
LinkedIn und generell
versuchen Leute anzusprechen,
die aktuell einen Job
haben, aber
eigentlich diesen Job nicht mehr machen wollen.
Der hat das
irgendwie in die Richtung gesagt,
wie Leute, die innerlich quasi schon
gekündigt haben oder Leute, die eigentlich keinen
Bock mehr auf den aktuellen Job haben,
die müsstest du quasi auch versuchen
anzusprechen. Und ich finde,
das hat sich wirklich sinnvoll angehört, was der
erzählt hat, weil mal ganz im Ernst, mal Frage
an euch Chat.
Einfach nur mal so, aber
lasst mich erstmal die drei Sachen jetzt, bevor ihr was
schreibt, lasst mich mal ausreden.
Wie würdet ihr euch
wie würdet ihr euch da oder wie
geht es euch persönlich?
Also sprich, habt ihr jetzt aktuell einen Job,
wo ihr
nicht ganz zufrieden seid und wenn jemand um die
Ecke kommen würde mit einem guten Angebot
und euch sagt, hier guckt mal,
dort verdient ihr vielleicht ähnlich viel
vielleicht mehr unter diesen
und diesen Bedingungen und diese Bedingungen sind
für euch halt wirklich attraktiv und ihr sagt,
hey, das ist ja viel besser als bei meinem
aktuellen Job. Das Gesamtpaket
aus Bedingungen, was man macht und
halt, würdet ihr
dann wechseln
oder nicht? Also sprich,
seid ihr
innerlich auch schon so weit, dass ihr eigentlich
denkt, ah, eigentlich habe ich überhaupt keinen Bock
mehr auf den Laden hier, aber ich bin noch zu faul
ich bin einfach zu
ich bin noch zu faul, mir
was Neues zu suchen. Ja und
ich glaube, in dieser Situation
sind viele
wahrscheinlich
bei weitem nicht alle, ne, ich denke mal
wahrscheinlich irgendwie so eher sowas um Richtung
was weiß ich, 20, 30 Prozent oder so
aber es gibt genug
und
wenn man solche Leute anspricht,
die quasi selbst nicht aktiv suchen
aber die ohne Probleme bereit wären
zu sagen, pff, was juckt mich mein aktueller
Laden, ich wechsel, dann hat
man schon viel gewonnen und das wäre
zumindest laut dem Recruiter, was ich von dem
gehört habe, ist
das wäre so aktuell
eines der wichtigsten Dinger, wenn man
eben als Unternehmen Experten
oder IT-Fachleute sucht
wenn du jetzt nämlich
jemanden hast, der super zufrieden ist
ja mit ein bisschen mehr Geld und ein bisschen
anders, wirst du da wahrscheinlich nicht viel ausrichten können
aber wenn du einen hast, der eh schon keinen Bock mehr hat
auf den Laden, dann geht das natürlich
einfacher
ja und ich sehe es ja, es ist ja bei vielen auch
so, ich muss auch sagen, bei mir, ich meine
ihr wisst ja, dass ich mich aktuell ein bisschen umgeguckt
habe, was Jobs angeht, bei mir ist es ja
auch so, es gibt viele Sachen, die mir gerade wirklich
auf der Arbeit ziemlich auf den Keks gehen
Homeoffice ist davon nur ein Punkt
und wenn jetzt wirklich
was kommt, was
gehaltsmäßig gut ist, was arbeitstechnisch gut ist
was auch von den restlichen Bedingungen
gut aussieht
durchaus möglich, dass ich dann da bald weg bin
ja, das ist eine gute Umfrage, das
können wir tatsächlich mal machen, ich mach mal kurz die Umfrage
machen wir mal
ich mach mal, Mods, ihr müsst
nichts machen, ich mach schon selbst
ja, nein
habt ihr
ah, die Frage ist zu lang, wir müssen
die anders, wir müssen die anders formulieren
und würdet
äh, tja Leute, also
es geht um diese Frage
ich kann die Frage leider nicht komplett
komplett reinpasten
in die Umfrage, aber ihr wisst, welche Frage
gemeint ist, ich mach
die Umfrage jetzt einfach mal, so
es geht um das hier, habt ihr
schon soweit gekündigt und würdet bei einem neuen
guten Angebot wechseln
würdest du wechseln, ja, wenn die
Arbeitsbedingungen gut sind, wenn das Gehalt gut ist
wenn mir das
Umfeld gefällt, ja, würd ich
gute Umfragenvorschlag
hier, also ich würd
mal sagen, es läuft so auf
ah, eben hätt ich noch gesagt 50 50, aber
eher so 2 Drittel
1 Drittel raus, von was
für einem Gehalt sprechen wir, von einem
wo du sagen würdest, dafür
wechsel ich, ja, also
natürlich nicht viel mehr, ja, also ich
mein klar, die meisten Leute würden wechseln, wenn
ihnen jetzt einer 5 mal mehr Gehalt bietet, ja
ok, das ist mal so, 60%
sagen prinzipiell würden sie das machen
gar nicht so wenig, ich hätt eher gedacht es umgedreht
ja soll er
ich mein, es ist kein Geheimnis, hab ich auch schon gesagt
dass es einige Sachen gibt, mit denen ich unzufrieden
bin, ich will nicht unbedingt weg
aber es gibt einige
Sachen, die mir wirklich auf den Keks gehen
und wenn ich, wie gesagt, wenn ich was anderes finde
was mich wirklich anspricht
dann mach ich das
warum ich, oh, na gut, das kann ich jetzt schlecht
in einem Satz zusammenfassen, aber es gibt, na ich
versuch's mal, es gibt einige Dinger
also ich, ob ich wirklich wechsle ist
noch nicht sicher, ich hab nächste Woche oder übernächste Woche
noch mal ein Probearbeitstag
was ist Probearbeitstag, Probearbeitstag
stimmt ja gar nicht, ich hab ein
ähm
so Kennenlerntag oder nicht
man guckt sich's mal an, Angucktag
quasi, ja
bei einem anderen Laden nächste Woche Montag
weil Montags bin ich immer, hab ich eh immer frei
äh, Schnuppertag
oder sowas, ja, genau
mal gucken wie das, wie das dann ist
klang im Vorfeld alles nice, aber gut
vieles klingt im Vorfeld nice, ja
muss man mal schauen, ähm, also
warum ich wechsle, es gibt ein paar Sachen, die mir wirklich
extrem auf den Keks gehen bei uns
äh, hauptsächlicher Punkt ist Homeoffice, obwohl man
sieht, also das ist jetzt wirklich nur die Kurzfassung
obwohl man sieht bei uns, dass
Homeoffice gerade in der IT
die letzten zwei, drei Jahre über wirklich sehr gut
funktioniert hat, die Leute auch mehr geschafft haben
alles wunderbar funktioniert und das was
funktioniert nicht am Homeoffice, also das was nicht
funktioniert nicht am Homeoffice liegt, sondern an
merkwürdigen Entscheidungen
ähm
und jetzt quasi man sagt
man möchte kein Homeoffice mehr oder
eigentlich weniger Homeoffice und
da ganz komische Dinger vorschiebt
so nach dem Motto, wir müssen die Leute vor der
Vereinsamung beschützen und sowas, da denke ich mir auch immer
Alter, ihr habt Probleme
ja, die haben allen Ernstes bei uns angeführt
wir müssen die Leute vor der Vereinsamung schützen
also wenn, wenn das schützenswert ist
dann müssten sie mich auch schützen, da vor mir Corona in der
Bahn einzufangen oder
ähm
mit dem Auto aufm, beim
Pendeln gegen den Brückenpfeiler
zu fahren, ja, das ist höchst, das ist wahrscheinlich
äh, schwerwiegender und wahrscheinlich
ja für mich als das irgendwelche
Homeoffice Dinger mich umbringen
also es ist einfach nur vorgeschoben
also bei uns machen sie einen Riesenakt was Homeoffice angeht
so nach dem Motto, wie der Hälfte der
Zeit anwesend im Büro
oder teilweise manche Leute sogar zum größten Teil
anwesend im Büro, das ist also, das Handling
von Homeoffice geht mir bei uns
extrem auf den Sack, vor allem
weil wir eine ähm
eigentlich Vereinbarung haben
und es auch verschiedene Prozesse
gibt für Homeoffice
die eben da eigentlich dafür sorgen
sollten, dass man
das machen kann
auch in größerem Umfang, aber die haben
einfach, obwohl sie das unterschrieben haben
und obwohl es das gibt, einfach jetzt
180 Grad Kehrtwende gemacht
und sagen sie wollen es doch
nicht und ich, meine persönliche Vermutung
ist folgendes, dass
auf Management Ebene man da etwas
entkoppelt von der Realität
ist, also sprich
die haben
gesagt, wir bieten das an
weil wir sind ja cool und wir sind ja modern
und es ist natürlich auch gut
hat für uns als Attraktivität
vom Arbeitgeber, wir bieten
Homeoffice Regelung an, aber
wir sind doch so ein geiler Laden
und wir mögen uns doch alle so und so
familiär und so freundschaftlich und so
dicke sind wir alle, dass die Leute das
gar nicht machen wollen
das ist meine persönliche Vermutung, dass das der
Gedankengang bei Management war
und dann gab es diese Regelung
und auf einmal haben 90% der Leute gesagt
ah ja gut, wir wollen die Regelung benutzen
und dann ist ihnen aufgefallen
oh wie, was, die Leute wollen jetzt, es gibt
eine Regelung und die Leute wollen das auch machen
und jetzt wollen sie wieder zurückrudern
und gerade im IT Bereich
ist es halt doppelt lächerlich, weil es mit
Homeoffice Technik besser funktioniert
halt als ohne Homeoffice, das ist ja nicht dazu
dass es einfach nur funktioniert, es hat besser funktioniert mit Homeoffice
also
das ist eine Sache, die geht mir extrem auf den Keks
und was ich persönlich
auch sehr fragwürdig finde, wir haben einige
Leute mit Risiko
Risikogruppen, also
sprich die haben Immunerkrankungen oder
irgendwelche anderen Erkrankungen in der Richtung
wo es wirklich äußerst unschön wäre
wenn die sich Corona einfangen, sogar
bei denen nerven sie rum
dass Homeoffice
nicht mehr regelmäßig erfolgen soll
und da denke ich mir, irgendwann ist es auch mal gut
also Leute, also ganz im Ernst
sterben um auf die Arbeit
zu fahren würde ich nicht
ich habe zum Glück
nicht so krasse Krankheiten wie die teilweise
bin ich auch wirklich froh drum
aber das muss echt nicht sein
aber das finde ich wirklich absolut unding
generell, die Handhabung von Homeoffice finde ich
ganz ganz grausam bei uns
das ist ein Punkt und das habe ich auch
meinem Chef schon gesagt
meinem jetzigen und meinem vorherigen
dass wenn er wirklich drauf
bestanden werden soll, so nach dem Motto
80-90% Anwesenheit
wieder im Büro, das werde ich nicht machen
ein Tag, kein Problem
ab und zu mal vielleicht
noch ein zweiter Tag, wenn was wichtig ist
ist okay, aber spätestens dann ist es vorbei
ich meine, ich merke das doch auch
bei mir
ich kriege mehr geschafft
ich bin deutlich weniger
gestresst und stressresistenter
ich bin gesünder
ich habe 15 Kilo abgenommen im Homeoffice
ich bin wahrscheinlich der einzige Mensch
der während Corona im Homeoffice abgenommen hat
und warum habe ich abgenommen
ich denke mal
das sind mehrere Faktoren
erstens, weil ich ausgeschlafen bin
weil ich fitter bin und mich dementsprechend
auch lieber bewege
also sprich
nicht mehr 5.45 Uhr aufstehen
sondern 7 Uhr
und Leute glaubts mir
diese eineinhalb Stunden
5.45 Uhr, 7.30 Uhr, eineinhalb Stunden länger
ist wie eine zweite Nacht
also
5.45 Uhr aufstehen
ist, du bist eigentlich halb tot
die ganze Woche und musst dann
den Samstag auch halb noch durchpennen
und 7 Uhr, 7.15 Uhr
aufstehen ist absolut in Ordnung
zumal man eben halt auch direkt
im Arbeitszimmer ohne zu pendeln
am Rechner ist und direkt anfangen kann
so, also
das ist so eines der Punkte
warum ich es gemerkt habe
ich bin gesünder, ich schaffe es
es gibt überhaupt gar keinen Grund
warum man da irgendwie
Akt macht
mit Homeoffice
das ist der erste Punkt, der mir bei uns
wirklich extrem
extrem auf den Keks geht
und warum ich
jetzt auch schon gesucht habe
beziehungsweise mich ein bisschen
umgehört habe, was es so gibt
da gibt es noch ein paar kleinere Punkte
die eher so mit der Kultur
in der Firma zusammenhängen
das kann ich jetzt, das habe ich schon öfters mal
am Rande immer so ein bisschen
breit getreten, ja also unsere
es gibt, es ist bei uns in der Firma sehr viel
planlos, ja, wir haben einen
riesen Anteil an
Projektmanagern und
Planungsleuten, allerdings
fühlt sich nichts wirklich geplant an
und wir schaffen
es einfach auch nicht Sachen
verbindlich, beziehungsweise mal
sinnvoll zu planen
also sprich, nehmen wir mal ein Beispiel
ja, Kollege von mir, da arbeitet
die Frau bei einem Amt
und die haben gesagt
die haben in dem Amt eineinhalb Jahre gebraucht
bis sie Homeoffice Regelungen hatten, also bei uns
ging das ja relativ schnell
aber
bei denen ist es jetzt so
seitdem wir diese Regelungen haben
die funktionieren einfach
irgendjemand
stellt einen Antrag, der Antrag wird sicher bearbeitet
und er bekommt sicher eine Antwort und er bekommt sicher
das und das eingeplant
es funktioniert einfach und bei uns ist es
ist es so
wir haben in vielen, ich muss jetzt mal weg von
Homeoffice, aber wir haben in vielen
Fällen Regelungen und wir haben in vielen Fällen
Planungen und so, aber
die sind immer so schwammig
alles und die sind so schwammig
dass du dich
als Techniker
als Manager dich gut hinter verstecken
kannst
aber als Techniker nicht
ich finde es übrigens generell nicht gut
wenn man sich hinter sinnlosen Regeln
verstecken kann, aber ich finde es noch
fragwürdiger, wenn
Regelungen existieren
die rein dazu da sind schlechte
Managemententscheidungen zu decken
aber im Umkehrschluss
alles an Verantwortung
und
wer war es jetzt
auf die Technikseite abwälzt
also
man muss auch mal anerkennen
ich muss ein Beispiel
ich habe 420 Zuschauer
ich muss mal ein Beispiel bringen, dass ihr
versteht was ich meine
also gehen wir mal von aus
irgendjemand
soll Wartungsarbeiten
durchführen, also irgendein
Techniker soll Wartungsarbeiten durchführen, was weiß ich
Kernelupdates, Serverrebooten
was auch immer, nehmen wir mal irgendwas simples
so und dabei
macht er irgendeinen Blödsinn
macht er irgendwas verkehrt
so und dann
ist keine Ahnung ruckelt ein Service mal für
15 Minuten, dann wird dann geguckt
ok woran lag es, bis zu diesem Zeitpunkt
ist auch alles vollkommen in Ordnung
aber das Problem bei uns ist
und vielleicht findet sich ja der ein oder andere wieder
weil ich habe das von vielen schon gehört
auch bei euch aus dem Chat und auch von ein paar Bekannten
und so, dass es bei größeren Unternehmen
eben öfters der Fall ist
so dann wird dann geguckt woran es lag
und da kommt dann meistens raus
es ging schief
nicht etwa weil der Techniker
sich ein falsches Verfahren ausgedacht hat
sondern
weil die Vorgaben
um Wartungsarbeiten
durchzuführen
so realitätsfern sind
dass du es am Ende dann gar nicht richtig
ausführen kannst, also
zum Beispiel ist es
mal ganz konkret, zum Beispiel ist es so
dass bei uns mittlerweile
die Hälfte des Monats keine Wartungsarbeiten
mehr erlaubt sind
weil irgendwelche wichtigen Veranstaltungen sind
allerdings
hat sich das Management überlegt
ok, wenn man einen
Change Freeze hat, dann gilt der 24-7
der gilt nicht nur
tagsüber, wo Veranstaltungen
sind, nein der gilt 24-7
also das bedeutet, wenn man jetzt einen
Change Freeze hat, vom 1. bis
zum 14. dann darf man 2 Wochen
lang absolut keine Changes machen
so oder sagen wir mal wir haben
Change Freeze, realistisches Beispiel ist
so eins so passiert, es gibt einen
Change Freeze vom 1. bis zum 11.
so was passiert jetzt
die Leute haben Druck, die haben Tickets
die haben Arbeit, die umgesetzt werden muss
was passiert jetzt, an diesem
Freitag hier werden
alle Changes durchgeführt, die sich
über die letzten 2 Wochen so aufgestaut haben
so und wenn
ein Techniker da sitzt um 0.02
und anstatt
einen Change 15
Changes machen muss
ähm
ja dann kann er auch mal Scheiße
bauen, das Problem bei uns ist jetzt
wieder nur, dass das alles so schwammig
gemacht ist, dass im Endeffekt
die ganze Sache an dem hier hängen bleibt
der sich hier vertippt hat
aber in Wirklichkeit und das ist das
was man trotz aller Beteuerungen
bei uns zur Verbesserung nicht
einsehen will, was
eigentlich dazu geführt hat, dass dieser Fehler
hier aufgetreten ist, ist nicht so sehr
dass der Techniker sich vertippt hat
ähm
sondern, dass der Change Freeze
so lang ist und der Change Freeze 24
7 gilt und er auf der anderen
Seite von seinem Chef
und den gleichen Leuten, die diesen Change Freeze
eingeführt haben, Druck gemacht
bekommt, der Change muss bis zum 15
umgesetzt sein
so, das ist halt, das sind halt
die Dinger und vielleicht findet sich da der ein oder andere wieder
das sind, so mal ganz grob
als Beispiel, dass so Dinger
die mir bei mir auf den Keks gehen
gepaart mit, dass
immer gesagt wird, man möchte sich
verbessern, aber wir möchten uns nicht verbessern
also, ich habe bei so vielen
Verbesserungsaktionen
mitgemacht, bei denen
nie was rausgekommen ist
ich habe sogar einmal am Wochenende mitgemacht
da ging es um irgendeine Innovations-App-Entwicklung
kam auch nichts raus, also ich habe
bei ganz vielen, wie können wir uns verbessern, Dinger
mitgemacht und es ist nie was rausgekommen
der größte, also der größte Witz war
ja mal, wir haben eine Umfrage gemacht
von irgendeinem, ich sage jetzt den Namen nicht
von irgendeinem Prüfungsunternehmen
da konnte man zufrieden
Freiheitsumfragen machen, wo die Probleme sind
also da musste man dann
also man musste nicht, das war freiwillig, aber
man konnte Fragebögen ausfüllen
da waren dann in den Fragebögen, stand dann solche Sachen
drin, wie klar, also zum Beispiel
da war dann eine Frage drin, wie klar
sind Arbeitsanweisungen
formuliert und sowas
so und am Ende hat man dann verschiedene Noten
bekommen, also hat dann das Unternehmen verschiedene Noten
bekommen für, was weiß ich
Zusammenarbeit
Arbeitsatmosphäre und sowas in der Richtung
so und
wir hatten kein
sonderlich gutes Ergebnis, muss man sagen
und gerade was, ja diese
Sache mit, ja wie klar
arbeiten oder wie klar Aufgaben
formuliert sind und wie klar
die Sachen geregelt
sind, haben wir wirklich schlecht abgeschnitten
hatten wir glaube ich nur eine 4 oder sogar 4,3
oder so, war richtig schlecht
und damit
das Ganze und jetzt kommt ja das
was bei uns gerne gemacht wird, was halt
auch ein Punkt ist, der mir wirklich auf den Keks geht
das Ergebnis war halt nicht gut
so und anstatt jetzt zu sagen, Jungs
wir dachten eigentlich, wir sind viel
besser, aber sind wir ja gar
nicht laut der Umfrage, wir werden uns
das jetzt mal zu Herz nehmen und tatsächlich
mal, ja
einen Plan ausarbeiten, was wir da
unternehmen können und mit diesen und diesen Zielen
gibt es nicht, weil in diesem Punkt
ab diesem Punkt hätte sich
das Management eingestehen müssen, dass ihre
Entscheidungen mit dazu führen, dass es Probleme gibt
und das, da tun die sich äußerst schwer
wahrscheinlich überall so
und deswegen hat man folgendes gemacht
damit das Ergebnis nicht so schlecht aussieht
wisst ihr was man gemacht hat?
das ist eigentlich ein Witz überhaupt, der Witz schlechthin
man hat sich von dem gleichen Prüfungsunternehmen
einen
Vergleichsdatensatz eingekauft
und dann hat man
nicht gesagt, Leute wir haben in diesem Bereich
eine 4,3
sondern man hat gesagt, wir sind
besser als der
Vergleichsdatensatz, also man hat keine
man hat nicht einfach nur die Noten präsentiert
sondern man hat sich einen Vergleichsdatensatz
eingekauft, der noch schlechter war
ich meine, dieses Prüfungsunternehmen
hat was weiß ich schon 50.000 Unternehmen
beraten in dieser Richtung
und natürlich findest du dann jemand
der schlechter ist als du selbst
und dann haben wir einen Vergleichsdatensatz
gehabt, der hatte dann keine Ahnung
5,3 bei dieser Umfrage
und dann konnte man sagen, guckt
mal hier, hier ist auch im Vergleich
ein gutes Ergebnis
und da habe ich mir damals schon gedacht, alter
Painschamp wollt ihr uns verarschen, wir haben eine 4,3
4,3 ist mega schlecht
in dieser Umfrage
aber es wurde so hingestellt, als ist es wirklich
richtig geil
und es ist halt so ein Ding bei uns
was nicht passieren wird, aber was
ich wirklich gut finden würde ist, wenn man
mal auf ganz oberner
Management-Ebene mal wirklich
thematisieren würde bei Problemen
ok, wir haben uns damals
für Weg XY entschieden
weil
aus der damaligen Sicht
kann ja keiner wissen, wie sich das in 2 Jahren
entwickelt, aus der damaligen Sicht
erschien es am sinnvollsten
das so zu machen, aber
wir haben jetzt gesehen, dass das
wohl für uns nicht
die beste Lösung war und deswegen
streben wir an, das in Zukunft so und so anders zu machen
das würde mir vollkommen reichen, ich erwarte nicht
dass sich der Vorstand hinstellt und sagt
Jungs, wir haben es verkackt, ja das wirst du
nicht erleben, aber zumindest eine
gewisse Einsicht, wenn
Sachen schief gehen, aufgrund von
schlechten Management-Entscheidungen
die hätte ich schon mal ganz gerne, weil du kannst
nicht immer sagen, die Leute setzen da
das falsch um, wenn es oftmals
im Wechsel von
2 Wochen komplett widersprüchliche
Entscheidungen gibt, die gegeneinander arbeiten
ja, wie das mit den Wartungsarbeiten
und dem Change Freeze
du kannst nicht 2 Sachen entscheiden
die nicht zusammen funktionieren
und dann am Ende sagen, die Leute sind schuld
Management hat das gut entschieden, die Leute haben es falsch
umgesetzt, das ist einfach
das
nicht, wie soll ich sagen, nicht
an der Wurzel gepackt, wo das eigentliche Problem existiert
und dementsprechend verbessern wir
uns auch nicht, und solche Punkte
sind das, die gehen mir bei mir, wo ich arbeite, wirklich
auf den Keks, weil alle unsere Projekte
ne, alle ist übertrieben, weil viele unserer
Projekte einfach so planlos sind
und kennt ihr das?
Kennt ihr Projekte, die klein anfangen
und sich dann on the fly
immer wieder neue Dinge ausgedacht
werden, weil
demjenigen, der es eigentlich planen sollte, aufgefallen
ist, er hat an die Hälfte nicht gedacht
so, ach das müssen wir auch noch
machen, ach das gibt es ja auch noch, ach das gibt es ja auch noch
und es dann aber nicht sagt, so nach dem Motto
ah, das war zwar nicht ursprünglich in der Planung
drin, aber wir müssen das jetzt noch machen, sondern der dann so
tut, als hätten die Leute
das falsch verstanden und er hätte das schon von Anfang
an gesagt
ja, dass jedes Projekt am Ende doppelt so
groß ist, ist gar nicht das, was ich meine
gar nicht das, was ich meine
ähm
das meine ich gar nicht, ne
das meine ich nicht, ich meine
dieses
nicht thematisieren
das Größerwerdens
also sprich, das Projekt
das man vom Anfang, dass man nicht von Anfang
an weiß, was da am Ende rauskommt,
dafür sind Projekte ja da, das ist ja
da sage ich nichts dagegen, aber das man so tut
als wäre das von Anfang an
gesagt worden
und die Leute hätten es schlecht
umgesetzt
das ist das, was mich nervt, ja
also was weiß ich, du baust irgendwie
drei oder fünf
Server auf, zum
testen und am Ende
sagt dir dann einer, ja ok
das ist jetzt, das ist so nicht passiert
das ist jetzt einfach nur mal ein Beispiel, ja
also zum Beispiel, es sagt zu dir einer
wir brauchen eine Testumgebung für neue
für Software XY, stell mal fünf
VMs hin, du stellst fünf VMs hin
mit Standardausstattung und sagst, bist fertig
und am Ende sagt dann jemand zu dir
von dem Projekt, ja ok
und, was ist mit den
15 TB Storage
dann sagst du, wie welche
15 TB Storage, na die Software
braucht doch 15 TB Storage, dass es
läuft, das ist doch klar
so
und, hä, das ist nicht klar
das hat keiner gesagt
das dann an dieser Stelle nicht klar
gesagt wird, oh ok
da waren unsere Anforderungen wohl
nicht ganz klar, oder oh
das haben wir, den
Speicherbedarf haben wir vielleicht falsch
eingeschätzt, alles ok
nein, es wird so getan, als hätte man das von Anfang
an wissen müssen, so
und das sind so Dinger
die
findet sich bestimmt der ein oder andere von euch auch
wieder, wo das so passiert, das sind so
Dinger, die gehen mir wirklich extrem auf den Keks
so dieses hätte man
auch wissen müssen, Gaslighting
nennt man das heute, ok
wusste ich nicht
dass es dafür jetzt einen neuen Begriff gibt
aber das ist halt, das sind so Sachen
die sind wirklich blöd
und dann wundern sie sich, warum immer so viel gegen die Wand
fährt, beziehungsweise
warum immer so vieles nicht so wird
wie man es sich ausmalt, ja
kein Wunder, ja und auch
ein Ding, was bei uns auch
ein riesen Problem ist, und ich glaube
das ist bei jedem etwas größeren Unternehmen
das Problem, dass das
was entschieden wird, und das was
bei dir ankommt, zwei komplett
unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe sind
und das, was du als Feedback sagst
und das was zurückkommt, auch komplett
zwei unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe sind
also sprich, wenn jetzt
auch, sagen wir mal, auf oberer Führungsebene
was entschieden wird
was dann, was du
gesagt bekommst, muss gar nicht mal
zwangsläufig mehr großartig was mit dem zu tun haben
wie wir gesagt haben, und wenn du dich dann
darüber beschwerst, dass es so überhaupt nicht funktioniert
kommt das so aber auch nicht wieder zurück
also
über drei, vier Manager-Ebenen
ist das so verwässert und verfiltert
dass es eigentlich gar nicht mehr funktionieren kann
oder mit dem Ursprungsgedanken nichts mehr zu tun hat
das ist auch so ein Ding
ich will mich nicht auf die Reihe kriegen
was, nein, ich bin kein Spieleentwickler
nix sage ich
dazu, nix
würde ich nicht mehr machen
vier Tage Woche, beste
und wenn die so weitermachen bei uns
gibt es zwei Möglichkeiten, entweder
ich suche mir wirklich was neues
worauf es wahrscheinlich rausläuft
oder aber, ich reduziere noch weiter
auf 50% oder so
und bin dann nur noch zweieinhalb Tage da
in den Tagen
miete ich dann nur und schreib ein paar E-Mails
und dann easy, ja nice
also wenn das klappt
wenn das klappen sollte
mit
ja mit
wo ich jetzt mal so einen Schnuppertag mache
demnächst
die sind auch ungefähr so weit weg
aber es ist halt auch 100% Homeoffice
da bin ich immer gespannt drauf wie das läuft
ja das ist immer das blöde Gelaber
Dankeschön Benzel für den Sub
nee, gar nicht mal
ganz im Ernst bei uns nicht
also ich würde sagen, sowohl mein aktueller Chef
als auch mein jetziger Chef
die sind nicht verkehrt
und ich glaube
die wollen auch viel machen
für die jeweilige Gruppe, aber können nicht
gar nicht mal
ich glaube gar nicht mal, dass es direkt
am direkten Chef liegt oftmals
die haben meistens
eher noch die Arschkarte
weil die kriegen von ihren Leuten gesagt wie kacke das ist
und von oben kriegen sie einen Anschluss
warum es nicht richtig umgesetzt wird
das ist auch eine geile Aussage
wie du willst zu den Konditionen nicht arbeiten
und nicht weiterentwickeln
das sind ja eigentlich zwei verschiedene Sachen
ich will nicht zu den Konditionen arbeiten
ja, aber ich will mich weiterentwickeln
ich möchte zum Einstieg schon mehr haben
aber in zwei Jahren auch nochmal
hast du das Video
heute abgebrochen?
ach nee, da sind wir immer noch dabei
ich wurde unterbrochen
so war der Gedankengang
hier gerade
wir gucken das gleich fertig
gegen einmal im Tag habe ich ja gar nichts
das reicht mir
ein Großraumbüro ist jetzt in Deutschland modern
bei den Amis schon nicht mehr
wir sind da immer
ein bisschen hinten dran
also ich kann das auch nicht ab im Großraumbüro
obwohl ich im Großraumbüro sitze
aber ich sitze hinter so einer Kunststoffwand
an der Wand
vor
einem
schalldichten Meetingraum
also ich kann eigentlich nur von links
bisschen was hören
und da sitzt meistens keiner
gute Umfrage
aber nicht jetzt
die meisten würden wahrscheinlich sagen Mittelbisse
ja
das ist ja auch so ein Ding
die tun bei uns so als sind sie furchtbar agil
aber das ist so ziemlich das anti-agilste Unternehmen
was man sich vorstellen kann
Samuel, danke für den Sub
machst du Quali-
nee
zumindest habe ich das nicht auf dem T-
natürlich probiere ich manchmal Sachen aus
ob die funktionieren oder nicht
das macht ja jeder, aber
ich bin nicht in irgendeiner Art und Weise
in einer Art und Weise
aber ich bin in einer Art und Weise
ich bin nicht in irgendeiner Abteilung
die für Qualitätssicherung zuständig ist
zum Glück
bei uns ist es mit Qualität nicht so weit her
ja ich habe auch zum größten Teil Kopfhörer auf
aber ich mag
Noise Cancelling Kopfhörer den ganzen Tag auf nicht
weil es gibt so ein drückendes Geräusch
äh nicht Geräusch
es ist eigentlich ein Geräusch
aber es fühlt sich nach einem drückenden Gefühl an
ich ziehe manchmal einfach nur in ihr Kopfhörer so leicht auf
und mache ein bisschen
Gedudel an oder so, dass mich nichts nervt
er kennt mich wieder
äh ich
ich kann deinen Namen anklicken
und dann sehe ich, dass du
schon
über 1000 Nachrichten geschrieben hast
ja und der Name kommt mir auch bekannt vor
wobei du könntest dich umbenannt haben
in der Kombination sagt mir der Name
gar nicht so viel
aber
du hast schon über 1000 Nachrichten geschrieben
du bist auf jeden Fall öfters da
und zwar seit dem 1. Februar 2021
regelmäßig
ja Leute
wer denkt ihr werdet nicht getrackt
oder so
wir sind hier bei Amazon
keine Chance
ok jetzt gucken wir uns einfach mal das Video fertig an
ist ewig rumgelabert
hier
wie gut läuft es in anderen Ländern
mit Digitalisierung
ok wo sind wir stehen geblieben
vom Klo aus abwickeln
sofa sofa
ich will alles vom Klo aus machen
ist das zu viel verlangt
ich bin in der Ukraine
und die hat weiß Gott größere Probleme
gibt es eine staatliche App
die fast alle staatlichen Dienstleistungen online anbietet
seit Kriegsbeginn kann man mit der App
sogar die Standorte russischer Truppen
direkt ans Militär melden
in Berlin kann ich noch nicht mal online
meinen Hund bei der Steuerbehörde anmelden
hab ich ihn halt nicht angemeldet
Hippomuk
so komm mal her
mein kleiner illegaler
ich bin froh
dass ich meine Katze nicht anmelden muss
du wenn du ein Mensch wärst
wärst du schon abgeschoben
ok also anderswo läuft es 10 mal besser
warum nicht bei uns
tatsächlich sind wir deutschen Technik faul
nach wie vor benutzen zum Beispiel nur die Hälfte
der 50 Millionen Sparkassenkunden
auch das Online Banking
ja kann ich
nicht nachvollziehen
warum Leute teilweise immer noch was gegen Online Banking haben
es gibt aber einen Punkt
den ich verstehen kann
denn Apps und Verfahren
sind unendlich dumm
und kompliziert gemacht
ich hatte beispielsweise
letztens
also wie gesagt
ich habe 3 verschiedene Konten
ich habe einmal Sparkasse
eine Direktbank
und auch die ganzen Sachen
für die Aktienstocks
so und ich wollte bei meiner Direktbank
letztens das Handy wechseln
also sprich ich habe ja noch ein altes iPhone 6
und ich habe hier ein iPhone 11
nur auf dem alten Gerät
das alte Gerät war aber sowas von entladen
und der Ladestecker ging gar nicht mehr richtig rein
und jetzt wollte ich
die App auf dem neuen Handy installieren
und irgendwie
das freischalten
so das ging einfach nicht
und damit das funktioniert hieß es dann
müsste ich mir eine temporäre App generieren
äh eine temporäre TAN generieren
mit dem ausgeschalteten
TAN Gerät
aber warum ist das überhaupt nur auf dem alten Gerät
weil ich habe das Gerät
doch aus dem Backup restored
aber anscheinend wird das Zeug von der TAN
nicht über das Backup irgendwie restored
und jetzt
bräuchte ich irgendeine SuperPIN
und diese SuperPIN
ähm
kriege ich nur über einen PDF Antrag
den ich per Post zur Bank schicken muss
da habe ich auch gedacht
what?
was ist da los?
aha monks
und die TAN App kriege ich auch nicht
auf mein
neues Handy
weil dazu brauche ich um die TAN App umzuziehen
brauche ich die SuperPIN
das habe ich ja schon erzählt
und die SuperPIN geht bloß über einen PDF Antrag per Post
also ganz wir
lull
du bist nicht mein Chef
ich weiß wie mein Chef auf Twitter heißt
äh nicht auf Twitter auf ähm
auf äh Twitch
irgendwie geht meine Tastatur gerade nicht mal
auf dem zweiten Bildschirm gescheit
warum nicht?
irgendwie kaputt ist
ja jetzt gehts wieder
ok also wir machen jetzt weiter
schreibt auf
was die Mitarbeiter innen in der Sparkasse
dann für sie am Computer machen
äh ich habe deutsches Tastatur Layout
ich habe englische Sprache Deutsch Tastatur Layout
ok Leute ich muss mir das Video jetzt mal fertig angucken
sonst wird das ja nie was
warum nicht bei uns
tatsächlich sind wir deutschen Technik faul
nach wie vor benutzen zum Beispiel nur die
Hälfte der 50 Millionen
ganz ehrlich nichts von dem was ich gesagt habe
ist irgendwie soll ich sagen
äh verboten geheim
oder sonst was also wenn sie damit irgendwelche
Probleme haben äh bei mir
dann weiß ich auch nicht ja
zumal ich nie gesagt habe wo ich arbeite
das keiner weiß
Sparkassen Kunden auch das Online Banking
nur die Hälfte die andere Hälfte
schreibt auf was die Mitarbeiter innen in der Sparkasse
dann für sie am Computer machen müssen
das ist so als würde man
erstmal eine Mail schreiben
per Text
ja das ist doch so
wie es am Anfang Fehler in den Corona
Zahlen gab weil sie immer Dinger vom Fax
falsch abgetippt haben
Hand und dann dem Enkel zum abtippen geben
und dann denken sich 25 Millionen Menschen
ja das ist für alle Beteiligten wohl das
Beste
ganz ehrlich ich bin dabei
ich bin absolut dabei hier das ist mein
Überweisungsträger
der wird jetzt hier halt gegeben
wobei ne ich machs persönlich
Deutschland ist digital
Beweisungsträger das ist auch so ein Ding
wisst ihr das trägert mich ja auch immer
ganz wenige Rechnungen die ich bekomme
haben nen QR Code drauf also hier habe ich zum Beispiel
was hier habe ich was vom Zahnarzt
ja kostet
kann ich euch sagen 70 Euro
weißt du ob vom Zahnarzt
ja ist vom Zahnarzt
70 Euro vom Zahnarzt
so und die haben nen
QR Code drauf
das scannst du nämlich einfach
dann mit deiner Sparkassen oder
App Bank App ist egal
und ist gut
aber es gibt genug die schicken immer noch Rechnungen
in diesem Überweisungsträger Format
oder Rechnungen wo gar nichts großartig
drinsteht und
dann musst du den Scheiß
abtippen und so das ist richtig
Kacke warum können die nicht Rechnungen für
2022 generieren
ich weiß das das geht ja
das geht mit dem Überweisungsbeleg
abfotografieren funktioniert manchmal
aber QR Code QR Code ist viel besser
QR Code ist einfach viel besser
langsam weil das
Geld fehlt sagt ein
Gutachten vom Wirtschaftsminister
QR Code Rechnung per App
Moment nicht per App
du bekommst eine Rechnung geschickt
da ist dann vielleicht auch ein klassischer
Überweisungsträger dabei und da steht was du bezahlen musst
und neben auf der Rechnung ist ein QR Code
und diesen QR Code scannst du
mit deiner Banking App
und diesem QR Code steht halt das was auf dem
Überweisungsträger draufsteht nochmal in QR Code
encoded drin und das versteht deine App
und füllt das für dich schon aus und dann musst du nur noch
eine Tanne eingeben und kannst abschicken. Woran liegt es dann?
Schlemrian, Bummelei
zu viel Mittagsschlaf
viel schlimmer
Organisationsversagen
Deutsche Beamte sind gar nicht faul
das würde ich denen tatsächlich auch nicht
unterstellen
das würde ich denen auch tatsächlich nicht unterstellen
dass die meisten deutschen Beamten faul sind
ich glaube oftmals nur
und das ist wahrscheinlich das was er auch sagen will
dass die
die Wirkung und die Anreize falsch
gesetzt sind also sprich
ähm
dass das was gemacht wird nicht die
erhoffte Wirkung erzählt
und das oftmals die Anreize entgegengesetzt sind
also sprich
man möchte eigentlich A erreichen
dafür muss man aber B machen
aber B
widerspricht eigentlich A
und
dann kommt halt Müll raus
falsche Art fleißig
das System ist scheiße
ein gutes Beispiel dafür ist die Digitalpakt Schule
da hat man schon 2018 gesagt ey
Schulen müssen digitaler werden
5 Milliarden Euro locker gemacht
120.000 Euro pro Schule
das reicht für richtig viele PCs
oder ein großes iPhone Pro
120.000 Euro ist nicht wenig also
von 120.000 Euro kannst du
ja weißt du was kostet
gehen wir mal von
na wobei so viel sind 120.000 Euro für eine Schule jetzt an
was kannst du denn davon kaufen
du kannst ähm
sagen wir mal
50, 60 ordentliche Rechner kaufen
also keine Ahnung
120.000 Euro
was kostet ein ordentlicher Rechner
sagen wir mal 1000 Euro für Schulen
kannst du 120 Rechner
kaufen okay
sagen wir mal
1000, 1300 vielleicht
kannst du 100 Rechner kaufen
das reicht ja nicht
du musst ja dann auch jemand haben der das einrichtet
der das verwaltet
bzw. irgendeine zentrale Verwaltungsgeschichte
Tablets für Schüler wäre natürlich auch richtig pock
wobei ich persönlich der Meinung bin ich finde
Schüler teilweise gar nicht so sinnig
ähm ich denke irgendwie
dass man heute
erwarten kann
dass Schüler ein Tablet
haben wobei es dann immer die Frage
ist äh ja wie sieht es mit
armen Familien aus die sich kein Tablet
leisten können
weil ich denke halt ein Tablet
es muss ja kein super krasses Tablet sein aber
sagen wir mal alle paar Jahre
300 bis 400 Euro
für ein Einsteiger iPad übrig
sollte machbar sein
muss ja kein super teures
2000 Euro iPad mit Stift
und allem sein
alternativ könnte man es auch so machen dass Leute
die eben nicht das Geld für haben sich das
irgendwie noch irgendwelche Förderung holen könnte
ich denke da könnte man einiges machen
ähm
ja aber wahrscheinlich ist es wieder so verkompliziert
dass die Einführung
alleine 120.000 Euro kostet
und man auch nicht ein Tablet hat
Direktor egal
wofür man das Geld halt braucht und da hat der
Staat gesagt hier 5 Milliarden Euro
viel Spaß damit nicht alles für Eis ausgeben
und dann haben die Schulen das Geld bekommen
und dafür allen Schülerinnen und Schülern
Tablets gekauft und jetzt sind alle zufrieden
nein damit der Bund
den Schulen überhaupt Geld geben durfte
musste man erst das Grundgesetz
ändern denn Bildung ist eigentlich
Ländersache und das finden die Bundesländer
super so das soll sich auf keinen Fall
ändern
mit Grundgesetzänderung haben wir doch die letzten 10 Jahre
über eh kaum noch Probleme gehabt
mittlerweile ändern wir das Grundgesetz
den Scheiß
weiß man in Deutschland die ist auf jeden Fall schlecht
wenn sich Sachen ändern dann schwitzt man
da kriegt man so ein flaues Gefühl im Bauch
so zuckende Augenlider Veränderung
einfach nicht gut und wir erinnern uns
das ist Föderalismus
der stand ja schon während Corona
für den Spaß im Wort Pandemie
Grundregel warum sollte es eine
Regel geben wenn wir auch 16
verschiedene haben können genau deshalb
vor allem hast du immer nicht durchgeblickt
was jetzt wie wo gilt
und das war ja teilweise an einem Tag so
also da war wirklich sehr sehr
undurchsichtig
konnte man im Grundgesetz nicht einfach schreiben
okidoki der Bund darf den Schulen Geld schenken
nein weil die Bundesländer Angst haben
dass der Bund sich auf die Art
mehr Einfluss erschleicht
haben sie zusätzlich reingeschrieben
ok Geldgeschenke immer gerne
aber zusätzlich gibt es eine Verwaltungsvereinbarung
in der wir das ganz genau regeln
wie viel Geld und wann und wofür
und wofür nicht und ah hast du da gerade
meine Schule angeschaut Finger weg von meiner
Schule
vielen Dank
tschüss
so und dann muss noch genau
geklärt werden was eine Schule
jetzt genau von dem Geld kaufen kann
und was nicht und deswegen werden Förderrichtlinien
geschrieben natürlich von jedem Land
extra ja klar vielen Dank
wir machen es halt gerne unglaublich kompliziert
ne
dann stellen die Schulen Anträge schriftlich
natürlich ja klar und die Anträge werden
gründlich geprüft und dann und dann
und dann Achtung Achtung Achtung
Alter der Kerl ist wirklich da
ich weiß nicht ein bisschen anstrengend
ist es ja schon
das wollte ich jetzt sagen
das sind so Sachen die vom Ansatz her
ja durchaus auch historisch gesehen
mal Sinn gemacht haben warum so Sachen
eingeführt wurden und so
aber wir sind halt wirklich
Meister da drin solche bürokratischen
Sachen auf die Spitze zu treiben
und dann fließt das Geld
ok also das alles dauert
aber so lange dass 15
Monate nach Änderung des Grundgesetzes
also zum Start der Corona-Pandemie
von den 5 Milliarden Euro erst 20 Millionen
überhaupt an den Schulen angekommen
waren das sind 0,4
das ist immer noch mehr als was bei der Bahn
beziehungsweise was bei der Bahn ankommt
was die Bahn von dem Geld was sie eigentlich
zum verbessern benutzen soll
am Ende wirklich benutzt
und weil jedes Mal ein Verwaltungsakt
nötig ist um die Förderrichtlinien
dem neuesten Stand der Technik
anzupassen hängen die immer mehrere Jahre
der Realität hinterher
auch anderswo fehlt uns nicht das Geld
sondern vor allem die Bereitschaft mal Sachen
anders zu machen zum Beispiel beim Datenschutz
der ist grundsätzlich super schließlich soll
keiner wissen was genau ich alles
auf dem Klo regel
ja Moment Moment Moment
außer ihr macht das über irgendwelche
Messenger solche Messenger sollen
in Zukunft natürlich nicht verschlüsselt sein
ja also wenn ihr auf dem Klo
in irgendeinem Messenger drüber schreibt
dass das ähm
ja so nicht mehr
ordentlich alles funktioniert
das soll natürlich nicht geschützt sein
das muss natürlich im Klartext lesbar sein
also logisch
der wird längst nicht mehr zeitgemäß umgesetzt
oder das alles was ihr so im Internet macht
Vorratsdaten gespeichert werden sollte
das ist ja auch kein Problem
zu Beginn der Corona Impfkampagne
wollten viele Bundesländer einfach allen über 80 Jährigen
direkt einen Termin zuschicken super Idee
die haben es gerade und das muss ich an der Stelle einfach
nochmal sagen weil es so gut passt
die sind aber selbst daran schuld dass den Scheiß
keiner mehr glaubt teilweise
muss man einfach sagen wie gesagt ihr erinnert euch
vielleicht noch daran
dass am Anfang
und Mitte Corona
da gab es diese Aktion mit
wenn du in ein Restaurant gegangen bist
dass du dich eintragen sollst
ähm
wo du gewesen bist
also wenn du irgendwo essen warst
solltest du dich eintragen wer du bist
mit Ansprechdings und so
und damals hat man gesagt ja
wir machen das rein
um Infektionsketten nachzuvollziehen
und da haben viele Leute mitgemacht
weil es ja auch sinnvoll ist
auch sinnvoll klang
ja ich hab das auch ausgefüllt
und es wurde damals gesagt
diese Daten werden rein zweckgebunden
verwendet zum Nachvollziehen der Infektionsketten
und
was kam ein paar Wochen später raus
die bayerische Polizei hat gesagt
achso jaja
wir haben auch Zugriff drauf
weil wir brauchen das ja auch
ich sag gar nicht mal so sehr dass es
prinzipiell eine schlechte Idee ist
diese Sachen der Polizei zur Verfügung zu stellen
sondern nur
dass man es nicht ankündigen kann
und sagt
nein streng zweckgebunden
und es dann ein paar Wochen später wieder aufweicht
und dann muss man sich auch nicht mehr wundern
wenn danach jemand
herkommt und sagt Leute ich glaub euch nix mehr
und ich bin ja eh der Meinung
dass dieser ganze Aufschwung
von irgendwelchem
Verschwörungsgedöns während Corona
auch zu einem
großen Teil
solchen Sachen geschuldet ist
dass dann viele Leute
die vielleicht eh schon ein bisschen
empfänglich waren für solche Sachen
gesagt haben hey
den offiziellen Quellen kannst du dir
gar nix glauben
ja dann guck ich mir lieber
wie hieß der Typ KenFM oder sowas an
also diese ganze
Geschichte was sich da entwickelt hat
auch diese ganzen Fronten die sich gebildet haben
dazwischen
das ist schon zu einem nicht unerheblichen Teil
auf unsere
sprunghafte
Informationspolitik
und
ja sehr
zweifelhaftes Einhalten
so eigene Rahmenbedingungen geschuldet
natürlich bei allen du hast welche gehabt
die das schon immer gerne gemacht haben aber
viele Leute hat das bestimmt
erst auch dazu gebracht
ja genau Chat die Polizei wollte da auch drauf zugreifen
obwohl man gesagt hat es wird anders gemacht
also das sind so Dinger
kannst du nicht machen und da kannst du dich vor allem nicht danach
beschweren dass dir keiner mehr was glaubt
und genau so wie es sein soll
aber alter Babiba was was
ist denn was
ja das ist mein Twitter Account was ist dein Twitter Account
what
den sie dort sehen ist der neue Kollege
der morgens an der
ok haha lol super funny
kek wait
gefake hier auf
auf Twitch
also mein Chef
schreibt nicht XD
da bin ich mir sicher mein Chef
war zwar früher großer Anime Fan
da gibts auch
da gibts ne geile Story zu
das muss ich euch erzählen
das hast du doch vorhin geschrieben
alter what the fuck
ähm da gibts
ne lustige Story zu und zwar
wir hatten mal vor
zig Jahren ist schon ewig her
hatten wir ne neue
Videokonferenzanlage
und das war
wie hieß das von Tandberg
oder so das gehört jetzt Disco mittlerweile
ähm so das war
ein äh
Videokonferenzanlage
und da ging es darum das sollte getestet werden
Mr Moogle im Dankeschön für den Sub
das soll getestet werden und die Leute waren nicht in der Lage
da mal irgendwie nen Videocall zu machen oder so
und ähm
damals wie gesagt mein Chef ist
äh Riesen Anime Fan
und damals hat er gesagt
wartet mal ich hab ein bisschen
Videomaterial dabei
äh womit wir zumindest mal den Fernseh
testen können ja
und
hat er das reingemacht
nein nein nein Chat kein Hentai Zeug
also ganz ganz normales
ganz normales Zeug
und da hat er das reingemacht
und das war dann halt mitten
in irgendeinem Anime wo sie halt
übelst rumgeschrien haben
und dann mit Schwertern auf sich eingekloppt haben
ähm
das hat die Leute damals
ein bisschen verwirrt
so als er das eingeschmissen hat
er hat damals die DVD reingemacht
und es steht dann halt so quasi
Abteilungs- also es steht alle dabei
und wollen die neue Videokonferenzanlage
sich angucken macht er halt die DVD rein
und auf einmal gehts halt los
und übelstes gekloppe
und ihr weißt
ihr wisst doch bei solchen Fight Szenen
wird halt teilweise auch übertrieben rum
rumgeschrien
dann kamen so diese typischen Sachen in Zeitlupe
wo die sich dann 30
Minuten was überlegen
wo in Wirklichkeit eigentlich nur 5 Sekunden
sind und ganz
zumindest waren alle wahnsinnig irritiert
danach als er seine Anime DVD
reingeschmissen hat aber das ist schon
das ist keine Ahnung das ist ja schon
bestimmt 12 Jahre
her heute schockt das kein
mehr
heute ist das ja deutlich mehr Mainstream
aber das war damals
etwas ähm
für viele irritierend ja
so weiter wir gucken jetzt mal fertig
Datenschutz wo hatten wir es denn von
Bundesländer einfach
allen über 80 Jährigen direkten Termin
zuschicken super Idee und genau so wie es sein soll
klingt sinnvoll ja aber einige Länder konnten das nicht
weil sie die Adressen dafür im
Einwohnermeldeamt nicht abfragen durften
der Datenschutz das kenne ich
ich sollte letztens auch bei irgendeiner ich wurde letztens
ausgewählt stand in diesem Brief
1% der deutschen Bevölkerung
wurden ausgewählt
bei irgendeiner Umfrage mitzumachen
musste irgendeine Umfrage beantworten
ähm musste ich mich einloggen in irgendeinem Online
Portal auch mega umständlich
und in dieser
Umfrage wurden ohne Scheiß 90%
der Sachen gefragt die sie eigentlich
schon wissen mussten so
wie groß ist das Haus wie viel
Stockwerke hat das Haus wie viel Zimmer
hat das Haus wie viel Badezimmer
das wissen die alles
aber das musste ich nochmal ausfüllen
Deutschland folgt nämlich
dem Primat der Einwilligung
das ist kein Affe obwohl ich super
fände wenn das ein Affe wäre Primat der Einwilligung
heißt das jeder selbst entscheidet
wie und wofür seine Daten erhoben werden
das hat super funktioniert
in einer Welt in der es kein Internet gibt
das ist ja prinzipiell auch nicht verkehrt
und man nur alle 3 Jahre mal eine Zeitschrift abonniert
während wir also
irgendeinen Martin der bei Facebook arbeitet
mitlesen lassen
das ist ja prinzipiell ist das ja auch ok
wenn wir eine Affäre mit Saskia haben
und auf Sex mit Tauchermasken stehen
dürfen Leute die für den Staat arbeiten
für Leute die wir gewählt haben
nicht mal ins Telefonbuch gucken
warum wissen
naja nur weil ich jemand gewählt habe
will ich nicht dass der meine Facebook
Messages lesen können soll
und mal ganz davon abgesehen
der Unterschied ist du stimmst
bei Facebook ja sogar zu
dass die das mitlesen dürfen
und die Leute machen es trotzdem
der Zuck darf mitlesen
ja
das ist das sogenannte Privacy Paradox
Menschen sind so überfordert
von all den Datenschutz Popups
die Leute haben schlicht und ergreifend keinen Plan
überall zustimmen
einfach nur um weiter in Ruhe auf dem Klo sitzen zu können
Entschuldigung ich bin dein Cookie
Kann ich wissen wo du wohnst?
Was ist deine Schuhgröße?
Verrätst du mir deinen letzten Traum?
Ist es ok wenn ich dich die nächsten 100 Tage beobachte
und verfolge
Nein zu allem
Nein zu allem geht nicht
Dann kann ich dich hier nicht weiter gehen lassen
Ja also dann nur so viel wie nötig ist
Gut dann gehen wir alles einzeln durch
Darf ich in deinem Müll herumwischen?
Nein
Ich verkauf selbst geschmierte Stühle im Abo
Die ersten drei sind umsonst
Monka S was ist das?
Wir erfinden ständig Dinge die für große Veränderungen stehen
Aber wenn wir sie dann in den Händen halten
kriegen wir plötzlich Angst
Ich mein was haben wir Deutschen nicht alles erfunden
Den ersten echten Elektro-Pkw
Das MP3 Format
Wir haben den ersten programmierbaren Computer gebaut
Wir hatten im späten 19. Jahrhundert Elektro-Fahrräder
Wir haben schon in den 50ern
geschmolzenen Käse mit Ananas und Schinken kombiniert
Ja stimmt
Ich mein wir haben
Wir haben ziemlich ziemlich viel
Röntgengeräte
Zum Beispiel ja
Und solche Sachen
Haribo haben wir übrigens auch erfunden
Genial
Alles Hammer Innovation
Was draus gemacht haben aber nicht wir
Sondern meist die Amis
Sogar in der Bundesstadt haben die nach unserem Toast benannt
Die schlauen Leute
Aus dem Gutachten
Oh ich hasse das wenn Leute schwätzen und fressen dabei
Alter
Wir haben in Deutschland ein
Status Quo Bias
Uns schmerzt der Verlust
Den ein Verhaltenswechsel mit sich bringen würde
Mehr als der Gewinn
Der sich daraus ergibt
Selbst wenn er viel größer wäre
Und manchmal sind die Ängste
Die wir einer neuen Technik gegenüber haben
Auch völlig unbegründet
Im öffentlichen Dienst zum Beispiel
Müsste kein einziger Mitarbeiter
Und keine einzige Mitarbeiterin
Wegen der Digitalisierung um seinen oder ihren Arbeitsplatz fürchten
Na gut
Dass wir ein bisschen technikfeindlich sind
Hab ich ja am Anfang auch schon gesagt
Zum einen sind die meisten eh verbeamtet
Zum anderen fehlen in den deutschen Behörden
Schon über 300.000 Beschäftigte
Tendenz steigend
Ein digitaler Staat würde also
Nicht nur uns einfachen Leuten auf dem Klo helfen
Sondern auch den Apparat selbst anlassen
Apropos
Hier ist übrigens mein Klo
Wollt ihr mal sehen
Tada
Wenn das mit der Digitalisierung klappt
Muss ich die Toilette nie wieder verlassen
Okay
Es ist ja durchaus was dran
Was er gesagt hat
Das Videoformat fand ich persönlich jetzt relativ unlustig
Aber Geschmackssache
Digitalisierung
Ich bin bereit
Ja das was er gesagt hat hat schon Hand und Fuß
Das ist bei uns echt
Ja wie gesagt
Wir müssen ja in Gigabit denken
Seit 2017 schon
Also ich denke schon lange in Gigabit aber
Es ist nicht zu denken bei mir aktuell
Denkt ihr auch schon in Gigabit Leute
Die kenn ich ja
Die ist ja auch schon 5 Jahre alt oder so
Der ist wirklich gut
Der macht gute
Also
Wir hatten uns ja damals vor 2 Jahren oder so
Die
Letzte Präsentation von
Herr Grisel angeguckt
Als die neu war
Der hatte ja 3 Sachen
Der hat das mit Spiegel
Im Scan
Und was war das letzte was wir zusammen
Angeguckt haben das habe ich vergessen ehrlich gesagt
Ich weiß nur noch das Schlusswort
Ach das Bahnmining
Genau richtig
Mit der Pofallerwende
Richtig mit der Bahn
Korrekt
Ich fand nur noch das Schlusswort
Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern
Das Schlusswort fand ich gut
Weil er sich da ein bisschen über die aktuelle Empörungskultur aufgeregt hat
Wo er gesagt hat
Erst mal wieder ein bisschen was Faktenbasiertes zu bringen
Anstatt sich die ganze Zeit zu empören
So sinngemäß das fand ich
Das habe ich mir gemerkt das ich das Outro von dem Vortrag
Recht gut fand
Aber ja das war das Bahnmining
Was haben wir noch noch
Reicht durch das eigene Startup
So viel Geld verdient ein Aktienexperte
Also Startup Leute
Verdienen erst mal wenn das Startup noch startet
Nix
So gut wie nix
Vielleicht verdient er was
Weil er krasser Aktienexperte ist
Das kann sein
Das wurde mir vorgeschlagen als neustes Video
WTF warum
Nö die Schaffnerin ist als letztes
Es wurde vorhin
Wurde mir das empfohlen als neues Video
Also Schaffner ist auch was
Das würde ich ihm wirklich
Im Leben nicht machen
Den Jäger haben wir auch schon geguckt
Das Jägervideo hat mich ja ein bisschen verstört
Als der das
Reh erschossen hat
Und dem Reh danach
Noch einen Zweig in den Mund gelegt hat
Da hab ich auch gedacht
Was ist mit euch los
Das war neu als ich das Tab geöffnet hab
Das kann sein
Hattest du schon den BMW Ingenieur
Gibt es nicht
Aber wahrscheinlich
Als Automatisierungsmechaniker
Ich glaube den hatten wir auch schon
Ich glaube wir hatten die alle schon
Bis auf die Schaffnerin hatten wir nicht
Und den Schulleiter hatten wir glaube ich auch nicht
Oh komm wir gucken uns ein bisschen Fireship an
Was ist da neues
Gibt
Kann man sonst noch
Weg
Well
Watt
Quatsch wen juckt es
Hugh
Nicht huge Hugo
Was haben wir denn sonst noch
Massive
Weg brauchen wir auch nicht
Kann man sonst noch
Ja wir gucken noch eine Runde Fireship
Wo ist es denn jetzt
Da
Fireship
Richtig richtig guter Channel hat
Das ist eines der Channel wo ich sagen kann
Ja ich verstehe warum er 1,5 Millionen Abos hat
It is August 18th 2022
And you're watching the code report
One of the most difficult decisions of a frontend developer's life
Is choosing between frontend UI frameworks
Because once you get jumped into a gang
It's really hard to get out
Leute in welcher Frontend Chat
In welcher Frontend Gang seid ihr
Es gibt zur Auswahl
Ich mach ne Umfrage Sekunde
Ich mach ne Umfrage
Oh
In welcher Frontend Gang seid ihr
Was haben wir zur Auswahl
Angular
Svelte
Ähm
View
React
Eins kann ich noch machen
Was braucht man sonst noch
Keine
Keine Ahnung was das ist
Okay
Also in welcher Frontend Gang seid ihr
Angular
Warum ist das so weit vorne
Was ist da los Chat
Ich würde mal sagen nicht nur Backend Leute
Ich würde mal sagen die meisten haben wahrscheinlich gar keine Ahnung von
Um was es da eigentlich geht
Ist nicht jeder hier Programmierer oder Entwickler
Oder Admin oder Cloud Architekt
Five Head High IQ
Also
Es hält sich tatsächlich
Relativ in Grenzen
Relativ ähnlich alles verteilt
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich erwartet
Dass wir
Warte mal bis es fertig ist
Also ich hätte jetzt eigentlich erwartet
Das React relativ weit oben ist
Weil das nach wie vor das verbreitet
So ein bekanntes ist
Das Svelte unten ist hätte ich mir gedacht
Das ist ja noch relativ neu
Also ich hätte ehrlich gesagt mit gerechnet
React
View Angular Svelte
Aber okay
Finde ich gut weil View ist ein gutes Framework
Svelte ist auch ein gutes Framework React kann ich nichts zu sagen habe ich nicht viel mit gemacht
Macht Angular fasse ich ihn nicht an
Die meisten wissen nicht um was es geht
Was auch vollkommen in Ordnung ist
So also Fireship
Wo bist du?
Auf geht's
Klar sind Frontend Web Developer Programmierer
Selbst
Ich sehe das eh nicht so eng
Selbst Leute
Die paar Bash Skripte zusammen gewurschtelt haben
Um ihren Server zu automatisieren
Das sind für mich Programmierer
Warum sollte ein Bash Skript kein Programm sein
Ich verstehe diese ganze Diskussion
Ja das ist halt Programm
Das ist ein Skript
Das ist doch im Prinzip genau das gleiche
Du hast eine Sprache in der du deine Logik mittels Schlüsselwörter
Und vordefinierter Syntax
Abbildest
Ob das jetzt irgendwas geskriptet ist
Oder was programmiert ist
Dann kompiliert ist und dann ausgeführt
Die Übergänge sind heutzutage eh fließend
Und
Macht im Prinzip keinen Unterschied
Das ist alles Programmieren
Manche machen auch gerne Lochkarten
Ja
Das ist halt sehr schwammig
Heutzutage
Es ist Programmieren
Naja Skripten ist Programmieren
Programmieren ist für mich das übergeordnete
Aber das ist die Diskussion finde ich teilweise
Bescheuert
Das kommt wahrscheinlich noch aus Zeiten
Wo Backend Entwickler sich geiler fühlen wollten
Als Frontend Entwickler
So nach dem Motto wie du machst hier nur Frontend JavaScript
Haha lul ich mach Backend Java
Ich bin viel geiler
Ich weiß es nicht
Ist es kompiliert oder wie auch immer
Kann man bei Python auch nur schwierig beantworten
Standardmäßig ist es
Ich sag mal
Minimal vorkompiliertes
Interpretiertes Zeug
Oder
Minimal voroptimiertes
Interpretiertes Zeug
Ansonsten kannst du Python
Allerdings selbstverständlich auch
Mit einem Zwischenschritt nach C++
Übersetzen und dann kompilieren geht auch
Performance Wunder darf man halt trotzdem nicht erwarten
Zumindest wenn man
rein im Python unterwegs ist. Wenn man jetzt
einfach Python quasi als Wrapper um irgendwelche
C-Libraries verwendet, dann sieht das anders aus.
Tja, so, wir gucken jetzt
das Video fertig. Hier, Frontend-Gang.
Multipage-Applications.
Ist es nicht vollkommen normal
für Webseiten mehrere
Webseiten, also
mehrere Seiten zu haben?
Aber mal gucken, er wird es uns jetzt gleich
erklären, ja.
Ich beantworte das hier gleich, alles Chat,
aber erstmal gucken wir das Video fertig, das ist nur so kurz.
Wie soll ich ohne Javascript diese Komponenten
sinnvoll im Browser ausführen? Aber kommt wahrscheinlich gleich.
... while using your favorite Javascript framework
or multiple frameworks at the same time.
But you might be wondering, how does a component work?
If it doesn't have its Javascript with it?
The answer is, it doesn't. It's just static
HTML by default. However, if you
do need interactivity and state, you can
opt into Javascript as needed to add
islands of interactivity to your website.
From a developer's perspective, Astro...
Ah, verstehe. Also sprich,
der rendert das einmal komplett
serverseitig, schickt es dir und dann hast du
quasi den initialen State,
hast du dann serverseitig gerendert
von deinem Counter
und wenn du Client Load schreibst, irgendwie
wird dann der Javascript noch
nachgeschickt oder so und dann wird's
interaktiv, nachdem die Seite komplett geladen ist.
Boah, das stelle ich mir aber nochmal doppelt,
dreifach umständlich vor.
Ah ja, Hydrate ist so das
Fachwort dafür. Das hat sich mal
irgend so ein krasser Javascript-Hackerman
ausgedacht. Das nennt man Hydration.
Wenn man serverseitig was rendert,
den State einpackt,
an Client schickt und der Client macht dann weiter.
So dieses State einpacken,
an Client schicken, Client lädt den
State und macht dann weiter. Das nennt man Hydration.
Ich weiß nicht, was es mit wirklich
Hydration, aber man nennt's halt so.
Wenn man es sofort laden will, wie normal,
nutzt man Client Load. Aber wenn man den Komponent nicht
direkt interaktiv machen muss, kann man auch
Idle nutzen, um zu warten, bis der Browser
chillt, oder Visible, um zu warten, bis der Komponent
in den Viewport kommt. Unter dem Hügel
benutzt Astro eine Technik, die
Partial oder Selektiv Hydration nennt,
um Komponenten in Platz zu rendern, als dass
der ganze DOM überwacht. Das ist ein riesiges
Deal, wenn es um Leistung geht. Weniger Javascript
zu runnen, bedeutet, dass es schneller wird,
und besser Zeit für interaktive
Scores. Das ist großartig, aber Astro
kann viele Dinge außer dem typischen
statischen Site Generator machen. Wie Next.js
kann es statisch dynamische Routen generieren,
indem man eine Funktion für
GetStaticPaths definieren kann.
Aber wenn man nicht alle
Routen prerenderen will,
das finde ich vom Ansatz her gar nicht schlecht.
Eigentlich eine gute Idee.
...Pages, kann es auch
voll Server-Seite Rendering handeln. Das bedeutet,
dass deine Pages bei Request-Zeit generiert werden,
und es ist auch möglich, dedizierte
API-Routen zu machen. Aber mit vollem SSR muss es
an einen Server deployiert werden, und kann
auf NoJS oder The Edge runnen, mit Plattformen wie
Cloudflare, Netlify, Vercel und so weiter.
Das klingt gar nicht so gut.
Wenn du mein letztes Video gesehen hast,
ist die eine Veränderung, die ich gemacht habe,
dass es nicht möglich ist, aus der Box
Klient-Seite Routen zu machen. Es ist anders als
etwas wie Next.js, das volle Hydration macht,
wo der Klient-Seite Router nach dem
initialen Page-Load überwacht. Mit Astro
bekommst du eine völlig neue Page für jede
Navigation. Das könnte ein Problem sein, wenn du
planen möchtest, Daten oder Status zu teilen,
zwischen Route-Changes. However, I discovered
there is a project called Astro SPA
that addresses this exact issue, although
it's not yet a stable part of the framework.
I also made a Meme-Framework to help with this,
and shout-out to everybody who's contributed,
to make that library better.
Was?
Flamethrower?
Nee, JS wahrscheinlich, oder?
Blazingly fast
Router for Static-Site!
Okay, da...
Meme-Framework... Alter, 1,9...
1.900 Sterne!
Ich glaube, ich...
war wert, sich anzugucken.
Mal gucken.
Python 8c ist schnell, wenn es eigentlich
eine C-Library ist, die du nur aufrufst.
Wenn du Python nach C übersetzt
und dann kompilierst, ist es auch nicht schnell.
Klar, gibt doch jede Menge Sachen,
die du Backend verwenden kannst.
Du kannst Java im Backend verwenden.
Du kannst, je nachdem, ob das
dir liegt oder das magst,
Go im Backend verwenden.
Du kannst Ruby on Rails
im Backend verwenden.
Du kannst Python im Backend verwenden.
Wobei, ich hab persönlich, ehrlich gesagt,
Python nicht so die schöne
Backend-Sprache finde.
Aber das ist sicherlich Geschmackssache.
Ich bin halt C-Sharp-Fan.
Wo ich weiß, wo was ist.
Ja, ich weiß das halt.
Du kannst JavaScript benutzen
als Backend-Sprache.
Oder TypeScript als Backend-Sprache.
Du kannst theoretisch sogar C++
als Backend-Sprache benutzen.
Aber ob man das will...
Ja.
Lass ich mal offen.
Kannst du aber machen.
Da gibt's auch so neue Sachen wie...
Wie hieß dieses
nach JavaScript kompilierte
Lisp-Zeug?
Elixier oder so?
Nee, Elm. Elm gab's dann dann noch, oder?
JS.
Elm. Und dann gab's dann noch...
Wie hieß das andere?
Wie hieß das andere,
was eine Zeit lang auch noch angesagt war?
Nicht Elm, sondern...
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Nee, nicht Erlang.
Carbon. Na, Carbon ist das...
Dieser Versuch von Google,
C++-kompatibel zu sein.
Also, ich glaube nicht,
dass sich Carbon groß durchsetzen wird.
Start? Nimm?
Nee, das meine ich alles nicht.
Vielleicht meinte ich auch Elm.
Nee.
Nee, Elixier meinte ich.
Gibt's ja auch noch.
War auch in letzter Zeit recht angesagt.
Ja, das für alle funktionalen...
Für alle funktionalen Fans.
Pipeline Operator.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Kackel.
Aber, wie gesagt,
ich mag C-Sharp, ich mag ASP.NET Core
fürs Backend.
Ist eigentlich mein Abstand.
Lieblings-Framework.
Und Sprache.
Also, für mich ist die...
Also, meine Lieblingskombination ist eindeutig
JavaScript Frontend mit Vue oder Svelte
und .NET.
Backend.
Ja, wenn man hart drauf ist, kann man sein Backend
auch mit Rust machen, aber da wüsste ich nicht,
warum man das machen sollte.
Oder mit Lua oder so.
Lass mal ein eigenes Frontend-Framework entwickeln.
Ist klar.
Das letzte, was ich machen will,
wahrscheinlich ist ein eigenes JavaScript-Frontend-Framework.
Erstens habe ich viel zu wenig Ahnung davon.
Und zweitens werden jeden Tag schon
50 neue Frameworks erfunden.
Jetzt müssen wir nicht auch...
Kek... Kek-JS.
Nee, nicht Keks. Kek-JS.
Das gibt's bestimmt schon.
Was auch immer ich da jetzt öffne.
Kek-JS, okay.
Kackel.
Kackel. Keckel.
Keckel-JS.
Kek-W-Bot.
Ha! Guck mal!
Serious Mark Keks-W.
Kek-W ist das erste, was man da findet,
wenn man Kek-W-JS sucht.
Alles klar.
Kek-W, okay.
Es gibt eine GitHub...
Okay, hier weißt du auch schon, was los ist.
Kek-W-420.
GitHub-Action to randomly laugh at people
who open an issue
on your repository.
Rest in peace.
Kitas, ja.
Kann man nur sagen.
Sehr gute GitHub-Action.
Die brauchen wir unbedingt.
Da machst du ein Pull-Request auf
und es kommt als Antwort erstmal...
Ach, der Typ heißt Kek-W-420.
Das könnte ein GitHub-Name von mir sein.
So random, wie der ist.
Partial Hydration ist so das letzte Stück,
welches Svelte fehlt.
Weiß ich, ob Svelte-Kit irgendwie sowas einbauen will?
Ach so, Astro heißt das.
Astro-JS.
Okay.
PHP.
Ja, PHP hab ich ja ganz vergessen.
Selbstverständlich kannst du natürlich auch PHP benutzen.
Für Backends der Klassiker.
Oder in Holy See.
Warum macht man denn sowas?
CoffeeScript.
Oh, das gibt's noch.
Backend nur in Assembler.
Alles klar, ja.
Das wird witzig.
Socket-Programmierung über Assembler.
Also ich meine,
das ist natürlich ganz klar plattformabhängig.
Aber...
Eh gut, Rust ist wichtig.
Rust musst du immer reinschreiben.
Written in Rust.
Placingly fast written in Rust.
Musst du dran schreiben.
Okay.
Äh...
Das muss ich mir jetzt angucken.
Hello World Linux Assembly.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Webserver.
Socket-Programmierung über Assembly.
Ich glaub nicht, dass das jetzt irgendjemand geben will.
Also CoffeeScript, weiß ich gar nicht, ob das noch aktiv weiterentwickelt wird.
Atom war ursprünglich...
Atom, wie die coolen Leute sagen.
War ja ursprünglich CoffeeScript.
Anscheinend wird das noch weiterentwickelt, ja.
Aber ich bin damit nie warm geworden.
Ich fand's am Anfang cool, weil ich Ruby-Fan war.
Moin Twinko.
Ich war ja...
Also...
Ich hab ja gerne Ruby programmiert.
Und CoffeeScript ist relativ ähnlich gewesen zu Ruby.
Aber...
Ich hab mir relativ schnell schon gedacht, Leute, was soll der Mist?
Warum nicht einfach JavaScript verwenden?
Moin Patrick, auch am Start.
Aha.
Okay.
Peng!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
inspired by cube world github account haben die einen haben die sowas auf
github das ist was anderes ja 2,6 k 2600 sterne daily comets hat minecraft
eigentlich eine vernünftige engine minecraft gibt es ja zwei varianten es
gibt den c++ flavor und den java flavor ich stelle es mir sehr abartig vor so
was in rust zu programmieren muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen world source
keine ahnung layer rock scatter also muss ja sagen rust ist auch nicht gerade
die lesbarste sprache wenn man sich das hier mal anguckt also
rust zu schreiben ist einfacher als zu lesen das ist tatsächlich so
ja finde ich auch allerdings muss das irgendwann selbst wieder lesen und dann
wird es natürlich schwierig wenn du für frontend gerne sowas wie judaswelt benutzt
dann nur das framework frontend oder ich benutze gerne das weltkit tatsächlich
aber ich verwende das hauptsächlich für den router und habe oftmals die
client-side server-side rendering sache aus kann man ja global ausschalten
i bought every playstation ever schön für ihn
richtig
also mein corona ist mehr oder weniger vorbei also ich bin jetzt am samstag
schon wieder ganz normal meine zwei stunden hier durch die berge gelaufen
und ich muss ab und zu noch ein bisschen random husten und bisschen merke ich
vielleicht aber ich rieche wieder normal glaube ich zumindest ich schmecke wieder
normal also ich denke das meist also ich denke mal zu 90 prozent ist es weg da
wird nichts long was ist aus diesem hyper pixel
das ist eine gute frage ja was ist eigentlich daraus geworden
das ist das hyper pixel wie ist das high pixel das ist in minecraft server
hightail ist dass das daraus geworden release 2023 auf jeden fall viele minute
tatsächlich das scheint noch unter development zu sein aber ich finde das noch nicht so gut.
development zu sein was ist eigentlich beim jugendwort
rausgekommen der top ten das wissen wir schon das
wissen wir doch schon ich meine das einzige was davon eigentlich geht ist ja
tatsächlich der rest gefällt mir nicht aber ich bin ja auch nicht mehr der
richtige für jugendwörter mit 38 soll das sein das kann ich mir gerade in der
forschung angucken das welt geht dann kürzlich die datei struktur geändert
wirklich von wasser von von wien nach wie okay was ist das was wird hier
gepostet anders wird du willst in die gomme mode erkennt sofort wenn etwas
hass ist und du wirst zum macher wenn du eine bodenlose aktion siehst haben wir
genau den richtigen job für dich der auch noch richtig ist
cringe ja der bosco hätte gewinnen sollen finde ich auch was wer hat was
von c sharp in c++ umgeschrieben warum macht man dann so was richtig
cringe hightail kein wunder dass das so ewig dauert bis es rauskommt
los error layout page what monka ist okay das muss man mal
angucken so leute ich würde sagen wir schon noch
gewesen doch oder kann ich mir so schlimm sein
ich esse jetzt was ich habe hunger max wirst du auch zum macher wenn du eine
bodenlose aktion sie ist ja das ist mehr suspekt wenn ich bodenlose aktionen
sehe ich habe neue programmiert stream geplant also eigentlich also nächstes
wochenende machen wir hetzner hetzner sponsor stream mit
über neues ip feature und stehen aber noch schreiben die woche über machen wir
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen avalon ja ui oder oder die oder erst mal die
grundlagen ist die sharp und die rast suchmaschine integration zusammen
das wollte ich jetzt sagen ja es hängt von ab also ich ich wollte ja noch zu
dieser zu dieser ddos news heute ein video aufnehmen quasi das war ich am
anfang des streams erzählt hat ein bisschen schön für youtube verpackt weil
youtube mag es nicht dass man so ein video aufnehmen kann weil youtube mag es nicht weil youtube mag es nicht weil youtube mag es nicht weil youtube mag es nicht
aus irgendwelchen gründen videos über ddos angriffe die haben immer 40 50.000
aufrufe ich weiß nicht so genau warum aber youtube mag das und die zuschauer
mögen das auch also werde ich mal ein bisschen der it allgemeinwissen
verbreiten was das angeht die zehn minuten video oder so keine ahnung wobei
das knapp wird normalerweise lade ich immer bis spätestens 15 30 hoch er ist
ja kein hacking video der nur ein info video über was was jemand anderes
gehackert hat gehackerman hat ja ich glaube auch dass es echt so ist jeder
hat schon was von dir ich mein sogar die ganzen montana black und elotrix fans und
so kennen das weil bei dem letzten bei diesem letzten was waren das black ops
turnier was sie da veranstaltet haben haben ja auch irgendwelche helden wieder
die die spiele server ddos und das turnier konnte nicht richtig stattfinden
das ist eine sache das verstehe ich auch nicht ja
die haben so viele leute am start die müssen doch ein paar halbwegs fähige
leute am start haben dass man diesen sachen besser vorbeugen kann
ich meine so einen du musst doch nicht so einen black ops server für den turnier
mit 20.000 zuschauern und was weiß ich wie viele hundert spielern musst du doch
nicht beim letzten klitschen haus da für 1 50 im monat laufen lassen sollen die
das mal bei einem gescheiten haus da laufen lassen sollen das bespielen
bespielen sollen das mit dem im vorfeld besprechen die sollen sagen guckt mal
wir wollen hier und hier ein turnier machen wir fürchten ddos angriff oder
aber sie sollen gleich das falls das irgendwie gescheit möglich ist mit der
server software das irgendwo in der cloud laufen lassen mit ordentlicher
application firewall und filter davor was dann aber halt im zweifelsfall auch
ein bisschen was kostet also wenn das mal irgendwelche eine fähige nenn ich mal
eine abteilung ist das falsche wort aber
irgendeine fähige admin gruppe machen würde raus 34 leuten mal wirklich
irgendwelche sinnvolle setup für so einen turnier aufsetzt dann passiert da
auch nix ich weiß nicht wie die das machen keine ahnung wenn natürlich
moderatoren die da ein bisschen was mit am hut haben das nebenbei machen ja dann
wundert mich das nicht aber wenn man mal da zwei drei fähige leute hinsetzen
würde die sich da ein gutes konzept überlegen dann ist eine auch so ein
turnier ohne großartige ddos problematik durchführbar
bin ich mir sicher und wahrscheinlich würden dass die leute wenn du die fragst sogar für relativ
wenig kohle machen weil weil sie weil dir weil er bestimmt weil die leute bestimmt auch fans
haben in diesem bereich man muss es ja nicht übertreiben ja also dass da irgendwie einer
jetzt irgendwie eine mehrere terabyte attacke fährt oder so halte ich jetzt war auch für für
relativ fragwürdig ich gehe mal eher davon aus dass die ihre server bei irgendeinem 0 15 haus
klitsche hausten ohne dass die bescheid wissen und dann leute um die ecke kommen mit mit mit
den billigsten tools ja und das irgendwie abgeschossen bekommen oder oder ja zumindest
zumindest eingeschränkt bekommen ich denke mal wenn du einen wiegarten auch immer relativ guten
anbieter hast mit ein paar sinnvollen regeln dann wird bei solchen sachen gar nichts passieren weil
die leute die dort dedossen sind irgendwelche frustrierten call of duty
kinder die daheim hocken das ist das ist ja nichts großartig koordiniertes geschweige denn
was mit größerem budget dahinter also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass es da viel braucht das
ordentlich über die bühne zu bekommen also was ich also was ich machen würde wenn wenn ich mich
um sowas kümmern würde wären werden paar sachen entweder würde ich mir überlegen ob ich nicht
vielleicht wirklich bei einem größeren cloud anbieter laufen lassen könnte dann mit den
passenden application firewall sachen davor aber wahrscheinlich würde ich zu hetzner gehen ganz
seit vier tagen bei dem cloud machen oder mit dem cloud im nicht
absolut besten fall das ist performant und günstig und ich würde in dem vorfeld bescheid sagen gerade
wenn das ein turnier ist überlegt euch mal dass in turnieren mit 100 mitspielern mit und mit mit
was ihr vorhabt, dann kann man da im Vorfeld
auch schon, da wissen
die, was auf sie zukommt. Und dann
sollte das in der Regel auch funktionieren.
Und du solltest halt, genau,
du solltest halt vielleicht auch nicht den
billigsten Server hinstellen.
Na, also irgendeinen Single-Core
Irgendeinen Single-Core
512 MB Cloud
VM, ne, ist vielleicht nicht
das Sinnvollste, ja.
Hattest du nicht Hunger? Doch, hab ich.
Also ich bin
mir relativ sicher, wenn man das mit ein paar
gescheiten Leuten machen würde,
dann sind solche Turniere ohne
größere Ausfälle möglich.
Man könnte sich beispielsweise auch überlegen,
da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ob das
ja, mit
Call of Duty funktioniert.
Man könnte beispielsweise das Ganze
auch gar nicht public aus dem Internet
erreichbar machen, sondern nur nach
vorhergehender Freischaltung.
Das wäre auch eine
realistische Variante, weil
die Spieler
die du hast, du hast vielleicht
100 Leute, oder sagen wir, du hast vielleicht 200
Leute, die mitspielen. Wenn du das
ordentlich machst, könntest du es
bestimmt auch in irgendeiner Art und Weise, müsste ich mir mal
was Sinnvolles überlegen, ja.
Weil das Internet muss ja nicht
aus der gesamten Welt
auf eine Public-IP von meinem
Gameserver kommen. Das ist ja überhaupt nicht notwendig.
Man könnte das auch
whitelisten, irgendwie.
Müsste ich mir, also
wirklich, also müsste ich mir mal
ernsthaft Gedanken drüber machen. Ich denke, es gibt,
es gibt dort gute Möglichkeiten, wie man das hinbekommt.
Ich glaube aber
einfach, dass
die Leute, die sich darum
kümmern, das schon mit guten Absichten
machen, aber es jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt
ihr
Aushängeschild ist, ja.
Nitrado ganz bestimmt nicht.
Das ist natürlich schon mal eine Hausnummer,
ja.
Das ist natürlich schon mal ein ordentliches Ding.
Die Kiste.
Sowas, ja genau, sowas in der
Richtung. Das müsste man sich, das müsste man
sich dann mal überlegen. Ja genau, an sowas
in der Richtung habe ich gedacht. Entweder
macht man halt Firewall-Regeln
davor. Ich meine, man kann es ja über die Hetzner-AP
auch automatisieren, dass man
wirklich sagt, hey, Zugriff ist
nur erlaubt von diesen IPs.
Was ja kein Ding ist. Ich meine, Leute,
man hat 200 Mitspieler. Die Leute
müssen sich einfach mit ihrem Steam-Account
über eine Webseite authentifizieren oder so
und
dann hast du ihre Public-IP
und schaltest du frei. Da kannst du
sicherlich irgendwas machen. Oder beispielsweise,
die müssen auf einen Discord-Server
und dort bei irgendeinem Bot was eingeben,
weil letztendlich, wenn sie Mist eingeben,
sind sie ja selber schuld. Da können sie halt nicht
spielen.
Also da könnte man mit Sicherheit
sinnvolle Sachen bauen, dass das funktioniert.
Also, ich denke, man könnte
das schön machen, wenn man sich ein bisschen Gedanken macht
im Vorfeld mit Leuten, die Ahnung haben.
Da, ja, da gehe ich schon von aus.
Aber gut.
Weil man kann sich nicht darauf verlassen,
dass wenn man auf Twitter rummeckert,
so nach dem Motto, ah, Alter, was für Arme,
Leute sind das wieder, die hier dedosten müssen
und den Leuten den Spaß verderben, dass das
irgendwie die Leute abschreckt. Das schreckt nicht die Leute
ab. Das lädt die Leute eher noch
ein, dir weiter auf den Sack zu gehen.
Die machen das ja absichtlich,
um dich abzufacken.
Also, das hat keinen Zweck.
Du musst schon ein paar Gegenmaßnahmen
betreiben, betreffen,
dass du nicht funktionierst. Oder, dass es
so aufwendig und teuer wird, dass es sich nicht lohnt.
Klar hilft das. Wir reden doch hier nicht
von irgendeinem Riesen-China-Kirche,
Chinesen-Botnet, wo Leute dahinter
stehen mit massig Kohle. Das sind
irgendwelche
Ex-Call-of-Duty-Kinder,
die das Turnier ein bisschen,
die Turnierbetreiber ein bisschen abfacken wollen.
Da ist ja nichts Organisiertes
großartig dahinter mit größerem Budget.
Die können sich
fünf Minuten billig
DDoS leisten.
Ja, wir reden hier von irgendwelchen Leuten, die eigentlich gar nicht
wissen, was sie machen.
Also,
deswegen denke ich, dass man
hier nicht jetzt die Wahnsinns... Also, man muss
hier nicht sowas auffahren.
Man braucht... Also, mit sowas muss man
hier nicht rechnen bei einem Montana-Black- und
Elo-Tricks-Black-Ops-Turnier.
Sondern mit was deutlich kleinerem.
Naja, wichtig ist, dass das Netzwerk
genug Bandbreite hat, die Requests
abzukönnen. Beziehungsweise, dass das Netzwerk
genug Bandbreite hat, dass
der eigentliche Traffic,
den du haben möchtest, dass das funktioniert,
noch durchkommt. Und da gehe ich
davon aus, da hat Hetzner genug.
Wichtig ist, dass es nicht auf deinem
Server durchkommt. Weil dein Server
wird es wahrscheinlich nicht verkraften.
Unrun-Dead. Dankeschön für den Sub.
So. Leute, ich gehe
jetzt was essen. Danach nehme ich vielleicht das Video
auf. Und je nachdem, wozu ich mich entscheide,
entweder nehme ich das Video auf, vielleicht streamen
wir nachher noch ein bisschen
Broggers-Kram.
Oder ich schaffe das Video
relativ schnell, dann machen wir das auch.
Ansonsten, ja, morgen. Aber morgen muss ich
erstmal Probe fahren gehen.
Ich glaube, man braucht gar kein richtig...
richtigen DDoS-Service. Also, man
müsste... Also, was du machen kannst, ist natürlich
sowas hier, wie die gemacht haben.
Die haben die Google...
Wie heißt die Google? Google Cloud Armor oder sowas
davor. Hat der immer noch
40 Girls im Pool? Wahrscheinlich.
Immer noch. Ja.
20 Zentimeter.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Also, du brauchst... Also, sowas hier kannst du natürlich
machen. Das dürfte aber relativ teuer
werden. Wobei, die
Jungs haben Geld. Wenn schon,
dann richtig. Aber ich glaube, man bräuchte gar nicht...
so eine richtige
Big-Brain-Lösung, wie jetzt bei Google
oder bei Azure oder so. Wahrscheinlich
reicht es, wenn du zu einem Hoster gehst
und dementsprechend sowas machst, wie ich vorgeschlagen
habe, dass man eben die Spieler whitelistet.
Sodass dein Server nicht...
Also, solange dein Server nicht mit einer
Public-IP im
Internet hängt, hat man, glaube ich, schon gewonnen.
Da wissen die Leute ja auch gar nicht, was
sie machen sollen. Ja, man könnte...
Man könnte die... Man könnte beispielsweise
die Spieler freischalten lassen und so.
Da gäbe es sicherlich gute Möglichkeiten.
Machst du eine Webseite,
wo sich ein Spieler mit seinem Steam-Account
anmeldet und dann
hast du seine Public-IP und die schaltest du
frei. Und dann siehst du ja auch relativ
schnell, wenn von einem dieser IPs was
kommt, kannst du die ja relativ schnell blocken.
Ich denke, da wäre gar nicht so viel
großer Aufwand notwendig, sowas
störungsfrei über die Bühne zu kriegen.
Na, das steht und fällt halt damit, dass du ein paar
Admins hast, die...
Naja, sag mal,
ein bisschen Erfahrung haben mit Dingern,
wo ordentlich Traffic drüber läuft.
Ich denke, dass Leute sich
ohne Probleme managen lassen.
Ja, Leute.
Dankeschön für die ganzen Subs heute.
Vielleicht bin ich nachher nochmal am Start.
Aber wir sehen uns. Ich geh jetzt erstmal was futtern.
Ich hab mega Hunger.
4 Stunden, 10 Minuten am Start gewesen.
Für meine Verhältnisse Sonntag schon ausgesprochen lang.
Wir sehen uns. Bis dann, Leute.
Macht's gut. See you.